DOING SOME HOUSEKEEPING.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GO OVER
TODAY'S AGENDA BEFORE WE
FORMALLY KICK OFF THIS SEVEN
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE.
THIS WILL BE OUR LAST COMMITTEE
UNTIL JUNE FIFTH OR WILL BE
RECONVENING WITH ASSEMBLY BILLS.
RAISING GERMAN THERE ARE TWO
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB TWO NINE
FIVE AN ITEM.
SEVENTEEN SB.
SIX TO NINE WE ARE GOING TO BE
PULLING ITEM NUMBER.
SIX SB TWO SEVEN TWO FROM
TODAY'S HEARING.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO HAVE.
LATE AMENDMENTS IN ITEM NINETEEN
SB.
SIX FOUR SIX WHICH WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MOMENTARILY.
OTHERWISE ALL OTHER COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WERE DISTRIBUTED.
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON OR YESTERDAY
EVENING.
WHERE TO START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
HERE TODAY WE'D LIKE TO GET A
WELCOME CENTER GLAZER TO THE
TABLE?
HE'S BRINGING FOR GOOD BILL SB.
TWO FOUR EIGHT WORKING HARD ON
THIS ISSUE SECOND TIME AROUND.
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT CENTER
GLAZERS HERE TODAY.
CENTER FOR END UP WELCOME SIR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
I THANK YOU I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND SO
MANY OTHERS.
YEAH THIS BILL HAS -- HAD A FULL
HEARING SIDE.
LAST YEAR AND IT COMES BEFORE
YOU WITH TWENTY SENATE CO
AUTHORS -- BIPARTISAN BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE JOINING TOGETHER TO
SAY THAT I SB TWO FORTY EIGHT
WOULD PROVIDE LONG OVERDUE
CHANGES. TO THE RENTERS TAX
CREDIT AND PROVIDE FINANCIAL
RELIEF TO TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME RENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE RENTERS TAX CREDIT AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW WAS ESTABLISHED IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO BUT HAS
ONLY BEEN INCREASED ONCE IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE SINCE THEN
RENTS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE TRIPLED.
WHILE THE LEGISLATURE HAS MADE
STRIDES IN EXPANDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
LITTLE HAS BEEN DONE TO PROVIDE
DIRECT FINANCIAL RELIEF TO THOSE
WHO NEED IT THE MOST RENTERS.
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE IMMEDIATE
IMPACT HELPING THOSE IN THE OIL
IN THE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
ARE STRUGGLING WITH THE
SKYROCKETING COSTS OF RENT.
INSTEAD OF DIFFERENTIATING
BETWEEN SINGLE AND JOINT
[inaudible]
FILERS.
THIS BILL WOULD INCREASE THE
CREDIT FOR THOSE WITH THE
PENDANTS MAKING THE CREDIT MORE
HELPFUL AND FAIR TO SINGLE MOMS
DADS AND FAMILIES. FOR THIS BILL
MAKES THE RENTERS TAX CREDIT
REFUNDABLE SO THAT EVEN THOSE
WITHOUT A TAX OBLIGATION CAN
RECEIVE THE BENEFITS OF THE
CREDIT.
ALTHOUGH OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND RANCHERS -- NOW RECEIVE
LITTLE OR NO CREDIT THEY WOULD
BECOME ELIGIBLE UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL.
UNDER THE NEW STRUCTURE SINGLE
AND JOINT FILERS WITHOUT
DEPENDENCE WOULD RECEIVE TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DOLLARS THOSE
WITH DEPENDENTS WOULD RECEIVE
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR DOLLARS.
A SIGNIFICANT AND MUCH NEEDED
INCREASED FROM THE SIXTY AND ONE
TWENTY THAT RENTERS ARE
CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE FOR TODAY.
THE SMART PROGRESSIVE BILL
COMPLIMENTS CALIFORNIA'S LONG
TERM GOALS TO INCREASE AND
EXPAND ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
WHILE TAKE YEARS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN HAVE ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE HOMES THIS BILL
WILL HELP MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS NOW.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
LUIS VERANDA WITH CALIFORNIA MAY.
THIRTY TWO AT A COMMITTEE THANKS
FOR ALL YOUR WORK THIS YEAR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK CENTER GLAZER FOR
OFFERING THIS MEASURE BRING
FORWARD LONG NEEDED REFORMS ON
THE RENTERS TAX CREDIT.
AS THIS COMMITTEE WELL KNOWS
HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S RENTERS PAY
MORE THAN 50% 30% SORRY OF THEIR
INCOME IN RENT NEARLY ONE IN
THREE PAY 50% OF THEIR INCOME OR
MORE.
THESE COSTS OF A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS MANY OF WHOM
STRUGGLE TO AFFORD RENT EACH
MONTH.
SB TWO FORTY EIGHT RETURNS THE
VALUE OF THE CREDIT TO ITS
EFFECTIVE VALUE WHEN IT WAS
ADOPTED IN WELL WHEN I WAS A
AMENDED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE
A COMMONSENSE ADJUSTMENT TO AN
OUTDATED PROVISION OF A VERY
IMPORTANT CREDIT -- IMPORTANTLY --
pACCESS TO THE RENTERS TAX CREDIT
AS YOU HEARD FROM CENTER GLAZER.
IT WILL NOT ONLY DOUBLE THEIR
INTEREST TAX CREDIT FOR THOSE
WITH CHILDREN BY ADDING NEW
PROVISIONS FOR RENTERS WITH THE
PENDANTS.
A GROWING SEGMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION BUT WILL
ALSO MAKE THE CREDIT REFUNDABLE
ALLOWING THOSE WHO DO NOT PAY
INCOME TAX THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO CLAIM THE CREDIT.
CALIFORNIA'S SEVENTEEN MILLION
RENTERS URGENTLY NEED THIS HELP.
FOR THOSE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE THOUGH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL LEADS IN GENERAL BEFORE
WE GO TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT WE
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
WITH GOOD TENDER FROM SAN JOSE
WHO IS HERE LATIN PROUD MISLAID
CHESTER YOU CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WIRES HERE WHY PRESIDENT WARLOCK.
PRESIDENT BELL.
THE PRESIDENT BIRDS BIRD.
AUTO NIELSEN WIENER.
WIENER PRESS.
BASINGER IN THE COMMITTEE A
QUORUM IS BEEN ESTABLISHMENT I
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO WELCOME
ANYONE WHO'S IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD PLEASE STATE YOUR FIRST
AND LAST AN ORGANIZATION WE
WELCOME YOU IN GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING SHERRY MEMBERS KATE
BELL WITH CAPITAL OF DOMESTIC
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT UPON THE AUTHOR FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
GOOD MORNING.
MISTER MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IS HEALTHY HOUSING --
FOUNDATION DIVISION IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING.
BOB MAILER REPRESENTING FEELS
THAT IN COMPANY IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS MOVE TOWARD
MORE EQUITABLE TAX POLICY I
THINK YOUR COMMENTS GOOD MORNING
MA'AM.
MORNING THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS
CHANCES TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING VANESSA GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUPPORT THE RISK IS ALSO GOOD
MORNING.
SUCK IT US ON BEHALF OF CITY OF
SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH GOOD MORNING. TWENTY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
SUFFICIENT HERE TO SUPPORT
[inaudible]
VERY.
PROTECT BETTER DO A LAST CALL
FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
WE NOW WOULD WELCOME ANYONE ELSE
WHO IS IN OPPOSITION TO PLEASE
COME FORWARD OR ANYONE WHO
SQUISHING IN BETWEEN.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
WE'D LIKE TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS CONVERSATION
INDOOR MOTION CENTER ABOUT THE
FLOOR SHORES AND THE DEVICE YEAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER BELT
MISTER VICE CHAIR [inaudible]
PLEASE SIR.
NOT NOT MAYBE TO PROVIDE
OPPOSITE OPPOSITION BUT MAYBE TO
PUSH BACK A LITTLE BIT JUST TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE DOING.
THE RIGHT THING WHY ARE WE
MAKING IT REFUNDABLE.
WELL I THINK THE THROUGH THE
CHAIR -- THE GOAL IS TO HELP
THOSE -- RANCHERS WHO ARE OUR
MOST ECONOMICALLY.
CHALLENGED AND SO WHETHER THEY
HAVE A TAX LIABILITY OR THEY
DON'T HAVE A TAX LIABILITY THIS
IS OUR OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THOSE
AT THE LOWEST END -- THE FTP IS
SAYING YOU'RE PROBABLY COST
ABOUT.
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR -- AS A TAX.
THE EXPENSE AND AND AND I'M JUST
CURIOUS -- THAT COULD PAY FOR A
LOT OF FUN PAYMENT.
WELL WE CURRENTLY PAY A LITTLE
OVER 200-100-0200 MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE CURRENT RENTERS
TAX CREDIT -- WE DON'T HAVE A
FINAL ESTIMATE ON WHAT THE COSTS
WILL BE UNDER THIS -- PROPOSAL
BUT IT'D BE I'D SAY IT'S PRETTY
CLOSE TO FIVE HUNDRED TO SIX
HUNDRED MILLION IS IS IT IS AN
ESTIMATE -- AT CAL A CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY PROVIDES OVER SIX
BILLION DOLLARS AND TAX RELIEF
TO HOMEOWNERS THAT'S UNDER OUR
CURRENT TAX CODE TODAY OVER SIX
BILLION.
WE CURRENTLY A PROVIDING AROUND
TWO HUNDRED MILLION FOR RENTERS.
AND YES INDEED IT WILL GO UP --
BUT CERTAINLY -- FROM AN EQUITY
POINT OF VIEW IT'S IT'S STILL
LOPSIDED AGAINST RANCHERS AT BUT
IT'S GOING TO HELP THOSE WHO ARE
MOST IN NEED AND SO I THINK IT'S
JUSTIFIED AND WE DON'T CERTAINLY
ANY KIND OF BONDING HAVE
INTEREST RATE OBLIGATIONS THERE
TOO SO.
WHAT'S THAT GOING TO THOSE
EQUATIONS OR MAYBE TO TALK ABOUT
THE JOBS ACT -- IN THE JOBSOR
THE TAX CUTS AND JOBS ACT WHICH
WHICH BROUGHT IN SALT THE STATE
LOCAL TAX.
DON'T YOU THINK THAT MIND OF
KINDA GIVEN.
RENTERS A LITTLE EVEN MORE OF AN
EVEN BREAK COMPARED TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP.
I DON'T KNOW.
YOU TELL ME I'M JUST WONDERING
IF THE THE RESEARCH YOU JUST
SITED MIGHT BE A LITTLE OUT
DATED BECAUSE OF THE NEW BILL.
I I DON'T I DON'T THINK ANYTHING
NEW EITHER BECAUSE THEY JUST
THIS IS OUR FIRST YEAR.
BUT I'M I'M JUST WONDERING.
IF IF MAYBE THINGS HAVE KIND OF
EVEN UP A LITTLE BIT OF ALL YOU
CAN DEDUCT THIS TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND YOU'RE NOT REALLY
GETTING A MASSIVE TAX BREAK FOR
OWNING A HOME NOW.
WELL THE THE NUMBERS THAT I I
PROVIDED IN REGARD TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I TAX BENEFITS ARE
DON'T RELATE TO FEDERAL -- TAX
LAWS IT RELATES TO HOW WE TREAT --
HOW HOW WE TREATED AT IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT THE THOSE ARE --
OLDER NUMBERS I I HAVE TO
RECHECK IT BASED ON NOW -- THE
THE FEDERAL RULES AND HOW THAT
AFFECTS THAT TAX CREDIT THAT
THAT WE PROVIDE IN THE STATE.
BUT IT'S A LOPSIDED.
I IT'S IT'S A MASSIVELY LOPSIDED
TODAY I DON'T KNOW IF IT WOULD
THAT THAT YEAH HOW MUCH IT WOULD --
STRAIGHT OUT I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE SUGGESTING THAT SOMEHOW
IT MIGHT BE EVEN BUT I THINK OF
YOUR SUGGESTION IS THERE COULD
BE MORE UPDATED NUMBERS -- I
THINK THAT'S A GOOD ONE AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO CHECK ON THAT.
WITH THAT I KNOW I GUESS ONE OF
MY LAST QUESTIONS WOULD BE THEN.
INSTEAD OF JUMPING THREEFOLD
MAYBE WE'D BE PHASED IN OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME.
YEAH I THINK THAT'S AN OPTION --
IN THE IN THE IN THE LEGISLATION
LAST YEAR I PROPOSED A FIVE YEAR
PHASE IN -- AND AT AT THE START
OF THIS BILL THIS IS THE FIRST
POLICY HEARING I'M COMING BACK
AND SAYING IF WE STARTED ALL AT
ONCE HERE'S THE BENEFITS THAT
WOULD COME FOM IT -- I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT -- AS AT IT THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD TODAY AND
GOES FORWARD THROUGH THE SENATE.
THE DOES THE TYPES OF
CONVERSATIONS THAT WERE LIKELY
TO OCCUR -- AS IT MOVES FORWARD
IN TERMS OF WHAT COULD WE AFFORD
TODAY THERE ARE OFF FRANCE
WITHIN THIS LEGISLATION.
THE GOVERNOR TO BECAUSE CALL
PAUSE -- BECAUSE OF ECONOMIC AID
ISSUES SO THAT'S THIRTY BILL TEN
BUT I'M I'M OPEN MINDED TO
MAKING SURE THAT WE MAKE IT
AFFORDABLE WITHIN OUR BUDGET
FRAMEWORK.
BUT ALSO -- ACCELERATES OUR
COMMITMENT TO HELPING OUR
POOREST RENTERS [inaudible]
WROTE.
TODAY WE HAVE A LOT OF BILLS
WERE WERE DISCUSSING TAX CREDITS
EVEN THE WHOLE PHILOSOPHY OF
RESEARCHING.
WHAT WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING SO
I'M?
I'M I'M SITTING HERE TRYING TO
FIGHT.
THIS YOU KNOW I SHOULD BE ANTI
TAX.
PHILOSOPHICALLY WITH HOW DO I
PAY FOR PENSIONS AND RETIREE
MEDICAL AND IT'S IT'S IT'S MAY
FIRST AND THE STATE HASN'T
RELEASED ITS.
AUDITED FINANCIAL STATEMENTS FOR
JUNE THIRTIETH [inaudible]
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND I HAVE THIS
FUNNY FEELING WHEN WE GET THE
NEWS IT'S GONNA BE PRETTY.
AWFUL IF YOU ADD NINETY ONE AND
A HALF BILLION OF RETIREE
MEDICAL.
TO OUR UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT
THAT'LL PUT AS UNDER WATER
QUARTER TRILLION DOLLARS ON OUR
BALANCE SHEETS I'M.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO
I BALANCE TRYING.
TO FIX A BALANCE SHEET WITH YOU
KNOW GIVING TAX CREDITS.
AS AS WONDERFUL AND IS.
YOU KNOW AS MUCH SENSE AS THEY
MAKE I'M TRYING TO FIGURE THAT
OUT SO I GUESS MISTER CHAIR THAT
THE QUESTION BE THAT THIS WOULD
OBVIOUSLY GO TO APPROACH NEXT.
RIGHT AND IN DOES APPROACH USED
THE LA OVER HOW TO YOU KNOW
WHO'S WHO IS RIGHT NOW LOOKING
OVER.
HOW IT ALL FITS IN HOW WE
PREPARE?
OUR BUDGET I'VE.
YEAH I KNOW I IN I THINK THE
VICE CHAIR -- BRINGS UP A POINT
OF LOOK.
WE MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS IT WILL
BE CONSULTING WITH.
THE PREPARATIONS CHAIR -- A AND
HIS VERY CAPABLE STAFF ON THIS
ISSUE.
I KNOW THAT DEPARTMENTS FROM THE
MINISTRATION -- IN ALL
THROUGHOUT STATE GOVERNMENT WILL
BE -- CONSULTING -- AND
OBVIOUSLY THE LEGISLATURE.
HAS FULL AUTHORITY OVER BUDGET --
AND AT TIMES THERE MAY BE
DISAGREEMENTS ON HOW TO APPROACH
BUDGET DEPENDING ON WHAT SIDE
YOU MAY BE ON AND I THINK ON
THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE CRISIS THAT
WE FACE ACROSS CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY IN THE LOW IN VERY
LOW CATEGORIES -- IT IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY TO BE ABLE
TO ADVANCE VERY MODERN VERY
MODERATE INDIVIDUAL TAX CREDIT.
TO A POPULATION CURRENTLY
DOESN'T SEE A LOT.
OF POSITIVES FROM THIS CURRENT
ECONOMY.
JUST MY OWN PERSONAL PAIN.
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZERS THANK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SERVICE YOU'RE
ALWAYS GRATEFUL FOR THE COMMENTS.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OUR
CONVERSATION FROM COMMITTEE WE
DO A MOTION.
BY CENTER ABOUT CENTER BUT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS
ABOUT THIS SO I THINK -- THERE
HAS TO BE A BALANCE BETWEEN --
MORTGAGE INTEREST DEDUCTION AND
RENTERS TAX CREDIT WHEN WE LOOK
AT THE MAY LIEU OF OF THE PUBLIC
AND AND LOOK AT THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND I THINK.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT --MORTGAGE
INTEREST.
DEDUCTION.
WHICH IS GONE UP WITH THE
INCREASE IN VALUE OF PROPERTY.
OF IN THE PURCHASE OF PROPERTY I
THINK THAT'S OF NOT BEEN
BALANCED BY.
INCREASES IN THE RENTER -- TAX
CREDIT SO IT'S KIND OF A I THINK
WE OUGHTA APPROACHES FROM A
POLICY STANDPOINT ON A LITTLE
BIT OF MISTER CHAIRMAN A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT.
TRADING A PROPER BALANCE IF YOU
WANT TO SET THAT WAY.
AND NOT -- DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
RENTERS AND RIGHT NOW THE
RENTERS.
HAVE NOT RECEIVED -- THE TAX.
OF CREDIT -- FOR AWHILE.
SO IT'S LIKE KIND OF LIKE AN
OVERDUE THING IN MY OPINION.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL I KNOW
IT'S GOING TO BE WORKED OUT IN
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE --
I WOULD ALSO SAY.
THAT I URGE RESTRAINT ON
CONSIDERATION OF OPTIONS LIKE.
BONDS -- I KNOW THERE IS A
EXCELLENT ARGUMENTS AGAINST
BONDS.
THAT WAS -- WRITTEN.
AND I REFER THE CENTER FROM
ORANGE COUNTY TO IT THAT WAS
WRITTEN.
OPPOSING OUR PROPOSITION ONE
LAST YEAR.
EXCELLENT WRITTEN TREATISE
AGAINST BONDING AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PROPOSITION ONE LAST
YEAR.
I SUGGEST THAT -- WE RESTRAIN
OURSELVES ON BONDS USING THAT.
WONDERFUL A TREATISE -- TO GUIDE
US IN OUR DISCUSSION OF BONDS.
SO I HAD AND I WORK FOR HIM TO
THAT.
ARTICLE THAT WAS WRITTEN -- IN
THE BALLOT STATEMENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER MISTER
VICE CHAIR.
MR.
I BELIEVE EIGHT YOU YOU MIGHT BE
REFERRING TO PROP SIXTY EIGHT OF
JUNE.
OF LAST YEAR NOT PROP.
ONE YEAH A QUICK BUT I WROTE A
THE OPPOSITION ARGUMENT FOR PROP
SIXTY EIGHT BACK IN IN JUNE OF
LAST YEAR.
WITH CONCERNS ABOUT THE FINANCES
AND THE REASON I BRING IT UP
LOOK AT BOTH OF THEM.
OKAY -- IS THAT -- YOU KNOW THE
THE THESE BONDS ARE ARE PURSUING
RIGHTEOUS CAUSES WELL BUT
THEY'RE COSTING TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND.
AND SO THAT'S WHY I WAS MAKING
THE POINT THAT -- THE SIX
HUNDRED MILLION IN IT.
IN LAS REVENUE PLUS TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION AND IN A BOND
PAYMENTS AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
WE'RE TALKING REAL DOLLARS SO
THAT'S WHY I BRING IT UP IN.
AND SINCE THE CENTER GLAZER IS
FAMILIAR WITH A GOOD BOND.
OPPORTUNITY THAT HE'S PURSUING I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT THE BIG
PICTURE FROM THE THIRTY THOUSAND
FOOT LEVEL -- AS YOU AND I ARE
ON THE BUDGET.
TRYING TO MAKE SURE EVERYTHING
WORKS.
WE HAVE A GOOD GAME MAKING HIM A
PING PONG GOING LASER JAMMER AND
TURN IT BACK OVER TO CENTER
ABOUT PLEASE MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THINK IF WE HAVE.
A A STABLE FINANCIAL SOURCE FOR
ON GOING ON FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WHICH THIS COMMITTEE HAS ADOPTED --
WITH SOME NEGATIVE VOTES -- I
THINK IF WE PASSED.
ONGOING STABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- WE
WENT NEED TO HAVE A BONDING AND
WE WOULD USE A 100% OF THE MONEY.
FOR THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS AND THAT'S ANOTHER
AVENUE WE SHOULD PURSUE AS IN
ADDITION TO THE RATHER START.
IT'S ALL PART OF A PACKAGE -- I
THINK LAND USE REFORM CENTER
WINNER HAS HIS BILL -- WE HAVE
THE TENNIS RIGHTS BILL -- THIS
BILL AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
FINANCING I THINK IT'S ALL PART
OF A LARGER.
EFFORT TO OF ATTEMPT TO TEACH TO
TAKE ON THE MAJOR CHALLENGE WE
HAVE ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITH
THE SENATE'S WORKING HARD ON
THIS WE ARE TO TO THE WORKING
SUPPORT THIS BILL AS WELL AS THE
OTHERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MAKE SOME QUICK CLOSING COMMENTS --
IN SAY THAT WE HAVE NO SILVER
BULLET.
IT IS GOING TO TAKE MATT
MULTIPLE TOOLS IN OUR BELT TO BE
ABLE TO COMBAT THIS CRISIS.
I THE RENTERS TAX CREDIT IS ONE
OF THEM.
AND CENTER BELL IS SHOWN.
TIRELESS LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND SENATE
BILL FIVE IS ANOTHER -- AND IF
WE ARE GOING TO SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER.
TAX CREDITS FOR MULTINATIONAL
BILLION DOLLAR CORPORATIONS IN
MEASURES HELD SHOULD E FOCUSED
ON TAX CREDITS FOR THE POOREST
CALIFORNIANS.
I AM PUTTING MONEY BACK INTO THE
POCKET AT WHICH IS WHY I THINK
THAT WE SHOULD BE MOVING FORWARD
WITH THIS BILL TODAY WE DO HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR BELL CENTRE
GLAZER WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE A
CLOSE.
LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
WORDS IN SUPPORT AND THANK YOU.
SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE FOR HIS
COMMENTS I DO THINK THIS IS
GOING TO BE A PART OF A PACKAGE
THAT -- WE ALL WORK TOGETHER ON
IT AS WE FINISH OUR LEGISLATIVE
YEAR.
I THANK THE CENTER FROM ALL
ORANGE COUNTY FOR RAISING THE
ISSUE THE BALANCE SHEET I THINK
HE KNOWS THAT I SHARE A LOT OF
HIS CONCERNS ABOUT THAT BROADER
QUESTION -- IT'S BEEN FORTY
YEARS FORTY YEARS SINCE WE
CHANGED THE RENTER'S CREDIT --
AND WHEN YOU TALK TO RENTERS YOU
KNOW THE THE FIRST RESPONSE IS
HEY DUDE.
WHAT'S TAKING YOU SO LONG SO.
I THINK THAT THAT POINT IS WELL
TAKEN THIS PROVIDES A LITTLE
MORE BOUNCE IN OUR TAX POLICY
IT'S GOING TO HELP THE POOREST
OF THE POOR.
IN OUR STATE AT AT A GET AN
IMPORTANT TIME AND WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR AND I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS IS A DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS MOTION
IS LANCHESTER ROLL CALL PLEASE.
THEY'LL.
THEY'LL HYBRIDS BIRD RICARDO
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NIELSEN I WIENER WIENER AYE YEAH.
AT CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR EIGHT
ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THIS
ROLE OPEN IT AND ADD ON AS FOLKS
COMING.
IS IN GERMAN WE HAVE TWO
WONDERFUL AUTHORS WHO ARE HERE --
IT WITH US TODAY WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE SENATOR DODD AND SENATOR
LEYVA CENTER DIED IS ON SB.
TWO SIXTY THREE FOCUS SEEN TAX
CREDITS UNABLE PROGRAM CENTER
DIED YOU DO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THIS ISSUE.
SO THAT WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR
TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
PRESENTATION -- AND ONE ALSO SAY
THANK YOU TO CENTER DOT FOR ALL
THESE FANTASTIC WORK ON THIS
ISSUE THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SB TWO
SIXTY THREE IS A SIMPLE TAX
CONFORMITY BILL -- GIVEN THE
CHAIRMAN'S-- NOT ADMONISHMENT
BUT ADVICE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
SO MUCH I WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE ME AND WELCOME THANK YOU
MELISSA CORTES ROTH ON BEHALF OF
AUTISM SPEAKS AND THE CENTER FOR
AUTISM RELATED DISORDERS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WOULD LIKE TO
GO TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
ABILITY TO PLEASE COME FORWARD
THIS TIME.
GETTING A JOB IN THIS -- GOOD
MORNING SIR MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
JOHN CABOT TECH CALIFORNIA STATE
DIRECTOR THE NFIB NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS.
HERE IN SUPPORT -- THIS WILL
GIVE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS THE
GREATER CERTAINTY CONFORMITY --
AND TO HELP THEM IN THEIR DAY
TODAY SO WE'RE VERY PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY SIR.
THAT THE WELCOME ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT TO PLEASE COME FORWARD
THIS TIME.
LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT.
NOW WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME ANYONE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSED.
WE LIKE REAR BACK TO COMMITTEE
TO BE RECEIVED WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR BY SENATOR BELT
THIS MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS --
FROM THE COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME.
HEARING SEEN NINE WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR BELTON --
MISTER DOT WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
WITH ESCRIBIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS CENTER VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOU
WORK ON THIS THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE MISS LANE
CHESTER GAME PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
HI WHY I'M MORE LOCK.
LOCK AYE BELL WELL I HERTZBERG
FURTADO.
YELTSIN I FEEL SAID I WINNER.
I ALWAYS LIKE CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
FIVE ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN CENTER DIED IN
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
BUT IN GENERAL ARE NOW WELCOME
MEANS SENATOR LEYVA.
FROM THE IN THE NAM EMPIRE TO BE
ABLE TO JOIN US I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
GOOD SENATOR. FOR ALL OF HER
WORK ON ALL ISSUES.
ON PROTECTING.
THE MOBILE HOME PARK RESIDENTS --
IT SHE HAS THIS IS BEEN A
PERSONAL ISSUE FOR HER FOR MANY
MANY YEARS.
THIS IS A GOOD BILL WE DO HAVE
AMENDMENTS IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY.
AND ITEMS -- TWO FIFTY TWO AM
CENTER THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS -- YOU ARE CORRECT
MISTER CHAIR THIS HAS BECOME A
PASSION OF MINE I DID NOT KNOW
UNTIL I GOT HERE BECAME THE
CHAIR OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
MOBILE.
AND MANUFACTURED HOMES HOW MUCH
I WOULD CARE ABOUT MOBILE HOME
PARKS AND THE RESIDENTS WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO MAKE SURE EACH
OF YOU KNOWS HOW MANY MOBILE
HOME PARKS YOU HAVE IN YOUR
DISTRICT. THIRTEEN REQUIRE YOU
ARE OUR WINNER WITH FIVE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE PARKS TWENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN SPACES.
THIRD MORLOCK I SHARE WITH YOU
YESTERDAY IN CASE YOU FORGOT
SIXTY SIX NINE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT CENTER
BELT FORTY SIX WITH.
EARNED SIX THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN SPACES.
SENATOR NIELSEN THREE HUNDRED
AND THREE PARKS WITH EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FOUR SPACES.
AND SCOTT WENER BRINGING UP THE
REAR WITH ONLY FOR PARKS AND SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE SPACES
BUT ALL OF THOSE RESIDENTS
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'RE DOING TO HELP THEM.
UP FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL.
SB TWO FIFTY TWO WOULD CREATE AN
INCENTIVE FOR PRIVATE MOBILE
HOME PARK OWNERS TO SELL THEIR
PARK TO THEIR RESIDENTS A
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ENTITY OR A LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AS WE'RE ALL AWARE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE EXPERIENCING A
SEVERE HOUSING CRISIS DUE TO
LACK OF ALL LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SINCE MOBILE HOMES AND
MANUFACTURED HOMES ARE IMPORTANT
OPTION IN CALIFORNIA WE MUST
STRIVE TO PRESERVE THE AVAILABLE
MOBILE HOMES PARKS STOCK.
SOME NONPROFIT AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PARTNERS ARE INTERESTED
IN MAINTAINING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND PURCHASING PARKS
FROM LONG STANDING BUSINESS
OWNERS.
THERE MAY BE SITUATIONS WHEN
PARK OWNERS DECIDE TO RETIRE.
AND LEAD THE INDUSTRY AND SELL
THEIR PARKS WHEN THIS OCCURS
RESIDENTS FACE STEEP RENT
INCREASES OR DISPLACEMENT WITH
FEW OPTIONS OF WHERE TO MOVE.
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE A
DEDICATION OF CAPITAL GAINS TAX
TO THE PARK OWNER WHO MAY WISH
TO LEAVE THE BUSINESS AND NOT
WANT TO DISPLACE RESIDENTS.
WITH THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THE PARK OWNER WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
41100% OF THE CAPITAL GAINS
EXCLUSION THIS IS A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM FOR THE PARK OWNERS AND
NOT A FORCED SALE.
MEMBERS SB TWO FIFTY TWO HELPS
PROTECT THIS LIMITED STOCK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND KEEPS LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
AND SENIORS OFF THE STREETS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I'VE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ALICIA
SEBASTIAN.
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
RURAL HOUSING SPONSOR AND
REPRESENTS MANY OF OUR NONPROFIT
HOUSING ENTITIES.
AND SUZANNE TAYLOR OF AUGUSTA'S
PROPERTIES MAN SHE MANAGES AND
OPERATES NONPROFIT MOBILE HOME
PARKS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE A
SECOND DAY IN A ROW I
APPRECIATED THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER LEYVA AND AGAIN PRECIADO
YOUR WORK WILL START OUT WITH AT
MISS BASHING THE GO TO MISS
TAYLOR YO HAVE TWO MINUTES --
AND WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT YOU ARE
HERE TODAY AND THANKS FOR
HANGING IN THE CAPITAL OVER THE
LAST FORTY EIGHT HOURS TO FLOOR
IS YOURS TWO MINUTES.
SO MY TO LEASES THE VAST AN
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR REAL
HOUSING.
THING ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION OUR
MEMBERS ARE PREDOMINANTLY
NONPROFIT AND PUBLIC AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS SERVING RURAL
FARM WORKER AND AMERICAN INDIAN
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES BY PULL THE
MICROPHONE A LITTLE CLOSER.
SORRY ABOUT THAT NO WORRIES IN
THE LAST TEN YEARS ALMOST FIVE
THOUSAND MOBILE HOME SPACES HAVE
DISAPPEARED WITH THE RECOVERY OF
THE HOUSING MARKET THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE BEING MARKED BY
OWNERS AND INVESTORS FOR
ACQUISITION AND CONVERSION TO
OTHER USES.
WHEN THIS HAPPENS RESIDENTS
CANNOT EASILY MOVE IN FACT OVER
81% OF TODAY'S MANUFACTURED
HOMES WILL NEVER BEBE LOCATED?
AS SUCH RENTERS AND HOMEOWNERS
ALIKE LOSE THEIR HOMES IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH PARTNERS
ACROSS THE STATE AND THROUGHOUT-THE COUNTRY WE HEAR SO OFTEN
THAT ONE OF THE FUNDAMENTAL
CHALLENGES FACING NONPROFIT
RESIDENT AND PUBLIC HOUSING
ENTITIES.
FROM SUCCESSFULLY PURCHASING AND
PRESERVING A PARK IS THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE.
PARK SALES CAN HAPPEN SO QUICKLY
AMONGST BROKERS AND INVESTORS
INTERESTED BUYERS NEVER HAVE THE
CHANCE.
THIS BILL CREATES AN INCENTIVE
THAT HELPS TO LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD AND GIVES LEVERAGE FOR
MISSION DRIVEN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRESERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS.
THIS IS JUST ONE TOOL IN THE
PARK PRESERVATION TOOL KIT BUT
IT IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
IN FACING CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS SB TWO FIFTY TWO WILL
ALLOW THE STATE TO MAKE THE MOST
OF EXISTING RESOURCES. TO
PROTECT THE HOUSING WE ALREADY
HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SEBASTIAN
TAYLOR FLORA GEORGE OF TWO
MINUTES AND WELCOME TO COMMITTEE
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SUZANNE TAYLOR AND
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
FIFTY TWO I AM THE FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ACOSTA
COMMUNITIES A CALIFORNIA
NONPROFIT HOUSING ORGANIZATION
THAT I FOUND A TWENTY YEARS AGO.
I'M ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF A CG A
MANUFACTURED CONSULTANT.
SPECIALIZING IN MANUFACTURED
HOUSING IN PROVIDING SERVICES
THE GOVERNMENT NONPROFIT AND
INVESTORS SO I HAVE A BROAD
POINT OF VIEW.
ARE NONPROFIT OWNS OR OPERATES
EIGHT COMMUNITIES HOUSING TWELVE
HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS AND FORTY ONE
HUNDRED RESIDENTS WITHIN THE
COUNTIES OF INTEREST AMBER DINO
ORANGE AND TULARE.
WHERE WE PROVIDE LONG TERM
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT THE
TOOLS AVAILABLE TO NON PROFITS
IN THE REDEVELOPMENT YEARS THE
RATE OF NONPROFIT PURCHASES HAS
SLOWED TO NEW ONLY A HALT?
WE'RE LOSING GROUND TO
NONTRADITIONAL HEDGE FUND GROUPS
THAT HAVE A VERY AGGRESSIVE
BUSINESS PLANS CAN FIND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN HOME
REPLACEMENTS AND HAVE ACCESS TO
BETTER POSITION FINANCING.
THEY HAVE A LONG REGION OF THIS
MARKET NOW.
THEY **** PROPERTIES QUICKLY IN
CLOSE IN THIRTY DAYS DESPITE AN
ACTIVELY LOOKING FOR PROJECTS
DAY BY DAY THE LAST PURCHASE A
GUST OF WIND MADE WAS THREE
YEARS AGO.
THIS PAST YEAR WE IDENTIFIED
SEVERAL PARKS OF INTEREST THAT
WOULD WE COULD FINANCE SOMEONE
OPERATE WITHIN OUR MISSIONS IN
EACH CASE WITHIN ONE WEEK.
OF GOING TO MARKET THESE
PROPERTIES WERE SOLD TO
INVESTMENT GROUPS.
AB TWO FIFTY TWO WILL GIVE A NEW
TOOL TO CATCH THE EYE OF THESE
BY OF OF THE BUYERS WHO ARE
OTHERWISE HAVE NO INTEREST IN
SELLING TO A PARTY.
AND THAT MAY HAVE DIFFERENT --
MISSIONS IN PROTRACTED CLOSING
SCHEDULES LIKE A BLACK CAR
NONPROFITS THE INCENTIVE WOULD
LET SOME OF THESE SELLERS WHO
WANT TO RETIRE FROM THE BUSINESS
OR WANT TO CASH OUT.
YOU MAY WANT TO CLOSER PARK OR
ATTEMPT TO CLOSE FOR ANOTHER USE.
IT OR AT THAT ARE NOT INTERESTED
OR DO NOT HAVE THE CAPITAL TO
FUND INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
REQUIRED UNDER EACH CD
REGULATIONS.
THERE IS A LIMIT TO PULL OF
SELLERS IN THIS -- MARKET HE
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE PROGRAM SO THIS
PROGRAM WILL NOT BE COSTLY TO
THE STATE.
OVERALL.
IN A GOOD YEAR MAYBE ONE OR TWO
AND A FOR LUCKY THREE PUT PARKS
ARE SOLD TO NON PROFITS PER YEAR --
THAT'S THAT'S A REALLY BIG DIP
IN WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH IN THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS.
OKAY WITH THIS INCENTIVE PROGRAM
WE MIGHT GET TO FIVE AND THAT
WOULD PROVIDE TWELVE HUNDRED
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS.
FOR A LOWER INCOME RESIDENTS
THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU CYNTHIA GRATEFUL
NOW WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
TO THE MICROPHONE BEHIND CENTER
LEYVA.
ALL THOSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME.
FOR LAST CALL.
WE NOW LIVE AT LIKE TO WELCOME
ANYONE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION.
THOSE WHO OPPOSE IT COULD PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
LAST CALL FOR POST WE NOW LIKE
TO BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONVERSATION.
AND OR A MOTION TO APPROVE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
WIENER.
I HEARING SEEN NO CONVERSATION
FROM THE COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO TURN OVER TO CENTER LABOR
FOR CLOSING COMMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
RELATED THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS
HAS A DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- MOTION AND SHE
HAS TAKEN THE IMMINENCE ASSIGNED
CHESTER ROLL CALL PLEASE CHOIR
HI WHY I'M MORE LOCK.
OR UNLOCK AYE BELL WELL I
HERTZBERG RICARDO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
LOOK AT THAT BODY PART IS SPORTS
AND LEYVA THANK YOU SO MUCH THEY
CAN BE SECURE THANK THANK YOU
GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK YOU LADIES
VERY MUCH.
WHERE HE THAT BILL ON CALL WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO THE
PORTANTINO SHOW MR PORTANTINO
HAS NOT ONE NOT TWO BUT THREE
BILLS LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THAT
ARE GONNA COME IN FOR THE BOY TO
THE COMMITTEE?
WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING THEM IN
FILE ORDER. FIVE EGGMAN WHATEVER
ORDER THE CHAIR WANTS TO TAKE
THERE WE GO -- IT'S GONNA BE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT FIRST SB THREE
FOUR NINE ITEM NUMBER NINE SB.
THREE FIVE FIVE AND THEN WITH
ACTIVATED TAKE ITEM THIRTEEN SB.
FIVE TWENTY ONE THIS SENATOR
PORTANTINO YOU HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON EIGHT AND NINE NOT ON
ITEM.
THIRTEEN WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR
TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
PRESENTATION ON ITEM EIGHT AND
NINE WE NÁN WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A FULL PRESENTATION.
ON ITEM.
THIRTEEN THANK PORTANTINO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS ON SB.
THREE FORTY NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
I WILL BE BRIEF -- SMALL
BUSINESSES I BELIEVE ARE THE
INCREASING BACKBONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S GROWING ECONOMY
RESEARCHERS AT OVER THREE
MILLION OF CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES ACCOUNT -- 499% OF
OUR STATES EMPLOYERS AND 45% OF
CALIFORNIA'S EXPORTS UNDER
CURRENT LAW THERE'S AN ANNUAL
MINIMUM TAX OF EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS ON EVERY CORPORATION.
THIS TAX IS A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
AND WE'RE PROPOSING TO HAVE A
GREAT DID -- SYSTEM AND FRANKLY
HELP SMALL BUSINESSES BY NOT
MAKING ALL SMALL BUSINESSES AB
AND HUNDRED DOLLAR TAX.
AND I HAVE THE SMALL BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION HERE AS WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CENTER WE
TAKE THEIR TURN IT OVER TO OUR
WITNESSES YOU HAVE. TWO MINUTES
BUT YOU DO A BI PARTISAN SUPPORT
WHICH IS GREAT NEWS SO WE'D
WELCOME A SHORT TESTIMONY IS
WELL IF YOU COULD PLEASE GIVE US
YOUR FIRST LASSEN ORGANIZATION A
WELCOME TO COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU I'M READY JUDGE COLEY
I'M PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION.
OUR ASSOCIATION HAS TWO GOALS
JOB CREATION AND GROW THE
ECONOMY.
PARTICULARLY FOR SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS.
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT TO US.
AND THIS IS NOT NECESSARILY IN
ORDER OF IMPORTANCE BUT
CURRENTLY ONLY 17% OF THE SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE ARE
INCORPORATED.
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS DOING ON
NEW TAX RULES I WAS TOLD BY THE
US CHAMBER SMALL BUSINESS.
TAX ADVISER.
THAT ONLY S. AND C. CORPORATIONS
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO COUNT
BUSINESS EXPENSES SO THIS IS A
PROACTIVE BILL.
THIS IS A BILL TO BRING BOARD
MORE TAX REVENUE TO THE STATE
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO
INCORPORATE MORE THAN 17%.
IT'S A FAIR BILL BECAUSE OF
MICRO BUSINESS SHOULDN'T PAY FOR
IT GOOGLE AND CHEVRON QUE.
IT IS BOB.
DEFINITELY THERE IF YOU DO THE
ARITHMETIC AND WE'RE GOING TO BE
PROACTIVE IN THIS IT ALSO WILL
MEAN THAT SMALL BUSINESSES DO
NOT HAVE THE RISK THAT THEY
CURRENTLY HAVE FOR LIABILITY.
AND SO WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS AND WE WILL WORK
HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES A CALIFORNIA.
CONTINUE TO GROW THE ECONOMY AND
CREATE MORE JOBS AND DO IT IN A
BETTER MANNER NOT THE
UNDERGROUND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'R GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY FOR ALL
YOUR WORK.
AND WE WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SOME
LASSEN ORGANIZATION.
MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN ROBIN
BLACK COME AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
SMALL MRS CESSATION.
AN INTEREST OF BREVITY JUST
WANNA THANK THE CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU OFFER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND THANK THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE GRATEFUL
YOU'RE HERE AS WELL.
WE'D LIKE TO BE OUR WELCOME
ANYONE ELSE WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FOR THE MICROPHONE
LOOKING FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT
WELCOME BACK SIR.
COME ON OVER. TWENTY MISTER
CHAIRMAN JOHN CAPITA CALIFORNIA
STATE DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS PROUD TO BE IN SUPPORT
THANK THE SENATOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP.
AND CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL THANKS FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
WITH ACCURACY THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE.
WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD?
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
NOW LIKE TO TURN OVER THOSE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSE.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
WITH A BETTER BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE WILL TURN OVER THE
VICE CHAIR MISTER PRESSURE THANK
YOU MISTER -- CENTER PORTANTINO
JUST HAD. TWO QUICK QUESTIONS SO.
FOR FOR FOR THIS GREAT NATION OF
THE MINIMUM TAX -- YOU YOU FILE
A TAX RETURN YOU HAVE TWO POINT
SIX MILLION IN TAXABLE OR
REFLECTS SALES.
REVENUES AND THEN YOU HAVE TWO
POINT SIX MILLION EXPENSES SO
YOUR TAXABLE INCOME IS.
ZERO BUT BECAUSE YOU HAD TWO
POINT.
SIX MILLION IN SALES YOUR
MINIMUM TAXES ONLY FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
THAT'S THAT'S WHY WE'RE WORKING
IT.
I BELIEVE CHAU.
SO HERE'S A CHART IN THE IN THE
ANALYSIS.
BECAUSE IT'S IT'S A AND GET THE
TAXI METERS FOR MINIMUM TAX YOU
PAY MORE.
IF YOU ACTUALLY HAD TAXABLE
INCOME SO THIS IS.
SORT OF HELPING CORPORATIONS
THAT HAVE.
MAYBE SEVEN THOUSAND TAXABLE
INCOME OR LESS EVEN THOUGH THEY
HAD TWO POINT SIX MILLION OR
WHATEVER.
IN IN IN REVENUES.
YEAH BETTY JO WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THAT YOUR MIND IS RE
INTRODUCING YOURSELF TO
COMMITTEE PLEASE I'M BETTY JO TO
CALL A FROM CONFERENCE SMALL
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION.
WHAT SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS TELL
ME?
IS THAT THE REASON THEY DON'T
INCORPORATED IS BECAUSE OF THE
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AND THAT IF PARTICULARLY IN
YEARS THAT THEY DON'T MAKE A
PROFIT THAT IS A REAL HARDSHIP
FOR THEM.
BUT THERE ALSO IS A FAIRNESS
ISSUE YOU ARE RIGHT ON THE FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS -- BUT THERE IS
A FAIRNESS ISSUE THAT.
BASED ON REVENUE A MICRO
BUSINESS SHOULDN'T REALLY PAVE
WHAT A BUSINESS LIKE MINE PAYS.
OF THAT HAS.
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
REVENUE.
AND CERTAINLY THE BIG BOYS.
FRANK I'M TAKE BELGIUM TECHNO
PER MILE PRACTICE DAYS IS A
CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT Là
AB THAT'S RIGHT I'VE GOT THAT
ABOUT YOU.
SO YEAH THE EIGHT HUNDRED
MINIMUM.
TAXES AS ONEROUS FOR PEOPLE THAT
ARE USING CORPORATIONS FOR A LOT
OF TAX PLANNING OR OTHER.
TECHNIQUES BUT NOT HAVE TO HAVE
A HIGH VOLUME.
BUT BUT DOING THE MATH I'M JUST
YOU KNOW YOU YOU WOULD GET.
AT A 50% CUT BUT YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A A TAX LOSS THE GET THE
BENEFIT.
IT MIGHT HAVE A GOOD YEAR IN
SALES BUT YOU HAD A YOU KNOW HI
YEAR OF EXPENSES SO IT.
I'M JUST TRYING.
TO WHAT IS.
IT SHOW YOU MY ARITHMETIC CON.
IF CURRENTLY OF LET'S TAKE FOR
THERE'S SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES
WITH EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA.
AS OF TWENTY TWELVE AND LET'S
TAKE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND IF
YOU TAKE THAT 20% OF THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND WOULD PAY EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS. 20% WOULD PAY
610020% WOULD PAY.
OFF FOUR HUNDRED AND 40% WOULD
PAY TWO HUNDRED THE REVENUE IS
GREATLY INCREASE FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THEY CURRENTLY ARE
PAYING NOTHING I THINK YOU'RE
TRYING TO GET TO THE TECHNICAL
IMPLEMENTATION FROM THE FROM THE
ACCOUNTANTS PERSPECTIVE.
HOW THEY WOULD HAVE THIS WOULD
APPLY TO THIS IN THAT SPECIFIC
CIRCUMSTANCE?
RIGHT IF YOU IF IF YOU'RE TWO
PARENTS SIX MILLION IN REVENUES.
BUT YOU HAD A MILLION IN TAXABLE
INCOME YOU'RE YOU'RE GONNA PAY
UP YOU'RE GONNA PAY THE 9% OR
WHATEVER THE RADIUS.
SO THE EIGHT HUNDRED IS IS IS
THE MATERIAL.
SO I GUESS WE THE POINT I'M
TRYING TO MAKE IS IT DOESN'T GO
FAR ENOUGH AYE.
YOU KNOW WE SHOULD BE WIPING OUT
THIS MINIMUM TAX IN I I I DON'T
KNOW HOW IT THIS BILL REALLY
DOES THAT I'LL VOTE FOR THE BILL
BUT BUT IT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
IF.
YOU BENEFIT ONLY IF YOU HAVE.
A TAX LOSS THAT YEAR.
QUESTION WOULD BE DO YOU STILL
GET THE KERRY BACK TO LOS. FOR
ALSO INCENTIVIZING INCORPORATION
I MEAN THERE THERE THERE'S
MULTIPLE FACETS TO WHY THIS BILL
FIRST WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE THAT
THE MINIMUM TAX.
OF FAIR APPLICATION OF IT AND
WE'RE TRYING TO INCENTIVIZE
INCORPORATIONS AT THE SAME TIME.
AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO HIT THE
SWEET SPOT.
AND YOU KNOW AS YOU KNOW. TO GET
A BIPARTISAN BILL ON TAXES IS TO
THE VERY NARROW SWEET SPOT.
OUR LORD WERE TRYING TO GET
THERE I GOT A SMIRK FROM LOOKING
SOMETHING SOONER PORTANTINO
BECAUSE WE WOULD LOVE TO TAKE
THAT AMENDMENT BUT IF YOU WANTED
TO OFFER THAT YOU KNOW.
THE CALL TO LIKE YOUR I WILL
TAKE YOUR AYE VOTE AND AND MOVE
IT ON BUT I I BUT I I I'M I'M
JUST THINKING A PRACTICE IT IT'S
IT'S NOT GOING.
TO BE WHAT WE WILL.
REALLY NEED IS JUST GONNA BE
WITH YOU HAD A TAXABLE AUSTIN
YOU YOU JUST SAVE A COUPLE
HUNDRED BUCKS AND THAT'S NOT THE
BANG I'M LOOKING FORWARD SO I
APOLOGIZE.
FOR BEING A CPA ARE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO NEVER VOTE IS
ELECTED IT REAL QUICK SO I'D
LIKE TO BRING CLOSURE TO THIS.
DISCUSSION HERE SO -- MA'AM IF
YOU DON'T MIND JUST RESPOND
BRIEFLY PLEASE.
THE MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX IS
EVEN IF YOU HAVE A LOSS.
IF IN REVENUES YOU KNOW FOR THE
YEAR SO IT'S THE BASE.
YOU STILL PAY TAXES ON ON YOUR
GROSS EARNINGS.
IN ADDITION SO I DON'T THINK YOU
LOSE ANYTHING BECAUSE CURRENTLY
THEY'RE NOT PAYING ANYTHING.
ARE YOU HAVE TO PAY YOUR EIGHT
HUNDRED EVERY YEAR REGARDLESS
BUT ONLY 17% A SMALL BUSINESSES
ARE INCORPORATED IN PAYING.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE THIS AT
LEAST 50%.
ART.
BUT I'M SAYING THERE'S NOT GOING
TO BE A BIG SAVINGS UNDER THIS.
FORMULA AS I UNDERSTAND IT.
AND SO I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW DO I SUPERCHARGE YOUR BILL.
TO GET CLOSER TO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AND AND I'LL STOP
THERE MISTER NO.
LOOK AT FIRST FIVE I AM SO
GRATEFUL TO THE VICE CHAIR --
WITH HIS PROFESSIONAL BACKGROUND
BRINGING THAT PERSPECTIVE
COMMITTEE IT IS HELPED US -- AN
AMAZING MANY TIMES OVER THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS AND WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR THAT.
WHEN THE ITEMS THAT WOULD
SUGGEST IS A SINNER MORLOCK IN A
CONVERSATION WITH CENTER
PORTANTINO -- ON THE SPECIFICS --
INTO PRIOR TO THIS BILL HITTING --
APPROPRIATIONS THE TWO OF YOU
COULD BE ABLE TO CONNECT BECAUSE
THANK YOU BRING UP SOME GOOD
POINTS AND I'M SURE THAT CENTER
POINTING WILL BE MORE THAN
WILLING. TO HAVE THAT THE
CONVERSATION AS WELL ABSOLUTELY.
ALL RIGHT NOW THANK YOU SO MUCH
WOULD LIKE TO RECEIVE WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE -- ONFROM THE DICE IN
THE COMMITTEE BEFORE WE ASSN A
PORTANTINO TO BE ABLE TO OFFER A
CLOSING WE ARE GOING TO NEED.
A MOTION AS WELL FROM COMMITTEE
ARE.
WHAT WOULD TURN OVER TO THE GOOD
SENATOR -- FOR CLOSING COMMENTS
I KNOW I'M CERTAINLY OPEN -- TO
WAYS TO IMPROVE THE BILL -- AS I
SAID WE'RE TRYING TO HIT THE
SWEET SPOT I'M VERY HAPPY THAT
THE BIT SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS THIS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SAYS AND
PORTANTINO WE'D LIKE TO BE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR.
THEY'RE DISTRACTED A DAY LATER
YEAH WE'RE LOOKING.
FOR WE HAVE A MOTION THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR WE
HAVE A MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR.
AT THIS MOTION IS A DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MISSING JUST A
ROLL CALL PLEASE REQUIRE HI WHY
I'M MORE LOCKED.
WHAT I BELT?
THEY'LL AYE HERTZBERG FURTADO
NIELSEN.
YES AND I WIENER WIENER AYE.
THAT CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
BIPARTISAN FIVE EIGHT ZERO VOTE
THERE WILL BE A DISCUSSION WITH
THE VICE CHAIR IS WELL IS IN A
PORTANTINO.
PRIOR TO HITTING APPROPRIATIONS
BUT CENTER WIENER A QUICK CHECK
IN.
I THINK WE HAVE -- TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN THE
RUNNING FOR THE WAR TODAY MY
RIGHT.
YES ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE KEEPING
TRACK ALL RIGHT.
REVIVE WE'VE -- IMPORTED THE
RICARDO LARA AWARD OVER TO THE
SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE WE'VE
BEEN AT THE CENTER MCGUIRE
WORKERS HE WAS THE LAST PERSON
TO ARRIVE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE HAVE -- AT MULTIPLE AWARD
WINNER CENTER WE ARE HERE TODAY
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HI DAY.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER NINE THIS IS SB.
THREE FIVE FIVE BUT WE DO HAVE --
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OR TAKE
MOMENT SAY THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THESE AMENDMENTS WE DO HAVE A
NAME IT'S IN FRONT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY.
YOU HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
ASK FOR A TRUNCATED VERSION YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK SIR THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
I WLL STICK WITH WITH WINSTON
CHURCHILL SAID THERE'S NO SUCH
THING AS A BAD SHORT SPEECH GOD
I WILL -- COMPLY WITH THE CHAIRS
REQUEST AND I WILL ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS PRESENTED BY THE
COMMITTEE AND THANK THINK
COMMITTEE FOR CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH MY OFFICE -- SB.
THREE FIFTY FIVE ELIMINATES
REQUIREMENT THAT DESIGNATED
ALTERNATE MEMBERS OF LEGISLATIVE
BODIES OF A JOINT POWER AGENCY
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE BODY OF A
MEMBER OF A LOCAL AGENCY TO
PARTICIPATE IN CLOSED SESSION.
SO WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THESE DESIGNEES HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE AND
WE THINK THIS WILL IMPROVE --
INTERACTION BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND J. P. A.'S AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CENTER
WE DO HAVE A COUPLE WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT WE WELCOME YOU
TO COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH
OF BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I HEAR FROM COMMITTEE WERE TO
ASK YOU JUST TO PULL THAT
MICROPHONE CLOSE TO THAT WORKS
FOR YOU IF YOU DON'T MIND JUST
GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND LAST NAME
AN ORGANIZATION IN WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF MY
NAME IS TONY TREMBLEY ON ELECTED
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER FOR THE CITY
OF CAMERI -- AND A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE CLEAN
POWER ALLIANCE AND AND PROUD TO
BE HERE -- WE ARE THANKFUL TO
CENTER PORTANTINO FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP -- I MINDFUL OF THE
FACT THAT THE CHAIR HAS
INDICATED THAT THIS OUGHT TO BE
A TRUNCATED ITEM SO ALL PROCEED
ACCORDINGLY -- IN MY OTHER LIFE --
pREPRESENTED PUBLIC AID AGENCIES
INCLUDING JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES AND HAD ALL KINDS OF
ISSUES -- COME UP OVER THE YEARS
WITH RESPECT TO THE BROWN ACT
THIS IS A GOOD GOVERNANCE BILL.
IT ALLOWS FOR FLEXIBILITY AND
EFFICIENCY OF FOR THE CLEAN
POWER ALLIANCE -- AND I WOULD
ASK I THINK WHAT I'LL DO IS
OLDER I'M GONNA LEAVE IT RIGHT
THERE AND IF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'D
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM.
AND WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THE COUNCIL AND MEANS A LOT THAT
YOU'RE HERE TODAY THANK YOU FOR
TRAVELING TO THE CAPITAL IN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IN
YOUR AT YOUR WORK AS WELL SIR.
GOOD MORNING MA'AM FLOORS A
WARNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THE FORGES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITIES IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE FIFTY FIVE WHICH ALLOWS
FOR NECESSARY.
AVENUE FLEXIBILITY WHEN
ADDRESSING COMPLEX TECHNICAL AND
TIME SENSITIVE INFORMATION
AFFECTING THE PUBLIC SERVICE ARE
ENTITIES ARE CHARGED WITH.
OUR MEMBERS REDUCE THE RISK AND
ASSOCIATED INSURANCE COST AND
NON PROFIT PUBLIC ENTITY GPAS.
THAT COME TOGETHER BY REGION OR
ENTITY TYPE TO USE THE ECONOMY
OF SCALE TO EFFECTIVELY SELF
INSURE FOR THEIR RISK AND LOST
CONTROL RELATED OBLIGATIONS.
LIKE WORKERS COMPENSATION AUTO
COVERAGE TOWARD IN GENERAL
LIABILITIES.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN OUR MEMBERS
MAY HAVE OBLIGATIONS TO THEIR
PRIMARY AGENCY FOR EXAMPLE IF
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN BOARD
MEETING WHICH WOULD CREATE A
CONFLICT FOR ALL OF THEIR LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
AND OF THAT NUMBER AGENCY AND
UNDER THIS BILL AND A DESIGNATED
REPRESENTATIVE SUCH AS A RISK
MANAGER OR OTHER HIGH RANKING
STAFF CAN EFFECTIVELY
PARTICIPATE ON BEHALF OF THAT
ELECTED MEMBER.
ALLOWING FOR KOREANS IN CRITICAL
PUBLIC SERVICES TO CONTINUE IN A
TIMELY MANNER WE SINCERELY THANK
THE SENATOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON BEHALF OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND URGE YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE
HERE NOW GOING TO GO TO THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT WE WELCOME
THE CERTAIN LOOK BACK TO
COMMITTEE THANK YOU MISTER --
DAVID JONES ABOUT THE CITY OF
SOUTH PASADENA THANK THE AUTHOR
WHEN ASKED FOR MY VOTE THANK YOU
SO MUCH WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF PLEASE COME FORWARD
WELCOME BACK.
IT'S LIKE IT US HERE ON BEHALF
OF CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
MORNING. ONE WAS CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL RAIL AUTHORITY
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS METRO LINK IS
IN THE PROCESS OF LOOKING AT
THIS BILL FOR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT IF YOU CAN PLEASE COME
FORWARD LAST CALL.
WHEN I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
ANYONE WHO MAY BE IN OPPOSITION
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADVANCE AT
THIS TIME LOOKING FOR THOSE TURN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
LAST CALL.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONVERSATION I AND OR A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
SENATOR BACK.
WE USE MOTION THE FLOOR WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR BELL.
SEE ANY ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION
OR DEBATE FROM THE COMMITTEE.
HEARING SEEN ON CENTER
PORTANTINO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE BY CLASS FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE DO HAVE A
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
FLOOR WITH AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR
BATTLE THIS WINCHESTER IF YOU
COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI WHY I'M MORE A LOT.
WELL LIKE I BELL.
SO I HERTZBERG RICARDO.
THERE'S AN AYE WIENER WIENER I
FIND THAT CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
FIVE ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR CENTER WAS ACCOUNTS BUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
AS WELL SIR.
THANK YOU.
THE GERMAN ARMY MOVING ON TO
ITEM THIRTEEN THIS IS THE LAST
ITEM ON THE PORTANTINO SHOW
TODAY THIS IS SB FIVE TWENTY ONE
WE'RE GONNA BE ASKING FOR A FULL
PRESENTATION ON THIS ITEM.
CENTER PORTANTINO IN YOUR LAST
BILL THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
PRESENTED BY THE COMMITTEE IN
THE ANALYSIS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR CONTINUE TO
WORK.
WITH MY OFFICE TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SB FIVE TWENTY ONE
WHICH WOULD ALLOW A TAX CREDIT.
TO TAXPAYER THAT OWNS A PROPERTY
RENTED TO OR AT LEAST BY PERSONS
RECEIVING ASSISTANCE UNDER
SECTION EIGHT OF THE UNITED
STATES HOUSING ACT OF NINETEEN
THIRTY SEVEN HOUSING PROVIDE AS
HOUSING PROVIDERS -- PRIVATE
MARKET LANDLORDS WHO RENT TO
SECTION EIGHT TENANTS ARE THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF CRITICAL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS TO
QUALIFIED FAMILIES IN NEED
HOWEVER DATA FROM THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
IN A CASE THAT THE NUMBER OF
LANDLORDS ACCEPTING VOUCHERS HAS
DECLINED OVER THE PAST DECADE.
WHILE THE NUMBER OF VOUCHERS
UTILIZED HAS INCREASED
ADDITIONALLY HOUSING CHOICES OF
SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER HOLDERS
ARE SEVERELY CONSTRAINED IN
FINDING A UNIT.
THAT MEETS THE PROGRAMS RENTAL
LIMITS FOR THOSE LANDLORDS WITH
UNITS THAT WOULD RAN ABOVE
SECTION EIGHT LIMITS.
PARTICIPATING IN THE SECTION
EIGHT VOUCHER PROGRAM IS A
DISADVANTAGE AND RESULT IN
RECEIVING A LOWER MONTHLY RENT.
THAN ONE COULD RECEIVE ON THE
OPEN MARKET. FOR THE VOUCHER
PROGRAM TO BE REALIZE ITS FULL
POTENTIAL IN PROVIDING ASSISTED
HOUSE HOLD ACCESS TO SAFE AND
DECENT HOUSING AND NEIGHBORHOODS.
OF THEIR CHOOSING THE PROGRAM
MUST APPEAL TO ARRIVE A WIDER
VARIETY OF LANDLORDS FOR
VOUCHERS TO BE APPEALING TO
PRIVATE MARKET PROPERTY OWNERS.
THEY MUST BE OFFERED A FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE THAT LOAN LARGE VALUE
IN LIEU OF CHANGING MARKET RATE
RENTS.
RAISING HOUSING COSTS CONTINUE
TO AFFECT NEARLY ALL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES SO BY INCENTIVIZING
LANDLORDS TO RID RENT SECTION
EIGHT RECIPIENTS LOW INCOME
FAMILIES ARE MORE LIKELY. TO NOT
BE PRICED OUT OF THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD AS RAINS CONTINUE I
KNOW -- CERTAINLY THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE -- AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HOUSING ISSUES IN
GENERAL ARE OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE IS JUST CREATE ONE
MORE INCENTIVE. FOR THE PRIVATE
MARKET TO TO TAKE SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHERS I MEAN -- IT'S SORT OF
TELLING THAT OF WORK CREATING
MORE OR THE THE MARKET HAS MORE
PEOPLE WHO QUALIFY FOR SECTION.
EIGHT BUT LESS OPPORTUNITIES TO
USE THOSE VOUCHERS THAT'S NOT
SOLVING THE PROBLEM AND SO WE
CAN CREATE A TAX BASE INCENTIVE
TO CREATE MORE.
PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNERS WHO
WOULD TAKE IN SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHERS -- BY MAKING THE
ECONOMICS BETTER.
WE THINK IT'S A GOOD INCENTIVE --
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT THE SOLUTION
IN TOTAL BUT WE THINK IT'S A
GOOD PART OF THE SOLUTION AND
WITH ME.
I A PETERS -- BACK FROM THE CITY
OF GLENDALE WHICH FRANKLY I HAVE
TO SAY IS ONE OF THE THE BEST
EXAMPLES OF A CITY -- DOING WHAT
IT CAN TO HELP PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING EARLIER IN
THE YEAR YOU KNOW THAT COMMITTEE
HEARD.
THE PROPOSAL TO USE TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS A BOND FUNDS
DIRECTLY 4100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HERE'S GLENDALE BACK
AGAIN.
WHICH HAS A LARGE APARTMENT --
MARKET PLACE TRYING TO HELP
THERE -- LANDLORDS -- PLACE MORE
FOLKS IN SECTION EIGHT HOUSING
SO MISTERS -- BACK IS HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND FOURTEEN I JUST WANNA
CONFIRM TO WHEN YOU'RE TAKING A
MINUTE I AM THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THIS IS A BACK WELCOME BUT WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE SIR
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR TWO MINUTES
THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING --
MISTER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS ITEM
BEFORE YOU.
THANK YOU TO THE SENATOR FOR HIS --
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
TOWARDS HIS DEDICATION FOUR
DEDICATION AFFORDABLE HOUSING
EFFORTS -- IN HIS DISTRICT HE'S
OUT AT EVERY EVENT THAT WE HAVE
AND SUPPORTING US IN EVERY WAY
POSSIBLE -- I JUST LIKE THAT
FROM AN OPERATIONAL PERSPECTIVE
IN IN ADMINISTERING A SECTION
EIGHT PROGRAM.
JUST ADD THIS THIS -- TO THE
DISCUSSION TODAY -- THE SECTION
EIGHT PROGRAM AND LIKE MANY
PROGRAMS NEARLY ALL OF THEM
CALIFORNIA -- THE WAITING LIST
FOR THAT PROGRAM THEY'RE CLOSED
HAVE BEEN CLOSED FOR QUITE SOME
TIME.
GLENDALE A WEIGHTLESS PROGRAM
HAS BEEN CLOSED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ONE AT THAT TIME THAT
WE OPENED WE HAD OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS APPLY.
HERE WE ARE SOME EIGHTEEN YEARS
LATER WE STILL HAVE TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED PEOPLE ON THE WAITING
LIST WAITING FOR THEIR VOUCHER.
IT'S VERY DISHEARTENING TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THIS -- RANGE OF
EMOTIONS WERE WE FINALLY PULL
SOMEONE OFF THE WAITING LIST
AFTER EIGHTEEN YEARS ISSUE THEM
ABOUT YOUR SEE THEM GO OUT TO
THE COMMUNITY.
COME BACK SIX MONTHS LATER WHICH
IS THE MAXIMUM TIME LIMIT HOW.
HAD GIVES YOU TO BE ABLE TO
CONTRACT UP UNIT AND SAY I'VE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO FIND A UNIT I
WAITED EIGHTEEN YEARS.
NOT BEEN ABLE TO CONTRACT AND
HAVE THE TURN THAT BELCHER BACK
OVER TO YOU.
WE THINK THIS BILL WILL.
HELP ADDRESS THAT ISSUE HELP
BRIDGE THAT GAP THAT A LOT OF
LANGUAGE ARE LOOKING AT THE
LOOKING AT THAT FINANCIAL DELTA.
SO THANK YOU.
WELCOME BACK MISTER CHAIRMAN
DAVID JONES ALSO ABOUT FOR
GLENDALE BUT ALSO ON BEHALF THE
CITY PASADENA.
CITY PASADENA RUNS THE SECTION
EIGHT PROGRAM THEY HAVE OVER
THIRTEEN HUNDRED LANDLORD TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE SECTION EIGHT
PROGRAM OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
ONE HUNDRED OF THE LANDLORDS
HAVE DECLINED TO CONTINUE THAT
OPERATION AND WE THINK THAT THIS
PROVIDES THE IMPORTANT SOLUTION
TO INCENTIVIZE LANDLORDS TO
CONTINUE TO BE IN THE PROGRAM
AND AND AS PETER HAS MENTIONED --
PEOPLE WITH VOUCHERS NOT BE ABLE
TO FIND A LANDLORD WILLING TO
TAKE THESE VOUCHERS WE THINK
THIS BILL WILL WILL GREATLY
ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF LANDLORDS
TO SAY YES THIS MAKES FINANCIAL
SENSE FOR ME TO RENT TO A VERY
LOW INCOME PERSON.
SO AS FAR AS THE DIVERSITY OF
COMMUNITIES THIRTEEN HUNDRED
HOUSEHOLDS IN PASADENA ARE VERY
LOW INCOME PEOPLE WE NEED THESE
PEOPLE TO STAY IN THE COMMUNITY
KEEP THE DIVERSITY THERE WE'D
ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TO SENATE
TESTIMONY WE NOW LIKE TO WELCOME
ANYONE WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF
PLEASE COME FOR FIRST AND LAST
AS WELL AS ORGANIZATION.
GOOD MORNING MARY ELLEN SHOW A
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HOUSING AUTHORITIES IN SUPPORT.
THE COMMISSION.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING KATE FELL ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION WITH OVER TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND HALF
MILLION IS THE STATE HERE IN
pAPPROACH THANK YOU THANKS FOR
COMING.
MORNING SHARE MEMBERS THE
CARLSON FOR THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES IN THE SANTA BARBARA
RENTAL PROPERTY ASSOCIATION WE
THINK THIS IS A REALLY GOOD IDEA --
IT IT IT'S AN INCENTIVE BASED
PROGRAM MARKET BASED PROGRAM
SUPPOSED TO MANDATE -- FOR
SOMETIMES AND I THINK GLENDALE
DOESN'T DO THIS BUT SOMETIMES
IT'S THE BUREAUCRATIC MESS AND
THE SOME OF THE COMMUNITY SO
THERE'S ANOTHER DISINCENTIVE TO
DO THAT SO WE APPLY THE AUTHOR
FOR MOVING FORWARD ON THIS.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MR CHEN
MEMBERS BATMAN WITH THEIR AND
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
LOUISE BACK.
THE ONLY BE WITH THE A
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT SOCIAL HER
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH LIKE VISITORS
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO BE A WELCOME
ANYONE WHO IS IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU PLEASE COME FORWARD.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
CENTRE BELL IN IN CENTER WIENER.
OKAY -- SENATOR -- IN SOME
COUNTIES.
THERE'S SOME NON.
FAIRLY FUNDED.
VOUCHERS [inaudible]
THE ERROR.
SET UP LIKE WE HAVE A HOUSING
BONDS AND SO FORTH AND WE SET UP
THESE.
VOUCHER PROGRAMS THEIR NON
FEDERALLY FUNDED.
WITH THOSE KINDS OF PROGRAMS BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE TAX CREDIT.
OR COULD THEY BE I MEAN WHEN WE
WE SET UP A LIKE A COUNTY TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM.
OF FOR AFFORDABLE IT BE THE SAME.
IT BE LIKE A SECTION EIGHT LIGHT.
TAX -- VOUCHER A VOUCHER PROGRAM
SECTION EIGHT LIKE VOUCHER
PROGRAM FOR LIKE HOME WAS -- FOR
PROGRAMS -- FOR OUT REASSURE
VETERANS ARE SO FORCES AND IT'S
NOT A SECTION H. BUT IT'S LIKE A
SECTION EIGHT RIGHT NOW THE WAY
IT'S STRUCTURED IT'S JUST THE
FEDERAL.
SECTION -- EIGHT BUT CERTAINLY
WE CAN LOOK AT EXPANDING IT TO
YEAH LOCALS OBVIOUSLY THE COST.
COMES INTO YOU KNOW HOW HOW
SIGNIFICANT THE TAX CREDIT WOULD
BE AT THAT POINT BUT CERTAINLY
WE CAN LOOK AT IT BUT TO BE TO
ANSWER QUESTION RIGHT NOW THOSE
LOCAL PROGRAMS ARE NOT INCLUDED.
OKAY SO WE ARE IT COULD BE A THE
STATE PROGRAM IN A RATHER THAT
OF STATE VOUCHER.
PROGRAM OF WE HAD A BILL LAST
YEAR THEY ACTUALLY THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS BUT BUT I THINK I
THINK THOSE KINDS OF PROGRAMS.
MAYBE A WORK WITH YOUR OFFICE
AND CERTAINLY LAUDABLE PROGRAMS --
THEN YOU'RE RIGHT MANY COUNTIES
ARE DOING OTHER THINGS OTHER
THAN JUST THE FEDERAL PROGRAM.
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
ANDERSON A POINT THAT I THINK
MISTER CENTER CENTER WIENER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALSO FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE --
AS I I THINK MAY HAVE BEEN I
DON'T REMEMBER FOURTH NOTED
EARLIER ON I'M CAUGHT IN A BILL --
THREE SPEARHEADED BY SENATOR
MITCHELL SB I THINK IT'S THREE
TWENTY NINE OF THE BAND'S
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST --
SECTION A RAW RECIPIENTS WHICH
IS LONG OVERDUE IN CALIFORNIA
OTHER STATES HAVE.
HAVE DONE AT A NUMBER OF CITIES
IN CALIFORNIA DO IT AS OVER --
TO TO DO IT HERE ON THE ONE OF
THE ARE ONE OF THE KEYS THE
FEEDBACK THAT I HEAR FROM.
LANDLORDS I KNOW IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND AND I THINK I'LL
SWEAR IS THAT -- SOMETIMES IT'S
NOT THE LANDLORDS DODD DON'T
WANT TO TAKE SECTION BUT
SOMETIMES IT'S THE LOGISTICAL
AND THE BUREAUCRACY AND
SOMETIMES IN SAN FRANCISCO WE
CUT THE LADIES -- AND AND SO WE
NEED TO IMPROVE THAT BIKE --
CREATING -- CARROT -- AS WELL AS
THE STICK IS IMPORTANT IN THESE
TWO BILLS ARE EXTREMELY
COMPLIMENTARY TO EACH OTHER.
I'M SO HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS AND
I WOULD ALSO LOVE TO BE OUT OF
THE CALL.
ABSOLUTELY YOU KNOW WE'RE HAPPEN
EDGES A CO AUTHOR AND AND YES
SENATOR -- FROM SAN FRANCISCO --
CERTAINLY HAS BEEN -- INVOLVED
IN THESE ISSUES -- INTIMATELY
PROBABLY AND MISTER BELL AS WELL
MORE THAN MORE THAN ANYONE.
NOT HAPPY TO ADD YOU BOTH AND
JUST LISTENING JUST IF I COULD
MISTER CHAIR THESE ARE LISTENING
TO JUST IN PASADENA'S CASE HERE
YOU HAVE.
YOU KNOW THIRTEEN HUNDRED
LANDLORDS AND A HUNDRED DROPPING
OUT BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMICS --
NO THOSE ARE REAL NUMBERS AND I
THINK BOTH BILLS WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN HAPPENED HAVE YOU
BOTH ON AS CO AUTHOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATE WINNER
CENTER BABBLE NOW LIKE TO GO TO
THE VICE CHAIR.
THRESHER FLOORS YOURS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MRS -- BACK YOU
YUBA.
WAITED ALL OUT FIGURES TO TAKES
YEARS TO GET A SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHER -- BUT IN YOUR CITY I'M
JUST CHRISTY TO SURVEY THE
LANDLORDS THAT DECIDED TO DROP
OUT OF THE PROGRAM. TO ASK WHY.
YES WE HAVE ENABLE RESPONDED
THAT THE DISPARITY IN THE RENT
THAT THEY COULD GET.
ON THE PRIVATE MARKET VERSUS --
THE SECTION EIGHT PROGRAM IS SO
GREAT THAT FOR THEM ITS
FINANCIAL DECISION -- THE
GLENDALE HOUSING AUTHORITIES SAY
HIGH PERFORMING AGENCY SO
DUROCHER SEE A RED TAPE THINGS
LIKE THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
STREAMLINE OPERATIONS THOSE THAT
DO PARTICIPATE LOVE THE PROGRAM --
TERMS OF LAMMERS A PARTICIPATE
THEY LOVE THE PROGRAM THEY FEEL
THAT WE DO A GOOD JOB THERE AND
THEY ARE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
THE DISPARITY IN IN THE LEASE UP
[inaudible]
SO.
YOU PROBABLY MET BRAINSTORMING
FOR YEARS AND SO YOU.
COME UP WITH THIS IDEA YOU THINK
THIS.
NARROWS THE GAP BUT IT WOULD.
ACCOMPLISH WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
TRY AND AND DO OR OR DOES IT
HAVE TO GO FURTHER.
THIS PARTICULAR BILL HELPS HELPS
NARROW THE GAP THERE ARE OTHER
MEASURES THAT AGENCIES TAKE. TO
HELP -- BRIDGETTE GAP AS WELL
IT'S NOT IT'S NOT THE CURE ALL
BUT CERTAINLY THE MAIN REASON
THAT WE HEAR FROM LANDLORDS --
AS TO THEIR CONCERNS AND IN
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM IS
THAT FINANCIAL GAP THAT'S ALL
THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT NOW
PARTICULARLY THE NEWER LANDLORDS
THAT ARE MORE -- INVESTORS AS
OPPOSED TO MOM AND POP.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING A
LOT MORE LLC'S COMING IN AND FOR
THEM IT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
EVEN SECOND GENERATION FAMILY
OWNERS ARE LOOKING AT THE BOTTOM
LINE.
LARA NEW LANDLORDS WOULD BE
LOOKING FOR TAX DEDUCTIONS OR
MAYBE A TAX CREDIT DOESN'T HELP
I'M.
THERE'S A B. SHOULD BE INCHING
TO SEE WHAT KIND OF REACTION YOU
GET.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR.
LIKE ME TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
CONVERSATION AT THIS TIME.
PARTY TO NEED A REASON
PORTANTINO FOR CLOSING COMMENTS
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR BELL
CENTRE PRINTING WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS -- AS
IT'S BEEN STATED YOU KNOW THIS
IS NOT THE ONLY SOLUTION THIS IS
PART OF THE SOLUTION AND YOU
KNOW WE HEAR SO OFTEN ABOUT
CREATING INCENTIVES AND WE THINK
THIS IS A APPROPRIATE INCENTIVE
TO CRANE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE A POINT YOU KNOW
WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER BELT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS A
MINUTE APPROPRIATIONS MISSING
CHESTER ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI WHY I'M MORE LOCK.
BELL THEY'LL AYE HERTZBERG
FURTADO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
HI.
THE CURRENT ENJOY THE FOUR ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN AND ADD ON AS MEMBERS
ARRIVE THANK YOU THANKS SO MUCH
CENTER PORTANTINO.
THERE'S IN GERMAN WE ARE ALWAYS
GRATEFUL.
IT'S GOOD CENTER FOR SAN DIEGO
PRESENTING COMMITTEE WE HAVE TO
BILLS BY SENATOR HUESO.
SENATE HUESO WILL START WITH
ITEM NUMBER TEN AS BEFORE TWENTY
TWO THEN WILL TURN IT OVER TO
YOU FOR ITEM NUMBER EIGHT TEAM.
SB [inaudible] SIX THIRTY FIVE
THEIR WAY TO THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND WE WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE
SIR.
AN ITEM NUMBER TEN PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT -- SB FORTY TWO THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT BILL THAT IMPROVE
IMPROVE TO REMOVE THAT AIMS TO
REMOVE A SIGNIFICANT BARRIER. TO
SUCCESSFUL RE ENTRY FOR THE
LIVES OF YOUNG FAN EX OFFENDERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE -- FOR THE HELP
THEY PROVIDED OUR OFFICE AND IT
IN THIS BILL AND I WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT I WILL BE ADOPTING
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS --
SPECIFICALLY OUR OFFICE WILL
DROP FALLING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS INCREASE THE CREDIT
PERCENTAGE 250% OF WAGE WAGES
PAID.
ADD IN THE COMPLETION OF EITHER --
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROGRAM A
COGNITIVE THOUGHT -- BEHAVIOR
THERAPY TREATMENT PROGRAM OR AN
AN ANGER MANAGEMENT PROGRAM FOR
NEXT VENDOR TO QUALIFY.
AS A QUALIFY AN EMPLOYEE IN THIS --
PROGRAM OP PREVENT A DEDUCTION
FOR WAGES USED. TO CALCULATE AS
BE -- FOR TWO TO CREDIT THE
TAXPAYER GETS INTO THE CREDIT OR
THE DEDUCTION FOR QUALITY
QUALIFYING WAGES PAID BUT NOT
BOTH -- A IN IN RECENT THIS BILL
IS IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL THAT
WILL HELP US -- TO REDUCE --
OFFENDER RECIDIVISM IN OUR IN
OUR PRISON SYSTEMS -- IN RECENT
DECADES THE NUMBER OF AMERICANS
WHO OF HAVE COME IN CONTACT WITH
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
INCREASE EXPONENTIALLY.
BETWEEN NINETEEN EIGHTY IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE CALIFORNIA PRISON
POPULATION INCREASE 510083%.
UPON RELEASE MANY CALIFORNIANS
HAVE FOUND IT DIFFICULT TO FIND
EMPLOYMENT.
SO WILD OUR SYSTEM IS SUPPOSED
TO BE -- A PUNISHMENT SYSTEM YOU
GOT A PRESENT YOU YOU YOU.
YOU YOU YOU DO YOUR TIME.
OFTENTIMES IN OUR SYSTEM IN
AMERICA [inaudible]
A A OF A ONE YEAR -- JAIL
SENTENCE OF ONE YEAR PRESENT OF
THREE YEAR CAN BE A LIFE LONG
SENTENCE THE STIGMA OF BEING AN
EX FELON FOLLOWS PEOPLE FOR THE
REST OF THEIR LIVES.
OFTEN MAKING DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO FIND EMPLOYMENT.
AFTER OF PAIN THEIR THEIR THEIR
DEBT.
OVERWHELMINGLY EX OFFENDERS HAVE
HAD TENUOUS RELATIONSHIPS TO THE
LABOR MARKET.
APPROXIMATELY 70% OF DROPPED OUT
OF HIGH SCHOOL CONTRIBUTING TO
THEIR ON EMPLOYABILITY.
THESE EXPERT EX EXISTING
BARRIERS.
TO EMPLOYMENT AND SUCCESSFUL
REINTEGRATION INTO SOCIETY HELP
FURTHER EXACERBATED BY EMPLOYERS
AND WILLINGNESS TO HIRE EX
OFFENDERS.
THIS IS UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE SAYS
STATISTICS DEMONSTRATE THE
POSTING CAR CAR SERRATION
EMPLOYMENT IS A MAJOR FACTOR.
IN THE SUCCESSFUL REINTEGRATION
OF RELEASED.
OFFENDERS SO THIS BILL SUPPORTS
THE SKILL BUILDING APPROACHES
ALREADY BEEN IMPLEMENTED ACROSS
THE STATE BY.
QUALIFIED FOR TRAINING PROGRAMS
BY PROVIDING A TAX INCENTIVE TO
EMPLOYERS WHO HIRE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED USE.
WHO HAVE SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED
A WORK READING THIS PROGRAM SO
WHILE WE'RE TRAINING ON
PROVIDING THEM SKILLS?
PEOPLE STILL DON'T WANT
EMPLOYMENT.
THEY CAN GET THEIR GED THEIR
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA THEY CAN GET
A CERTIFICATE OF COMPLETION WHEN
ONE OF THE TRADES.
AND STILL PEOPLE DON'T WANNA.
SB FOUR TWO TWO SIMPLER TAX
CREDIT WILL ALLOW A QUALIFIED
IMPORT LAWYER.
TAXPAYER WHO HIRES FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES A CREDIT IN THE AMOUNT
EQUAL 250% OF THE QUALIFIED
WAGES PAID BY THE TAXPAYER.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT IT COSTS
ROUGHLY ROUGHLY SIXTY THOUSAND A
YEAR TO INCARCERATE A PRISONER
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
USING THE NUMBERS IN THE
ANALYSIS THIS PROGRAM KEEPS
TWELVE YOUNG EX OFFENDERS FROM
RE OFFENDING THAT THIS THIS
PROGRAM WOULD COST THE STATE
NOTHING.
IN TAX REVENUE.
GIVEN THE SOCIAL BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE NEXT
OFFENDER NOT GOING BACK TO
PRISON.
ULTIMATELY THE SAVINGS WOULD BE
EVEN GREATER LET'S TURN EX
OFFENDERS LESTER PRISONERS INTO --
CONSTRUCTIVE MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY LET'S CINNAMON TO
TAXPAYERS LET'S HELP THEM
REALIZE THIR AMERICAN DREAM
LET'S PROVIDE THEM AN EDUCATION.
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
IN AND HELP ME SUPPORT THIS
POPULATION GET ACCESS TO THE
AMERICAN DREAM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE READ ADDIS WHO
REPRESENTS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURTS TO MAKE.
SOME SOME -- SOME REMARKS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THAT I FOR
I WILL MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS THE CENTER MISTER HARRIS.
ALWAYS WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE
HERE TODAY YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
THANKS FOR ALL YOUR WORK THE
FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS READ
ADDISON BEHALF THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORES IN STRONG
SUPPORT TODAY -- FOURTEEN COURSE
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THERE THANKS TO YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN THE GOVERNOR IN THE PAST HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS.
TO HELP YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN WHO
HAVE HAD HARSH BACKGROUNDS.
A REMOVE SOME BARRIERS THE TWO
KEY BARRIERS WE WORK ON ARE
HELPING THEM GET THEIR FOUR YEAR
OR THEIR HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE.
DIPLOMA HE AND GET JOB
EXPERIENCE IT'S A CRITICAL SET
OF BARRIERS THAT ARE IN FRONT OF
THESE PEOPLE AND WE'RE ABLE TO
HELP THEM DO THAT.
BUT WE ARE ONLY ONE PART OF THAT
CAREER PATHWAY.
WE TRY TO HELP THESE YOUNG MEN
AND WOMEN ONCE THEY LEAVE OUR
PROGRAMS TO GET.
JOBS THROUGH VARIOUS EMPLOYER
NETWORKS THAT WE HAVE.
THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL BARRIER
AND THAT WE HAVE FOUND THIS IN
MANY CASES BECAUSE AS I STATED
WE DO WORK WITH A GROUP OF YOUNG
MEN AND WOMEN WHO HAVE HAD SOME --
PAST EXPERIENCES THAT ARE NOT
IDEAL THAT MEANS A NUMBER OF
THEM I DO HAVE FELONIES ON THEIR
RECORD AND WE HAVE FOUND THAT
THAT'S BEEN A COMPLICATION.
IN GETTING THEM.
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT AFTER THEY
LEAVE OUR PROGRAM.
THIS.
BILL THAT THE SENATORS ADVANCING
WE THINK BECOMES AN INCIDENT
THAT ALLOWS US TO WORK WITH
THOSE EMPLOYERS AND TO HELP
REMOVE THAT ONE ADDITIONAL
BARRIER WHEN OR RELATES TO A
FELONY ON THE RECORD. TO HELP
THESE YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN GET
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT INTO THE
FUTURE THEREFORE WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
MISTER ADDISON KEEP YOUR
TESTIMONY WE'RE GRATEFUL TO
SENATOR AS WELL FOR ALL OF HIS
WORK LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
WITH ACTIVATOR OPEN IT UP NOW.
TO ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FOR AT THIS TIME THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
LAST CALL.
LIKE VERY NOW SEE IF THERE IS
ANYONE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COME FORWARD THIS TIME.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSED.
THAT TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE RECEIVED WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE CENTER ABOUT
[inaudible]
SHERMAN.
I READ THE STAFF REPORT THE AND
SUGGESTED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SOMEONE ELSE.
SIR WESSEL.
I AM HAVING -- BLOCK ON THE
AMENDMENT THAT DEALS WITH.
COMPLETION OF A SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT PROGRAM COGNITIVE
BEHAVIOR THERAPY PROGRAM OR
ANGER MANAGEMENT. FOR AN EX
OFFENDER TO QUALIFY.
AS A QUALIFYING EMPLOYEES -- OF
THIS POOR BILL.
AND I THINK THAT'S AN
UNNECESSARILY.
AMENDMENT OKAY I JUST SAY THAT
OKAY -- AND I DON'T KNOW WHY.
I JUST.
OF DON'T KNOW WHY WE WOULD PUT
ON THE EMPLOYMENT BARRIERS.
THE EMPLOYER DOES NOT KNOW.
WHETHER OR NOT.
THEY HAVE A SUBSTANCE ABUSE
PROBLEM OR AN ANGER MANAGEMENT
PROBLEM ONLY THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS.
WHEN THEY'RE GOING ABOUT HIRING
THE PERSON BUT THEY DO KNOW?
THAT THE PERSON IS AN EX
OFFENDER [inaudible]
AND IT'S A PROBLEM THE PROBLEM
THE BILL'S TRYING TO ADDRESS.
IS NOT THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
[inaudible]
ISSUES.
WITH THE PERSON BUT THE FACT
THAT THEIR EX OFFENDER ANDERS
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST HIRING.
AGAINST PEOPLE THAT HAVE THEIR
EX OFFENDERS.
SO I I'M I'M I'M TROUBLED BY
THIS [inaudible]
ADDED.
I JUST TROUBLED BY THE ADDITIVES
AMENDMENT THAT WAS SUGGESTED
HERE AND I I DON'T KNOW IT'S A
VALID AMENDMENT -- I QUESTION
THE AYE AYE.
I DON'T KNOW WHY IT'S THERE IT
SAYS -- PEOPLE WITH THESE --
THAT EX OFFENDERS HAVE THESE
PROBLEMS -- I DON'T THINK THEY
HAVE PROBLEMS WITH THOSE THINGS
ANYMORE THAN NON EX OFFENDERS
[inaudible]
SO.
WHY IT CAN YOU COMMENT CAN WE
TALK ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT?
I I I I JUST I I I WOULD PREFER
NOT TO HAVE.
THAT AMENDMENT IF I WAS VOTING
ON THIS.
I THINK THIS PUTS INNER ADDED
ADDED IMPEDIMENT ON THE PROGRAM
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
YOU KNOW I I AGEE WITH YOU THAT
THAT AMENDMENT PUTS -- OF THAT
IT MAKES AN ASSUMPTION THAT
SOMEBODY IS IMPRISONED FOR ONE
OF THOSE ISSUES YEAH THAT'S WHEN
A PART NUMBER AND AND FOR YOU
KNOW I WOULDN'T OF ADDED THAT
AMENDMENT MYSELF EITHER GIVEN.
THE BROAD RANGE OF OF REASONS
WHY PEOPLE GO TO PRISON BUT WHEN
I LOOKED AT IT -- IN SOME
INSTANCES THERE ARE PERCENTAGE
OF THEIR SOME PROGRAMS ALLOW
PEOPLE OF THE POTENTIAL TO GET A
REDUCED SENTENCE OF THEY GO
THROUGH -- DRUGS -- EDUCATION OR
DRUG TREATMENT.
PROGRAM AND THAT IS THAT USUALLY
COVERS A FAIR AMOUNT OF THE
POPULATION NOT EVERYBODY.
AND THE OTHER AMENDMENT HAD TO
DEAL WITH -- THE THE COGNITIVE
BEHAVIOR.
THERAPY -- AGAIN ARE THERE IS
SOME -- PEOPLE IN IN PRISON THAT
FALL UNDER THE CATEGORY AS WELL
AND THEY ARE ALSO WITHIN THE
SYSTEM REQUIRED TO GO THROUGH.
SOME KIND OF TREATMENT PROGRAM
THAT ALLOWS THEM -- TO ALSO
QUALIFY FOR A REDUCED SENTENCE
AND AND THEY ALSO -- OFFER THAT
WITHIN OUR PRISON SYSTEM.
BUT AGAIN WHAT IF YOU DON'T FALL
IN THAT.
CATEGORY BUT THERE ARE OUR
PERCENTAGE.
I FELT I FIGURED THAT ON ENTER
ANGER MANAGEMENT PROGRAM AT THE
VERY LEAST WOULD DO ALMOST
ANYBODY SOME GOOD.
ANYBODY WHETHER YOU HAVE A MATT
ANGER MANAGEMENT PROGRAM OR NOT
A PROBLEM OR NOT YOU YOU YOU
WOULD BE WELL.
SHOULD I AGAIN THESE ARE NOT MY
AMENDMENTS -- THE CHAIRMAN AS A
VERY INFLUENTIAL MAN AND AND AND
AND I I I DON'T THINK THEY KNOW
THEY THEY THEY MAKE IT HARDER ON
THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT THAT DO
NEED OUR HELP BUT AT THE SAME
TIME THESE PROGRAMS COULD BE
VERY HELPFUL.
I I CAN IS COMMON RIGHT LOOK I
THINK THAT THE WHAT WE WERE
TRYING TO BE ABLE TO HIT.
IS BEING ABLE TO MOVE -- THE
INDIVIDUAL FORWARD.
AND IF YOU'RE COMING OUT OF
PRISON FOR EXAMPLE -- BEING ABLE
IN IF YU'VE BEEN IN PRISON FOR
QUITE SOME TIME TO BE ABLE TO GO
THROUGH A WORK READING THIS
CLASS IS GONNA BE CRITICAL TO
YOUR SUCCESS LONG TERM.
IF YOU ARE -- IF YOU DO HAVE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE THAT TREATMENT.
OUT OF THE WALL -- IF YOU ARE
GOING TO BE LOOKING AT ANGER
MANAGEMENT.
I'M TO BE ABLE TO PICK AND
CHOOSE FROM EITHER OF THESE
PROGRAMS -- IN IT IS SUPPOSED TO
BE ABLE TO HELP AN INDIVIDUAL
BROWN THEMSELVES OUT -- AND BE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD AFTER SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES IN MAY FACE.
IT'S NOT SAYING THAT YOU HAVE TO
BE A TO CREATE ALL OF THEM THAT
BEING ABLE TO PICK ONE OF THEM
THE BILL TO BECOME THAT
INDIVIDUAL WANT TO BE.
YOU WANT TO BE LONG TERM AND WE
BELIEVE THAT EACH OF THESE ARE
SELF HELP.
AN END TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON
YOURSELF IN CANADA THE I THINK.
IN A MINIMUM EVERYTHING IN
REGARDS OUR WORK READING THIS
WILL PROBABLY BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A WELL ROUNDED
INDIVIDUAL LONGER TERM.
BE MARKETABLE IN THE MARKETPLACE
AS WELL THAT'S WHY WE ARE
ADVANCE THAT -- LOOKING AT THAT
WELL ROUNDED INDIVIDUAL --
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
OUR I BELIEVE THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL ADD COSTS THAT
WILL BE TAKEN UP IN
APPROPRIATIONS.
BECAUSE IT WILL INVOLVE COST TO
PAY FOR THESE.
PROGRAMS.
AND THE THEY WILL ALSO ADD DELAY
THE TO THE PERSON.
ENTERING IN THE PROGRAM.
BECAUSE THEY WOULD FIRST HAVE TO
COMPLETE THESE PROGRAMS PRIOR TO
BEING ENTERED INTO THIS PROGRAM.
SO I THINK I THINK THOSE ARE THE
IMPEDIMENTS I'M TALKING ABOUT
IT'S A BARRIER. FOR SOMEBODY
ENTERING INTO THESE PROGRAMS.
SO -- AND ANNA ANNA AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT EVIDENCE WAS USED.
TO MAKE THE ASSUMPTION
[inaudible]
REGARDING -- THE COMPLETION OF
THESE PROGRAMS. FOR AN EX
OFFENDER TO QUALIFY. FOR TO BE A
QUALIFYING EMPLOYERS IN THE BILL
SO I AM.
I AM -- TROUBLED BY -- I WISH
THAT WE COULD -- HAVE THESE
AMENDMENTS RECONSIDERED AT SOME
POINT.
IF THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE --
PUTS A IN ORDER BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE. FOR EXAMPLE.
THERE THEY WOULD TAKE A LONG
TIME YOU CAN'T JUST WALK INTO A
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROGRAM AND
LEAVE IN THIRTY DAYS IT TAKES
WHILE IT IS TIME CONSUMING
[inaudible]
IT'S SO -- SO IT PUTS A BARRIER
IN THE PERSON ENTERING INTO THE
PROGRAM.
SO OF THOSE ARE THE REASONS WHY.
I WOULD -- PERHAPS AS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE FOR
GOING TO MOVE THIS BILL. TO
CONSIDER -- WHETHER THAT THE
CLUSTER WORDS -- PURSUING.
AND THAT WE SHOULD CONSIDER --
DROPPING THIS AMENDMENT.
HE STEP HEADS UP THIS ALREADY IS
ABOVE.
THE FISCAL [inaudible] FOR
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHT THIS BILL AS
IT CURRENTLY STANDS.
YEAH BUT I'M SAYING THAT THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
WHEN THEY LOOK AT THESE
AMENDMENTS DISS ACROSS?
THE PUSHES THE COST OF THE
PROGRAM UP.
ABOVE SO THE COST OF THE THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROGRAMS AND
BEHAVIORAL THERAPY ALL THESE
THINGS.
ADD TO THE COST OF THE PROGRAM
WHICH MAKES IT MORE.
IT MAKES A BEYOND A TWENTY EIGHT
POINT EIGHT EIGHT THAT'S WHY HE
IS ALREADY KEY THIS IS SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO PRIOR TO THESE IN THEM INTO
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE'S CLEAR IT'S ALREADY
QUEUED IS.
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND CENTER
NIELSEN [inaudible]
THEY ARE.
THEN THE INCARCERATED POPULATION
[inaudible]
THEIR CONSTANCE. ONE OF WHICH
EARLY ON SADLY.
THEY DIDN'T GET NURTURED
[inaudible]
THE DIFFICULTY.
SOMETIMES FROM THE WALMART
[inaudible]
AND THEN [inaudible]
DRUGS [inaudible]
ALCOHOL [inaudible]
GANGS THE COME LATER.
WHERE THE INDIVIDUAL FIND REFUGE
FROM THEIR OWN PAIN [inaudible]
THE INCARCERATIONS PURPOSES
PUNISHMENT AND REHABILITATION
[inaudible]
REHABILITATION IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
AND IT ISN'T JUST IMPORTANT.
TO GO TO A A IS TO BE ABLE TO
INTERNALIZE A A IN OTHER WORDS
GET. TO BE ABLE TO APPLY.
THE TENANTS OF A EIGHT WHEN YOU
RELEASE [inaudible]
THE CREDITS.
HISTORICALLY.
THAT HAVE BEEN GRANTED.
WE'RE TO BE BASED ON COMPLETION
OF PROGRAM [inaudible]
NOT JUST.
PUT IN YOUR BOTTOM IN A CHAIR.
AND SITTING THERE BECAUSE THAT
IS NOT CONSTRUCTIVE IS NOT
HELPFUL.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE.
WE'RE PUTTING PEOPLE OUT WE
SHOULD BE.
A COURT IN THEM. TO THE HIGHEST
DEGREE POSSIBLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
WHEN THEY ARE RELEASED INTO
SOCIETY?
AND BY NOT HAVING SOME
REQUIREMENTS. FOR BEING INVOLVED
IN TREATMENT.
I THINK IT'S FOLLY.
AND GREATLY IMPAIRS THE
OPPORTUNITY OF THAT INDIVIDUAL
TO SUCCEED AND I THINK THAT
WOULD BE OUR OVERALL INTENT HERE
TO PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE INDIVIDUALS BOND RELEASE.
THE SIX FEET.
SO THIS IS A CONTINUUM OF THE
TREATMENT REQUIREMENTS ELEVEN
QUESTION RATED TO DO SOMETHING.
ABOUT YOUR FUTURE AND YOUR
DIFFICULTIES WHILE YOU'RE
INCARCERATED.
AND THEN TO AVAIL YOURSELVES OF
OPPORTUNITIES UPON RELEASE. TO
BE MORE SUCCESSFUL.
I REALLY BELIEVE IT'S CRITICAL
THAT THESE AMENDMENTS BE
RETAINED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT THAT'S
THE DEAN OF THE SENATE CENTER
NIELSEN VERY GRATEFUL FOR THOSE
WORDS I THINK THE OTHER PIECE IT
IS.
IMPORTANT TO BE A NOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS.
THESE AMENDMENTS ALLOW FOR MORE --
INDIVIDUALS WERE COMIN OUT OF
PRISON TO BE ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR
THIS TAX CREDIT.
SO AS THE BILL WAS ORIGINALLY
FOCUSED WORK READINESS WAS IN
THE BILL PRIOR TO COMING IS
COMMITTEE.
WHEN WE ADD THESE ADDITIONAL
ITEMS SUCH AS?
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL THERAPY
ANGER MANAGEMENT IT ACTUALLY
CA IT WILL LOOK A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE OF THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL BE ABLE
QUALIFY FOR THIS TAX CREDIT.
UNDER THE BILL THE TEN GETS MUCH
LARGER -- IN THAT IN.
PLEASE I WANT TO PUT WORDS IN
HIS IN A WAY SAYS MATH BUT I I I
BELIEVE TRYING TO BE ABLE TO
EXPAND THIS COMMONSENSE TAX
CREDITS WAS MANY FOLKS AS
POSSIBLE IN THE STATE.
IS -- WHAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO BE
A TO CAPTURE AND SO THAT WAS THE
OTHER PIECE IS THAT THE MORE --
TRIGGERS THAT WE HAVE IN THIS
BILL HIGHER THE POPULATION WILL
BE ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR THE
CREDIT CENTER MORE LOCK.
THE COMMISSION JR CENTER HUESO
THERE ARE TWO TYPES OF EMPLOYERS
THAT ARE EXCLUDED.
THOSE THAT PROVIDE RETAIL
SERVICES IN THOSE THAT PROVIDE
FOOD SERVICES AND I'M JUST
CURIOUS.
WHY THAT WOULD BE THE CASE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS BILL
FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW.
AND IT IS BASED ON TAX CREDITS
OF A EXISTING PROGRAM THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE SO IT IS WERE KINDA
REQUIRING.
OF THE THE UTILIZATION OF THOSE
SAME CODES.
I THAT ARE IN AND ALREADY IN
STATUTE.
TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS PROGRAM.
SO IF YOU WANT TO WORK FOR A GAS
STATION THAT HAS A CONVENIENCE
STORE THAT WOULD BE.
DROP THE QUALIFIED.
DEPENDING ON THE JOB DESCRIPTION
IF YOU WORKING AS A MECHANIC IN
A IN A IN A JOB A GAS STATION
HAS A RETAIL ELEMENT YOU WOULD
YOU WOULD QUALIFY.
YOU WOULD QUALIFY YOU WOULD AS A
MECHANIC YET EVEN THOUGH IT'S
HAS RETAIL SALES SERVICE YES AS
A MECHANIC.
STRAIN.
JUST SATISFY CURIOSITY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU TO SEE SOMEONE WILL
LIKELY BETTER -- ADVANCE IN
MOTION.
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
NIELSEN BY HERE BEFORE CENTER
TITLE.
MAYES RUBIO I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY I KNOW IT'S A
WORK IN PROGRESS GOING TO KEEP
WORKING ON IT -- BUT I I THINK --
SEEMS LIKE A REAL PLEASURE THE
GOAL -- AND SOME HAPPY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SO WE DO HAVE
A MOTION FOR BY CENTER NIELSEN.
SENATE HUESO THANKS FOR ALL YOUR
WORK SIR -- IN AS YOU SAID YOU
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS.
FOR MORE THAN A FEW YEARS
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR FOCUS ON THIS --
INTO THE FLOOR IS YOURS FOR
CLOSING STATEMENT THANK YOU JUST
AS YOU KNOW I WANT TO FIND WAY
TO HELP THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
AND THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
IS OFTENTIMES -- BUT JUST A VERY
INTERESTING AND AND WITH THERE'S
I THINK THIS BILL IS WRITTEN
WILL HELP A LOT OF PEOPLE.
AND AND IT WOULD MAKE OUR STATE
BETTER STATE FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS AT FOR FOR MANY
REASONS HAVE -- I HAVE FALLEN
INTO INTO THEIR CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT I THINK THIS
PROGRAM WOULD HELP A LOT OF
PEOPLE -- SO I WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATE HUESO
AND AGAIN THANKS FOR ALL YOUR
WORK -- IN FOR WORKING WITH US
THIS IT HAS A MOTION BY CENTER
NIELSEN SAYS TO DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO PERFORATIONS MISS
LANE JUST ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI ARDMORE Là.
THEY'LL THEY'LL ARTICLE IT'S
BURKE RICARDO.
HELLO I NIELSEN.
YES AND I WIENER.
WIENER HI.
TURNING YOUR THE FIVE YOUR VOTE
WE ARE GOING TO KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN.
IN ALLOW FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO ADD
ON SENATE HUESO WOULD YOU MIND
IF WE TAKE OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR QUICKLY -- BECAUSE
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A MEMBER
LEAVING IN ABOUT FIFTEEN MINUTES
THIS WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
MEMBERS WE HAVE TWO ITEMS ON
THREE ITEMS ON THE CAN TWO ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT COUNTER ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN IS OUR MOTION TO
APPROVE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE FISA
VICE CHAIR.
OF MISSING JUST A ROLL CALL
PLEASE WIRED HIGH.
HI BILL.
I HERTZBERG HELLO.
HELLO HI NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX ZERO A
VOTE AND WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT
ROLLED OPEN.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO BE TURNING
OVER TO CENTER HUESO ON HIS
FINAL BILL FROM THE COMMITTEE
TODAY THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN SB.
SIX THIRTY FIVE WELCOME BACK
CENTER HUESO THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME TO
PRESENT THIS BILL YOU KNOW I
I'VE I'VE NEVER DONE THIS
SOMEONE DO SO LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF HIGH
PRESENTS BILL AND AND I AND I
WANT TO JUST GIVE GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF SENSE OF MY MY
EXPERIENCE.
IN LIFE AND HOW I CAME TO BE
WHERE I AM HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND AND I THINK IT'S
VERY SPECIFIC TO THIS BILL SO I
KNOW YOU'RE VERY BUSY BUT IF
YOU'LL INDULGE ME [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
I USED TO I USED TO BE IN
BUSINESS AND I RAN A BUSINESS
AND A AND IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
WHERE I GREW UP.
AND IT WAS -- WELL IT'S ONE OF
THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS THAT IS AS
BEEN KIND OF THE AN AREA THAT
HAS BEEN -- YOU KNOW A LOW
SOCIOECONOMIC NEIGHBORHOOD --
WHERE YOU HAVE -- HIGH POVERTY
RATES WHERE YOU HAVE A LOW
INVESTMENT RATES.
AND AND I HAD AN EXPERIENCE ONE
TIME WHERE I DROVE INTO A MORE
AFFLUENT PART OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND AND THEY THERE
WAS THIS BEAUTIFUL BUILDING.
THAT WAS BEING TORN DOWN.
AND IT AND IT JUST SHOCKED ME
HOW THEY WOULD TEAR DOWN A ROOM.
OF A BIG BUILDING A NICE
BUILDING.
THEY WERE TEARING DOWN TO BUILD
SOMETHING BRAND NEW.
AND IT SHOCKED ME AND MADE ME IT
MADE ME -- INTROSPECTIVE AND I
STARTED THINKING WHY DOESN'T
THAT HAPPEN IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
WHERE WE HAVE -- PROPERTY THAT'S
LOWER VALUED WHERE YOU COULD
COME IN AND BUY US.
A YOU CAN GET A GOOD DEAL ON A
PROPERTY WHERE YOU CAN -- BUILD
ALMOST ANYTHING YOU WANT.
BUT THEY'RE GOING TO AREAS WERE
PROPERTIES MORE EXPENSIVE MAKING
THESE BIG INVESTMENTS AND
BUILDING THERE AND IT JUST
DOESN'T IT FROM A BUSINESS
STANDPOINT THAT OFTEN DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO SOMEBODY.
WHO IS TRYING TO SAVE WHO'S
TRYING TO CUT COSTS WHO'S TRYING
TO CREATE EFFICIENCIES WHY DON'T
YOU INVEST?
PLACES WHERE WHERE LAND IS MORE
CHEAP OR YOU COULD GET CHEAPER
LABOR WHERE YOU COULD -- GET
OFTENTIMES A BETTER DEAL ON YOUR
INVESTMENT.
AND THAT LED ME -- TO TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT THAT I ACTUALLY -- IN
ROLLED AT SAN DIEGO STATE IN AN
AND GOT A DEGREE AND AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND I FROM
THERE.
I I ACTUALLY STARTED BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION AND I START
ADVOCATING FOR MY NEIGHBORHOOD
AND FROM THERE I ACTUALLY WENT
TO WORK FOR THE CITY'S ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT DIVISION.
WORKING IN BUSINESS EXPANSION A
RETENTION I ACTUALLY WORKED IN
REDEVELOPMENT.
AND HELP TO FOCUS AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND HELP TO
ATTRACT INVESTMENT INTO
UNDERSERVED AREAS.
AND OFTENTIMES WITHOUT AN ACTIVE
PROGRAM PEOPLE WILL NOT COME AND
INVEST IN UNDERSERVED AREAS IT'S
JUST NOT GOING TO HAPPEN ON ITS
OWN.
AND AND YOU ACTUALLY NEED
PROGRAMS TO ATTRACT PEOPLE TO
BASICALLY MAKE A SALES PITCH IN
STATE IF YOU INVEST HERE.
THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO GET.
AND I ACTUALLY WORKED IN THAT
AREA AND I HAD A LOT OF SUCCESS
BEING YOU BRING IN THAT
INVESTMENT INTO UNDERSERVED
AREAS REDEVELOPMENT USED TO BE A
POWERFUL TOOL. TO HELP SHAPE OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND NOT ONLY DID
WE USE REDEVELOPMENT WE USE THE
AN ENTERPRISE ON OVERLAYS TO SAY
LOOK WE HAVE REDEVELOPMENT
DOLLARS WE HAVE AN ENTERPRISE
ZONE.
WE HAVE -- FEDERALLY DESIGNATED.
ZONES THAT ARE -- ALSO GIVE A
CERTAIN TAX BENEFITS.
SO.
WHILE OFTEN PEOPLE SAY YOU KNOW
IN NICE NEIGHBORHOODS PEOPLE
MAKE INVESTMENTS.
AS AS MANY AS THEY DO AND
UNDERSERVED AREA SO THESE
PROGRAMS REALLY DON'T HELP I
THINK THAT'S A FLAWED ANALYSIS I
THINK THAT IS BEING MADE BY
PEOPLE THAT I HAVE NEVER REALLY
WORKED.
IN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THAT
UNDERSTAND HOW.
HAVING ADDITIONAL TOOLS IN YOUR
TOOL BELT.
COULD HELP MAKE.
CERTAIN PROJECTS A REALITY IN
AREAS WHERE THERE WOULD BE NO
INVESTMENT AT ALL.
I'VE LIVED IT I'VE I'VE ACTUALLY
WORKED AND I COULD I COULD BRING
YOU KNOW MY DISTRICT AND SHOW
THAT PROP PROJECTS THAT WE
BROUGHT USING THESE PROGRAMS.
THAT NOW ARE CREATING JOBS THAT
NOW ARE PRE PROVIDING.
OF FOD IN IN AREAS THAT WERE
FOOD DESERT'S.
YOU KNOW WE HAD FOOD DOES RETURN
FOOD SWAMPS IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
NOW WE HAVE LOCALLY OWNED
BUSINESSES THAT ARE THERE
PROVIDING OF FOOD OASIS WE HAVE
SUPERMARKETS ARE PROVIDING
ACCESS TO DREDGE.
AFFORDABLE NUTRITIOUS FOODS ALL
OF THEM.
ALL OF THESE PROJECTS IN SOME
WAY OR ANOTHER WERE MADE A
REALITY BECAUSE ONE OF THESE
PROGRAMS.
SO I THOUGHT IN THE IN IN IN THE
ABSENCE OF OF OF HAVING A VERY
CLEAR STRATEGY AND HOW WE'RE
GOING TO REDEVELOP THESE THESE
UNDERSERVED AREAS.
THAT THIS BILL WOULD NOT BE.
THE COMPLETE SOLUTION BUT WOULD
BE ANOTHER TOOL IN A TOOL BELT
TO HELP.
LOCALS COMMUNITIES HAVE ACCESS --
TO A SALES PITCH OF MARKETING
TOOL -- OF A BUSINESS EXPANSION
AND RETENTION -- TOOL TO HELP.
OUR OF THE FOCUS INVESTMENT IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS.
SO THIS BILL.
IN ESSENCE WOULD CONFORM
CALIFORNIA'S PERSONAL INCOME AND
TERM IN TALK IN COME TAX LAW.
AND OUR COACH TO PROVISIONS OF
THE INTERNAL REVENUE CODE THAT
ALLOW FIRST.
SPECIFIED TAX TREATMENT FOR LOW.
INCOME THERE IN INCOME DERIVED
FROM ACTIVITIES WITHIN FAT
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED
OPPORTUNITIES SOUNDS.
IN ESSENCE THIS BILL WOULD IT
WOULD OF PASS ON THOSE IN SPEAK
A TAX INCENTIVES CREATED BY.
THE OPPORTUNITIES ON PROGRAM AT
THE FACT FOR PROGRAM -- AND AND
AND PROVIDE THOSE LOCALLY.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO DO THIS.
WE OTHER STATES IN THE COUNTRY
ARE DOING THIS WE NEED TO OFFER
OUR UNDERSERVED AREAS THIS THIS
INCENTIVE -- THIS WOULD -- WOULD
THIS WOULD HELP US COMPETE. FOR
BILLIONS TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT ARE CURRENTLY BEING
REYES NATIONALLY. TO AND INVEST
IN OPPORTUNITIES SOUNDS WHY
WOULDN'T WE ALLOW.
OUR OFFER TO RESULTS TO BIT
BENEFIT FROM.
THESE INVESTMENTS IF WE ADJUST
OUR TAX CODE AND PEOPLE DON'T
HAPPEN TO THEM AND WE DON'T SEE
THIS INVESTMENT COME TO THOSE
AREAS.
NOTHING IS LOST BUT IF WE DO.
WE COULD HELP TRANSFORM THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THEN BUILD
HOUSING BUILD SUPERMARKETS BUILD
ODD JOB CREATING INDUSTRIES IN
NOT BE BUILT THERE.
AND SO I I ASKED THE CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COUNTY TO SEE
THE THE WISDOM IN THIS BILL.
BECAUSE IT WOULD IT WOULD GIVE
THESE UNDERSERVED AREAS.
ARE AN ADDITIONAL -- A TOOL. TO
HELP BRING THOSE INVESTMENTS TO
THESE AREAS THESE ARE JOBS FOR
THESE NEIGHBORHOODS.
THESE ARE IMPORTANT PROJECTS
WHEN YOU SAY THAT THESE
INVESTMENTS WOULD WOULD GO OTHER
ELSEWHERE.
NATURALLY THEN YOU'VE NEVER HAD
TO TAKE.
A TROLLEY OR A BUS. TEN MILES TO
GO TO THE SUPERMARKET.
YOU'VE NEVER HAD TO DO THAT.
AND IF AND IF THIS PROJECT TO
BRING A SUPERMARKET TO YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD A COULD TRANSFORM
THE LIVES OF PEOPLE THAT DON'T
HAVE ACCESS. TO TO EITHER PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION OR AN AUTOMOBILE
OR OR THE ABILITY TO GET TO A
SUPERMARKET THIS TEN MILES AWAY.
I I REPRESENT.
AND I HAVE THE REP I REPRESENT
SOME COMMUNITIES ARE CURRENTLY
DEALING WITH THAT.
AND I REPRESENTS SOME
COMMUNITIES THAT WOULD BE ONE
VERY WELL SERVED.
BY THIS BILL I ALSO REPRESENT
SOME THAT HAVE ACTIVE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
WORKING TO TO BRING INVESTMENT
TO THOSE AREAS IN THIS WOULD
HELP THEM -- GIVE AN ACT PUT AN
ACTUAL ANOTHER TOOL IN THE TO
BELT TO HELP THIS.
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
WITNESS WHO REPRESENTS A
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
HER NAME IS UP.
MARIA BUT DESTACA.
EN AND SHOULD LIKE TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS AS FOR THE BILL IF IF
YOU'LL ALLOW THAT MISTER SHERMAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SANTORUM'S
BUT HE SAID WELCOME WE'RE
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES IN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THIS CALL IS PLEASE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
ON THIS BILL.
WE APPRECIATE SENATOR WESO FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL TO
LEGISLATURE -- WE HAD THE
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE HAVE SUPPORTED MANY
OTHER BILLS TO INCREASE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT INTO INTO CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR BUSINESS
MEMBERS.
AND WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE ECONOMIC EFFORT
OPPORTUNITIES TO THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS.
ULTIMATELY THIS BILL IS A GREAT
WAY TO BRING IN CAPITAL TO THE
AREAS THAT NEED IT THE MOST AND
FOR THAT WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GROUP OF YOUR TESTIMONY GOOD
MORNING SIR GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS -- PULLED LEVEL
TO APEX GROUP ALSO REPRESENTING
THAT SPENDING CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE -- CENTER HUESO
ELOQUENTLY LAID OUT THE REASONS
WHY THIS BILL IS NEEDED -- WE
KNOW THAT WE HAD ECONOMIC
ENTERPRISE ZONES AND AND THE
STATE FOR A LONG TIME -- WE NO
LONGER HAVE THOSE FOR DIFFERENT
REASONS OF THIS IS WOULD BE WHAT
I'D CALL A TWO POINT NO VERSION.
OF THAT -- USING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PLAN IT CERTAINLY
HELPS A LOT OF LATINO
COMMUNITIES.
AND COMMUNITIES WERE A YOU HAVE --
MINORITIES THAT DON'T GET THE
ECONOMIC INCENTIVES THAT IF THEY
ONLY HAD THOSE AND HAD CAPITAL
INFUSION OF THOSE AREAS WOULD
PROVIDE A GREAT BENEFIT.
AND WITH THAT -- I JUST WANNA
MAKE THOSE COMMENTS AND WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
BECAUSE MY TO SCRATCH OUT A
GREAT PLAYER HERE WE NOW WOULD
LIKE TO GET OPEN UP TO ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD LOOKING FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL PLEASE ADVANCE.
LAST CALL NOW LIKELY TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL PIC PLEASE
ADVANCE.
LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
LAST CALL.
WHEN I?
COMING ON BACK ADD TO THOSE WHO
I THIS BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE TO BE EVER QUESTIONS
CONVERSATIONS.
AND OR ANY DEBATE DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS CONVERSATIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE CENTER ABOUT -- THE
FEDERAL THE FEDERAL --
OPPORTUNITY -- ACT -- IS KIND OF
A BROAD [inaudible]
BASED THING.
THAT -- APPLIES TO FEDERAL TAX
CREDITS AND SO FORTH.
HOWEVER -- DEALING WITH
CALIFORNIA'S PROBLEMS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND POVERTY.
OF ONE WOULD WOULD [inaudible]
A OPPORTUNITY ARE TAILORED TO
CALIFORNIA BE MORE TAILORED TO
THOSE TWO ISSUES HIRING HIRING
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN THE
OPPORTUNITY JONES.
OR LOW INCOME RESIDENTS YOU KNOW
OR PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
OF FOR THOSE AREAS AND I THINK I
THINK -- THE ISSUE OF
OPPORTUNITY JONES.
BENEFITING OTHER THAN POOR
PEOPLE.
SUCH AS THE GENTRIFICATION OR
BUSINESSES LOCATING IN IN THOSE
AREAS AND GETTING THE TAX BREAK
BUT NOT REALLY.
MAKING AN EFFORT TO HIRE PEOPLE --
THAT NEED WORK -- IS AN ISSUE SO
MAYBE PERHAPS YOU CAN ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE.
WHAT I?
I I THINK I THINK MORE OR MORE
OR LESS PEOPLE THINK THOSE ARE
THE FLAWS OF THE FEDERAL.
FEDERAL PROGRAM IT WASN'T
DIRECTLY RELATED.
TO HIRING POOR PEOPLE AND
UNEMPLOYED PEOPLE PROVIDING JOBS
FORUM.
WASN'T IT -- SPECIFIC ENOUGH ON
THAT WAS MORE A BROAD BASE.
TAX -- PROGRAM.
IF YOU'RE YOU'RE GETTING INTO A
VERY COMPLEX AREA BECAUSE YOU
KNOW AS AS WE HAVE OVER THE
YEARS SOUGHT TO CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
[inaudible]
AND AND ONLY MADE THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AVAILABLE TO
PEOPLE LIVE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
IT IN THE AREAS WHERE YOU BUILD
IT YOU OFTEN RUN INTO FEDERAL
LAWSUIT -- ANTI DISCRIMINATION
LAWS THAT DON'T ALLOW.
YOU -- TO THE TWO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST PEOPLE THAT THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BENEFIT FROM THESE
PROJECTS.
WE WE I'VE ALWAYS BEEN AN
ADVOCATE OF OF OF OF HI HIGHER
IN.
LOCALLY OF OF BUILDING PROJECTS
A NEIGHBORHOOD THAT PROVIDE
HOUSING TO THE PEOPLE OF THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD AND OFTENTIMES WE
RUN INTO -- STATUTES THAT THAT
PREVENT YOU FROM MAKING THOSE
SPECIFIC [inaudible]
LAWS.
AGAIN IN THIS BILL.
WERE WERE WORKING WITHIN A
SYSTEM THAT WE WE WE ALREADY
HAVE OUR SYSTEM -- YOU KNOW IF I
IF I COULD -- CREATE A DIFFERENT
SYSTEM IT WOULD IT WOULD LOOK
VERY DIFFERENT THAN THE ONE WE
HAVE BUT UNFORTUNATELY.
WE'RE WORKING WITHIN A FEDERAL
TAX CODE THAT IS -- SET IN STONE
A PROGRAM THAT IS SET IN STONE
IT'S OFFERING US -- INVESTMENT
INTO THESE AREAS.
IF I I JUST WANT TO MAXIMIZE THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE FOR
CALIFORNIA TO TO BENEFIT FROM
THESE INVESTMENTS.
THESE INVESTMENTS WILL BRING
HOUSING IT'S AREAS WHERE WE
DON'T HAVE HOUSING IT WILL BRING
SUPERMARKETS AREAS WHERE WE
DON'T HAVE SUPERMARKETS IT WILL
BRING -- THE KIND OF INVESTMENTS
THAT WILL BRING JOBS TO AREAS
THAT HAVE LOW JOBS -- DOES.
GENERALLY YOU KNOW I'VE AGAIN I
WOULD LIKE.
THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN MY PORT
COMMUTERS TO WORK ON THE PORT.
AND I'VE ALWAYS TRIED TO PUSH
THAT BECAUSE THOSE ARE VERY HIGH
PAYING JOBS AND UNFORTUNATELY
OFTENTIMES IT DOESN'T WORK THAT
WAY.
PEOPLE MAKE A CERTAIN WAGE AND
MOVE OUT INTO A DIFFERENT AREA
AND THAT THAT HAS BEEN. TO SOME
WHAT WE CAN'T WE CAN'T PREVENT
AND THAT WE I I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD PREVENT IT.
PEOPLE US ARE MAKING MONEY AND
THEY WANT TO MOVE OUT WE CAN'T
STOP THEM [inaudible]
BUT I I AM LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW --
AT AT WHAT WE CAN GET FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND THAT IS.
POTENTIALLY BILLIONS.
OF OF INVESTMENT DOLLARS IN INTO
OUR MOST UNDERSERVED AREAS.
AND THE THESE COULD PROVIDE --
LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
PEOPLE THOSE AREAS AGAIN IT'S
IT'S WE OFTENTIMES.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL HAVING THESE
INCENTIVES COULD HELP.
UP PEOPLE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
A TRACK THAT THE THE THE RIGHT
KIND OF INVESTMENT FOR THOSE
NOTES.
NEIGHBORHOODS THIS IS NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN ON AN ON ITS OWN I
THINK OF WE CREATE THIS.
PEOPLE SOMEWHERE INVEST IN A
BUSINESS AREN'T GONNA DAHLE THE
SENSE WHO WHILE LOOK WE CAN.
WE CAN DRIVE A BENEFIT FROM THIS
PEOPLE GENERALLY NOT NOW IT WILL
BE THE THE THE THE THE LOCAL
LEADERSHIP THE DEPARTMENTS THAT
THAT FOCUS ON ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND REVITALIZATION.
TO TO ATTRACT THAT INVESTMENT
AND HOPEFULLY THEY'LL HAVE A
PROGRAM.
AND WE YOU KNOW WE HAD A BILL
LAST YEAR.
THAT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW THAT
WILL REQUIRE GOBIZ.
TO WORK WITH LOCALS ON ON ON
HELPING TO ATTRACT FEDERAL
DOLLARS AND HELPING.
TO ATTRACT STATE DOLLARS INTO A
PROMISE ZONES AND OPPORTUNITIES
ON SO OFTEN AREA DOESN'T HAVE A
PROGRAM THE STATE DOES AND AND
AND WE WILL -- ED AND I AND I
THINK THROUGH OUR GOLD IS GIVING
THIS TO OUR GOAL BUT IS.
IS WELL.
WILL HELP GOBIZ ADVOCATE FOR THE
THE IS -- UNDERSERVED AREAS AND
PROVIDE DISINCENTIVES. TWO
PEOPLE INVEST IN HOPEFULLY WILL
WILL WILL WILL DRAW THE RIGHT
pNEIGHBORHOODS.
THE ONE THAT BUILDS ON THE NEEDS
OF THESE COMMUNITIES AND I FEEL
VERY CONFIDENT THAT ALL OF US
TOGETHER.
CAN CAN WORK TO ALSO -- TRACK
THIS INVESTMENT TO COMMUNITIES.
OF SENATOR IF I COULD SENATOR
DIFFICULT MYSTICALLY SIR AUG.
OF WHEN I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
SENATE COUNCIL.
I AUTHORED THE PROPOSAL'S GREAT
THE FIRST ENTERPRISE ZONE IN
CALIFORNIA IN SAN JOSE.
AND WE HAD -- IMPLEMENTED THE
CAMP GARCIA LAW.
WHICH WAS THE FEDERAL ENTERPRISE
ZONE ACT AND I ACTUALLY HAD --
CONGRESSMAN GARCIA FROM THE
BRONX.
TOUR AND I DROVE AROUND THE AREA
DURING THE ENTERPRISE ZONE.
OF AND HE WORKED WITH JACK CAM.
OF RESERVE REPUBLICAN DEMOCRAT.
JOINT -- LAW CONGRESS CAME FROM
BUFFALO AND THEN -- REPUBLICAN
AND THEN CONGRESSMAN GARCIA.
FROM -- THE BRONX.
AND THE AGE DIGIS.
IT WAS DONE BECAUSE NOTHING ELSE
WORKED. FOR THE MURDER SOME OF
THESE AREAS AND YOU KNOW NO
OTHER KINDS OF OR MARINO OR
STRATEGIES WORK SO THE DECIDED
TO LOOK AT THE TAX INCENTIVE
IDEA [inaudible]
AND THE CALIFORNIA ACT WAS
CREATED WE LIMITED THE CALC --
FOR KIDS YOU KNOW AND AND TWENTY
ELEVEN AND REESTABLISH -- THE GO
BILL AS ANY OTHER KINDS OF
BENEFITS -- WITH -- A STUDY THAT
WAS DONE ON ENTERPRISE ZONE THAT
SHOWED.
THE ENTERPRISE ZONE PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA THAT SHOWED.
US SOME OF THE ENTERPRISE ZONES
WERE SOME OF THEM DON'T WERE.
THERE WASN'T A CLEAR GOAL.
AND SO WHAT WHAT WHAT MY
QUESTIONS ARE. FOR YOU IS WE
DON'T WANT TO RE ESTABLISH A
PROGRAM THAT REPEATS THE SAME
MISTAKES.
THAT WE HAD WITH THE ENTERPRISE
ZONE BECAUSE SOMEONE WORK SOME
OF THEM DON'T WORK AND WE WE
CAN'T.
WE DON'T WANT TO GO THROUGH THAT
KIND OF THING AGAIN LIKE WE DID.
IN THE PAST -- AND WE HAVE A LOT
OF EXPERIENCE WITH THE
ENTERPRISE ZONES BECAUSE IT WAS.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR TO TWENTY
ELEVEN THE ENTERPRISE ZONE
PROGRAM EXISTS IN CALIFORNIA SO
WE DO HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
WITHOUT.
WE KNOW THE RESULTS IN.
OF AS A TAX CREDIT PROGRAM IT IT
HAD SOME FLAWS.
HOW DO YOU REVEREND RE THING WE
DO WILL HAVE SOME FLAWS NOTHING
IS PERFECT BUT LET ME TELL YOU
READ IT DEPENDS ON HOW YOU LOOK
AT THE OUTCOME IF YOU SAY THIS
BUSINESS WOULD HAVE LOCATED?
IN SAN DIEGO ANYWAY LET'S SAY
FOR EXAMPLE.
THAT THIS BILL WITH THE THIS
DIDN'T CREATE [inaudible]
NEW.
NEW WELL YOU YOU CAN MAKE THAT
ARGUMENT [inaudible]
BUT WHETHER THEY LOCATED IN THE
STUDIO THE GENERAL INDUSTRIAL
AREA IN THE MORE AFFLUENT PART A
CITY OR WHETHER THEY LOCATED IN
AN UNDERSERVED AREA.
I CAN TELL YOU WHOLE HEARTEDLY I
CAN NAME BUSINESSES.
THAT SPECIFICALLY WENT -- TO
UNDERSERVED AREA PROVIDE LOCAL
JOBS ALL THE HIRES WERE LOCAL.
AND THEY MOVE THEIR SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE OF CERTAIN INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAD THAT NO
LONGER EXISTS.
AND I COULD PROVIDE YOU A LONG
LIST OF BUSINESSES.
THAT WERE THERE SOME OF THEM
THERE ARE NO LONGER THERE.
WINDOWS PROGRAMS AND DID.
SOME OF THOSE BUSINESS MOVED OUT.
AND WEB BUT WHERE THEY WERE IT
INITIALLY.
LOOKING TO GO [inaudible]
AND WHAT WHAT HAPPENS WITH THOSE
JOBS IS THOSE JOBS OR THIS PLACE
IN THAT AREA PEOPLE THAT ARE
WALKING TO WORK.
NOW EITHER HAVE TO MOVE OUT OF
THE STATE OR OR OR TAKE OUT --
OR A OR MATH MATH THE MASS OF
OUR OR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION TO
A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT PART OF
THE COUNTY.
AND AND THAT'S WHAT.
IN IN ONE PART THAT'S THAT'S ONE
OF THE THINGS I THINK THIS BILL
COULD HELP.
IN THOSE AREAS IS TO PROVIDE
LOCALIZED JOBS TO PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN IN AN AREA THAT THEY
ONLY LIVED THERE FOR THE TO
PORTABLE BUT THEY THEY THEY WERE
ALSO CREATING JOBS THAT ARE
BETTER PAYING JOBS THAT WILL
GIVE THEM A JOB WHERE THEY LIVE.
AND IT AND IT AND IN MANY CASES
THERE DURING GOING TO BE JOBS.
THAT THEY CAN -- YOU KNOW YOU
YOU'RE ALSO FAMILIAR WITH THAT
REPORT THAT TALKS ABOUT -- THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE PEOPLE OF
SOMEBODY HAVING A JOB.
OR OT OFTENTIMES IS WHETHER
THEY'RE ABLE TO GET TO THE JOB.
AND THAT THE FURTHER JOB THE JOB
IS AWAY FROM THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
MAY MEAN WHETHER THEY CAN GET
THE JOB AND I WANT I WANT TO
LOCATE JOBS IN UNDERSERVED AREAS
I WANNA I WANNA LOCATE --
QUALITY JOBS THERE'S BUT IN THE
END IF WE CAN PROVIDE JOBS TO
PEOPLE IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS.
IT WOULD MAKE AN ENORMOUS
DIFFERENCE IN THEIR LIVES AND I
THINK THIS BILL.
WHAT THE STUDIES HAVE NOT?
ANALYZED IS WHETHER THESE BILLS
ARE PROVIDING A JOBS IN THOSE
AREAS I DON'T THINK THAT THE
ANALYSIS AFFECTED BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T CONFORM TO MY EXPERIENCE.
I HAVE WORKED ON THIS AND I HAVE
ATTRACTED BUSINESSES TO THESE
AREAS AND THEY HAVE COME.
BECAUSE OF OF OF A OF A OF BACK
PACKAGE THAT WE PROVIDE THERE
ARE THERE ARE.
WHEN YOU COME IN AND SAY WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE YOU A FEDERAL
TAX RATE A STATE TAX CREDIT
WE'RE GOING?
TO PROVIDE YOU WITH -- A STATE
DOLLARS WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH UP OF LEASES A
REDEVELOPMENT DOLLARS WAIT
AROUND WELL.
THAT'S IT WE DO IT ALL IN AS A
WHAT WILL GO NINE THE
INTERPRETERS ON WITH THE RE I
ALWAYS BOAST OF CALIFORNIA'S --
INTACT I ALWAYS BOAST OF TEXAS
CALIFORNIA'S TAX INCENTIVE
PROGRAM AND WE HAVE A VERY
HEALTHY ONE BUT WE COULDN'T WE
CAN DO MORE FOR THESE.
THAT IS A STATE WIDE PROGRAM I I
I I THINK WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING FOR THESE.
UNDERSERVED AREAS IN THE ABSENCE
OF REDEVELOPMENT AND AND
UNLOCKED AND THIS IS NOT
COMMITTEE IN -- STATE DOLLARS
LIKE REDEVELOPMENT US A WEEK WE
NEED TO DO MORE WE'RE NOT DOING
ENOUGH BUT THIS WOULD WITHDRAW --
THOSE INVESTED AND IF IT FAILS
IT WILL COST US NOTHING NO WAY
CEREALS AND I APOLOGIZE WE JUST
HAVE -- PRETTY BIG BILL COME IN
RIGHT AFTER YOU AND I I DO
APOLOGIZE IS PREGNANT TAKE A BIT
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE OTHER ARE OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR LET'S GO TO SEND HER TITLE
PLEASE ON THIS BILL.
MISTER CHAIR UP THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS TO OUR
ATTENTION.
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY AND YOUR
PASSION I CAN SEE IT.
IN YOU AND AND EXPRESSING THAT
TODAY -- YOU KNOW AS A COUNCIL
MEMBER FOR THE CITY OF FINGER.
THAT WAS MY BIGGEST FRUSTRATION
THAT WAS.
THE REASON FOR ME EVEN WANTING
TO BE HERE TODAY IS THAT I SAW A
LACK OF INVESTMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
I REPRESENT ABOUT TWENTY THREE
CITIES IN AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES.
AND I HAVE SEEN THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT OVER THE YEARS WITH
REDEVELOPMENT ON I HAVE SEEN OUR
COMMUNITIES JUST CONTINUE TO
SUFFER.
AND I I I THINK THAT THIS BILL
WILL HELP ADDRESS ONE PIECE BUT
I THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT
WE NEED TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE INVESTMENTS ARE BEING MADE.
NOT SOMETHING THAT I CONTINUE TO
SAY -- YOU KNOW ALL THE TIME AND
I'M SURE THAT MANY IN THIS IN
THIS ROOM HAVE HEARD ME TALK
ABOUT INVESTING AND IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT THE
MOST BECAUSE UP.
YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE JUST LOOKING FOR
AN OPPORTUNITY AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO TO WELL I TO TO LIVE IN EIGHT
EIGHT IN A COMMUNITY THAT BIG
YOU KNOW THEIR CHILDREN ARE
HAPPY AND THEN THEY CAN GO TO
THE PARKS AND AND THAT.
MEANS JOBS THAT MEANS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IT MEANS THAT WE GOT
TO PUT OUR DOLLARS.
OUR OUR EFFORTS IN THOSE AREAS
THAT NEED IT THE MOST -- SO I I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU.
IN A FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
ON THIS BILL LIKE I SAID TWENTY
THREE CITIES.
EQUAL AMOUNT OF UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES -- AND SO OUT OF
THOSE THERE'S ABOUT TWENTY TWO
THAT THAT HAVE OPPORTUNITY ZONES
IN THEM SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND OUR I'D LIKE --
TO I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY AND I'D LIKE TO THE
BALL WHEN APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BETTER CENTER THAT IS THAT WE DO
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR OF
THE MOTION IS TO DO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE IF
THERE IS ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS CONVERSATION.
FROM THE COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME.
HEARING SIXTEEN NO ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATION WOULD LIKE BETTER
TURN IT OVER TO CENTER HUESO TO
BE A CLOSE PLEASE THANK YOU JUST
SIMPLY I THINK I'VE.
SAID ALL I COULD SAY -- JUST ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY FOR THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER TITLE
MADE THE MOTION TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS MISSING JUST A
RECALL PLEASE [inaudible]
OR LOCK [inaudible]
BELL.
BURGER. FOR TOMORROW.
WELL I NIELSEN.
WIENER.
WIENER HI.
KERN INJURES A THREE ZERO BUT WE
ARE GOING TO KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN
AND ADDED MEMBERS ON HERE
MOMENTARILY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANYWAY SO WE
DO APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK ON
BOTH TEN ITEM TEN IN ITEM.
EIGHTEEN I CENTER HUESO IN HIS
TEAM IS WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN OF
COMMITTEE WE'D LIKE TO GO TO
TAKE CARE OF SOME HOUSEKEEPING
FIRST WE'D LIKE TO INVITE ASSN
OR JACKSON BUTTE TO COME FORWARD.
I SHE'S CMING FORWARD.
WE ARE GOING TO BE WORKING THE
FILE.
UNTIL ABOUT TWELVE FIFTEEN
TWELVE THIRTY ISHE.
WITHIN GONNA TAKE A QUICK HALF
HOUR RECESS AND COME BACK AT ONE
O'CLOCK IN THIS ROOM.
BUT WE DO HAVE SOME INDIVIDUALS
FROM THE COMMITTEE THEY'RE GONNA.
HAVE OTHER OBLIGATIONS AT THAT
TIME -- AND THEN WILL ALLOW
FOLKS WITH A CALM MIND AND ON AT
APPROXIMATELY ONE PM H.
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
LADIES IN GERMAN NOW LIKE WE ARE
TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
THIS IS SB.
FOUR SIXTY EIGHT BEFORE THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SANTA BARBARA GET
STARTED I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE CENTER JACKSON
AND SAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
ISSUE AND ABLE TO DRIVE A
COMPROMISE SAID GOOD NAY VANCE'S
DATA DRIVEN.
TRANSPARENT.
UP PROCESS IN THE MINDS IN YEARS
TO COME ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
ADAM SENATOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
WITH THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
SHOULD JUST SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AFTER YOUR KIND REMARKS
BUT I WILL PRESENT BECAUSE THIS
IS A A NEW ISSUE THAT REALLY IS
IS A NON PARTISAN ISSUE -- YOU
KNOW WE'RE LOOKING FOR GOOD
GOVERNMENT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY WE'RE LOOKING FOR
TRANSPARENCY -- WHEN IT COMES TO
THE USE OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS?
SO THE SP FOUR SIXTY EIGHT IS A
GOOD GOVERNMENT MEASURE THAT
WILL HELP US IMPROVE OUR SYSTEM
OF TAX CREDITS TAX DEDUCTIONS
AND TAX EXEMPTIONS. TO ENSURE
WE'RE MAKING THE BEST USE OF OUR
LIMITED PUBLIC DOLLARS SOMETHING
WHICH I KNOW MY GOOD FRIEND
SENATOR MORE LOCKED DOWN AN
ORANGE COUNTY TALKS ABOUT.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND TO THIS
IS A A BILL I THINK HE SHOULD
LOVE.
SO I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE
CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEES
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH ME ON
THE BILL AND I AM TAKING
ACCEPTING AS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS.
A SERIES OF AMENDMENTS ACTUALLY
REFOCUS THE A CURRENT CONTENT OF
THE BILL BY CREATING AN
INDEPENDENT BODY.
CALLED THE CALIFORNIA TAX
EXPENDITURE REVIEW BOARD WHICH
SOMEDAY WILL PROBABLY WOULD BE
REFERRED TO IS CAL TURBA.
AS WE DO EVERYTHING IN ACRONYMS
HERE.
BUT THIS BOARD WILL CREATE A
PUBLIC PROCESS FOR THIS
INDEPENDENT BODY TO SET UP A
SCHEDULE. FOR THE EVALUATION OF
THE STATE'S MOST COSTLY TAX
EXPENDITURES ULTIMATELY ONCE
EVALUATIONS BY THE LA OWES
OFFICE ARE COMPLETE.
THIS FIVE MEMBER BOARD WILL MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON WHETHER TO
CONTINUE.
ALTER REPEAL OR AMEND THESE
EIGHT TAX EXPENDITURES THAT ARE
CAPTURED UNDER THIS BILL.
NOW CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS
NEARLY EIGHTY OF THESE TAX
EXPENDITURES WITCHER ESSENTIALLY
TAX CREDITS -- THAT WE GIVE TO
OF VARIOUS CORPORATIONS THEIR
PROVISIONS IN THE TAX CODE THEY
INCLUDE TAX CREDITS TAX
DEDUCTION SALES TAX EXEMPTIONS.
AND INCOME EXCLUSIONS THE REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF TAX COLLECTED IN
EXCHANGE FOR AN INTENDED PUBLIC
POLICY OBJECTIVE.
MANY TAX EXPENDITURES SO WERE
CREATED DECADES AGO TO ACHIEVE
CERTAIN GOALS AND ECONOMIC
BENEFITS SUCH AS IMPROVING
INDUSTRY COMPETITIVENESS.
INFLUENCING TAXPAYER BEHAVIOR OR
SPURRING ECONOMIC GROWTH ALL
WORTHY GOALS BUT THEY HAVE SAT
ON THE BOOKS FOR DECADES WITHOUT
ANY SCRUTINY ANY OVERSIGHT OR
EVEN THE NECESSARY TO DEMINT
DATA TO DEMONSTRATE THE RESULTS.
THIS TAX EXPENDITURES KERRY
SIGNIFICANT COSTS TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE SAME MANNER
IS SPENDING PROGRAMS.
THIS YEAR TAX EXPENDITURES WILL
REDUCE REVENUE TO THE GENERAL
FUND BY SOME SIXTY SIX BILLION
DOLLARS.
THAT IS A LOT OF MONEY.
EVERY DOLLAR OF A TAX
EXPENDITURE THE DOES NOT
GENERATE ITS COST IN NEW REVENUE.
TAKES APPROXIMATELY FORTY CENTS
OUT OF CALIFORNIA'S CLASSROOMS
THE A PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
AND REDUCES THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR CRITICAL
PUBLIC SERVICES.
ARE THESE TAX EXPENDITURES WORTH
THEIR COST.
IT'S A FAIR AND STRAIGHTFORWARD
QUESTION THE UNFORTUNATE FACT IS
WE HAVE NO IDEA.
A TWENTY FIFTEEN AUDIT BY THE
STATE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR REGARDING THE STATE'S
TAX EXPENDITURES CONCLUDED QUOTE.
ADOPTING OVERSIGHT METHODS WOULD
IMPROVE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
STATE'S CURRENT AND FUTURE TAX
EXPENDITURES PROVIDING THE
LEGISLATURE WITH MORE
INFORMATION AND A BETTER
ACCOUNTING OF THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS.
AND IMPACT.
A TWENTY SEVENTEEN REPORT
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH BY THE PEW
CHARITABLE CREW A TRUSS.
SCORED CALIFORNIA AS TRAILING
WITH TWENTY EIGHT OTHER STATES
AHEAD OF US IN EVALUATING THEIR
TAX INCENTIVE PROGRAMS AND
INFORMING THEIR LEGISLATURES TO
THE VALUES OF SUCH PROGRAMS.
AND THESE ARE RED STATES AND
BLUE STATES STATES FROM ALABAMA
FLORIDA MISSISSIPPI INDIANA.
MARYLAND THE STATE OF WASHINGTON
THE LIST GOES ON THIS IS SHOWS
GOOD GOVERNANCE.
THIS MEASURE SB FOUR SIXTY EIGHT
WILL BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
EXAMINING SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST TAX EXPENDITURES. TO
EVALUATE WHETHER THEY'RE
ACHIEVING THEIR GOALS.
THIS BILL CHOOSES AMONG THE
LARGEST OF THE TAX CREDITS AND
SALES TAX EXEMPTIONS.
THAT HAVE NO METRICS IN
EXISTENCE TO DETERMINE EFFICACY
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM NO SUN
SETTING PROVISIONS AND RESULT IN
REVENUE LOSSES OF GREATER THAN A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
PER TAX CREDIT.
THE BILL CREATES SAID INTEREST I
APOLOGIZE BUT BECAUSE THIS IS
NEW AND IN ON THERE ACTUALLY THE
THE OLD ANALYSIS IS.
MOOT NOW IT'S BEEN REPLACED BY
THE THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VEBEEN WORKING ON THAT WE'RE
TAKING YESTERDAY.
BUT THIS BILL CREATES A NON
PARTISAN BOARD COMPRISED OF THE
STATE COMPTROLLER THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST.
THE STATE AUDITOR THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE OR
THEIR DESIGNEES AND A
REPRESENTATIVE WHICH STATE TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION TO CREATE
A SCHEDULE FOR THE LA OWES
OFFICE. TO ANALYZE THESE TAX
EXPENDITURES TO DETERMINE IF
THEY ARE INDEED ACHIEVING THE
GOALS INTENDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND ONCE THE LA -- COMPLETED TO
ANALYSIS THE BOARD HAVING
CONSIDERED INFORMATION FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE PUBLIC
REGARDING THE OZONOLYSIS WILL
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
AS TO WHETHER THE TAX
EXPENDITURE AT ISSUE IS INDEED
MEETING THE PURPOSES FOR WHICH
IT WAS ESTABLISHED OR WHETHER IT
IS NOT.
AND SHOULD BE ALTERED CONTINUED
OR REPEALED THE BILL THEN
REQUIRES THIS COMMITTEE.
IN CONCERT WITH THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND TAX TO
HOLD A SPECIAL EXCUSE ME A JOINT
PUBLIC HEARING TO CONSIDER THE
LA OWES REPORT IN THE BOARD'S
RECOMMENDATIONS.
IT WOULD BE MY HOPE THEM THAT
FOR ANY TAX EXPENDITURE FOUND TO
HAVE OUT LIVED OR STRAIGHT FROM
ITS PURPOSE THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD VOTE TO ALTERNATE A TO
ALTER OR TERMINATED.
ON THE OTHER HAND IF IT IS
INDEED MEETING THE EXPECTATIONS
OR DOING THINGS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S FEELS ARE STILL
APPROPRIATE IT WOULD RETAIN.
THAT TAX READ SO.
AGAIN THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE NEVER DONE IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY AND ONE I HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE CAN BUILD ON IT WILL
BRING TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO CALIFORNIA'S
TAX CONCERN OF A PROCESS BY
CREATING A MECHANISM.
AND A PUBLIC REVIEW PROCESS OF
SO SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
COSTLY TAX EXPENDITURES.
IT WILL ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO
DETERMINE WHICH OF THEM ARE COST
EFFECTIVE PROPERLY DESIGNED IN
AFFECTING THE THEIR INTENDED
PUBLIC POLICY OBJECTIVES AND
WITH THAT I HAVE WITH ME HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL JENNIFER
BAKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND CHERYL
HE DAY.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATE JACKSON
MEMBERS.
YOUR OFFICES YESTERDAY AFTERNOON
RECIEVE THE AMENDMENTS HI IS
WELL AS A SUMMARY FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
IS THE COMMITTEE INTERESTED IN
SEEING THE SUMMARY AND
AMENDMENTS OR DO YOU ALL HAVE
THEM WITH YOU.
HAVE THEM PERFECT JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ALL IN THE
LOOP -- AS YOUR OFFICES RECEIVE
THEM ON THE LAST DAY OF APRIL IN
THE AFTERNOON WHEN I WOULD LIKE
TO GO TO TURN IT OVER TO MISTER
BAKER AND THEN TURNED OVER THE
SEAT A BAKERY OF TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JENNIFER
BAKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION I'M HERE TO
PROVIDE ANY TECHNICAL BACKGROUND
IN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I'D LIKE
TO TURN MY TIME OVER. TO JODIE
DAVE BARRY WHO'S GOT A
REPRESENTING CTA ON BEHALF OF
OUR INANCING PUBLIC EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND SHE SERVICES
ASSIGNS COORDINATOR FOR AT LAKE
TAHOE ELEMENTARY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER BAKER'S
SO WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO IS
THAT MISS BAKER USE
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY SECONDS
OVER TWO MINUTES -- MISSED IN
HIS MISTAKE CORRECT -- STATE
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE YOU%
WITH AT THREE AND A HALF MINUTES
BECAUSE THAT WOULD.
BE THE REMAINDER OF THE TOTAL OF
FOUR AND THEN WHEN WE HAVE THOSE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A PRIMARY AUTHOR
IN THE END EXCUSE ME A PRIMARY
WITNESS AND THENTO SECONDARY
WITNESSES.
WHO HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH SO WE
HAVE EQUAL TIME FOR ALL SIDES?
THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE
THREE AND A HALF MINUTES AND WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU CHAIR.
A GOOD MORNING -- MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
AM JUDY DAY VERY THE CHAIR
FINANCE AND PUBLIC EDUCATION FOR
C. T..
EIGHT THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
THIS OPPORTUNITY DISCUSSES MUCH
OVERDUE AND NEEDED CONVERSATION
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY REGARDING
CALIFORNIA'S TAX DOLLARS.
AS THE GOOD SENATOR MENTIONED
ALREADY -- LEGISLATORS HAVE
INCREASINGLY TURNS TO TAX
CREDITS TO ADVANCE POLICY
INTERESTS AND OFTEN NOT FULLY
UNDERSTANDING OR DEBATING THE
IMPACT OF THOSE TAX CREDITS OR
EXEMPTIONS ON THE STATE'S
GENERAL FUND OBLIGATIONS OR
SCHOOLS FUNDING THROUGH --
SCHOOL FUNDING THROUGH PROP.
NINETY EIGHT EVERY DOLLAR AS A
SENATOR MENTIONED -- OF TAX
CREDIT. TO THE GENERAL FUND
TAKES APPROXIMATELY FORTY CENTS
OUT OF CALIFORNIA CLASSROOMS.
REPRESENTING THE SHARE OF
REVENUES THAT WOULD HAVE GONE TO
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FROM
THE GENERAL FUND.
CALIFORNIA HAS SPENT MORE THAN
SIXTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN TAX
CREDITS AND EXEMPTIONS IN THE
PAST DECADE.
THE PROPOSITION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT SHARES OF THESE TOP
TAX CREDITS AND EXEMPTIONS
TOTALED MORE THAN TWENTY SIX
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
DURING THE SAME DECADE OF
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN CALIFORNIA CUT
SIXTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS FROM
SCHOOLS TO BALANCE THE BUDGET
DURING THE RECESSION.
AS EDUCATORS WE ARE HELD TO
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
EVERY DAY -- OUR STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES.
BOTH TAX CREDITS AND EXEMPTIONS
NEED TO BE TRANSPARENT AND
STREAMLINED. TO READ TO BE
REGULARLY EVALUATED ON THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS TO THE STATE.
AS THE STATE AUDITOR NOTED IN A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATOR IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SOMEBODY'S TAX
CREDITS ARE NOT ACHIEVING THEIR
GOALS AND OTHERS MAY NEED TO BE
UPDATED TO ENSURE THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO MEET THEIR GOALS.
AS YOU KNOW PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS SUFFERED GREATLY DURING
THE LAST ECONOMIC DECLINE AND
OUR SCHOOLS ARE JUST BARELY
STARTING TO CLIMB THE WAY BACK.
UP.
STUDENTS AND EDUCATORS NEED THE
LEGISLATOR TO CREATE A PROCESS
IN WHICH THE MONEY USED FOR TAX
CREDITS CAN BE AB VALUE EIGHT
FOR THEIR ECONOMIC IMPACT. TO
ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S GETTING OUR
RETURN ON ITS INVESTMENT.
IF THIS IS NOT DONE HOW CAN WE
BE SURE THAT THE PAST AND
CURRENT.
REDUCTIONS EDUCATION FUNDING AS
A RESULT OF THESE TAX CREDITS
AND EXEMPTIONS ARE REALLY WORTH
IT.
AS AMENDED SB FOR SIXTY WILL
CREATE A COMPREHENSIVE PROCESS
TO EXCESS THE FACT IN THIS OF
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST TAX CREDITS
AND EXEMPTIONS.
ALLOWING FOR THE RECOMMENDATION
OF THE LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE
WHICH CAN OF WHICH YOU CAN USE
TO MAKE MORE INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT THE COST OF TAX CREDITS
AGAINST THE INVESTMENT IN
QUALITY PUBLIC EDUCATION.
MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF AS WELL
SENATOR JACKSON AND HER STAFF
FOR THE COLLABORATION AND
COMMITMENT. TO THIS ISSUE.
THIRTY SECONDS I RESPECTFULLY ON
THE BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND ALL THE
CHILDREN THAT WE SERVE.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH STAYS IN
GERMAN NOW CAN OPEN IT UP FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT TO BE A
TO PROVIDE AT TESTIMONY WE'RE
GONNA ASK.
THESE INDIVIDUALS TO BE ABLE TO
STAY AT YOUR FIRST AND LAST AS
WELL AS YOUR ORGANIZATION IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD AT
THIS TIME.
THE WINNER TO SELL EITHER ALEX
TO CAPRI ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
WE HAVE A PROGRAM TO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA -- TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIR FOR HIS WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD IN SUPPORT
THINKING.
THE SECOND CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
JENNY LIBERTY CITED IN HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT EAST I TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION SAN JOSE SUPPORT.
ALICIA SALGADO MORAL MILPITAS
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT.
THIS IS A BILL IN SUPPORT CITY.
THANK YOU MARK MCDONALD MCCALLUM
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE FOOTHILL
THE ANSWER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
SERRA BOTCHES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
OVER TO MORE HE GONNA BE HAVE A
FOR A UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
MATH AND SCIENCE TEACHER SUPPORT.
READING BONNIE SCHATTEN CTA AS A
FORTY YEAR TEACHER OF FIRST AND
SECOND GRADE AND BURBANK I'M IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MORNING HELLO LAUREN MANNING --
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
PRETENDING.
THE MORNING.
THE MORNING JULIANNE NEIL
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING SIR.
DAVE WALRATH REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MORNING CHRIS
FAMILY FRESNO TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CTA
SUPPORT YOU VIRGINIA.
PRIME MACLAINE AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
MORNING REGISTER ON BEHALF THE
ANAHEIM SECONDARY TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH MORNING GOOD MORNING
MARC ALBERT ON BEHALF
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN SUPPORT.
YOU SO MUCH AND SHALL RECEIVE
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
AND SURELY DEVON THE
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNOR'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH I'M VERY GRATEFUL THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WITH THAT VERY DO A LAST CALL
FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT
LASKAR FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO INVITE ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS INTO SECONDARY
WITNESSES TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
AND THEN WILL ALSO HAVE THE
REMAINDER OF THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED TO BE ABLE TO COME TO
THE MICROPHONE.
WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR THOSE WHO
WHO SPOKE IN SUPPORT TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE WAY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY OPPOSE THEN LOST WILL
ASK FOLKS TO BE TO COME BACK UP.
ALL RIGHT SO I TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE FAIR AND EQUAL TIME
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ONE PRIMARY
SPEAKER.
AND THEN. TO SECONDARY SPEAKERS
THE SECONDARY SPEAKERS WILL BE
ALLOWED TO MINUTES EACH.
ALL RIGHT WHO'S GONNA BE OUR
PRIMARY SPEAKER IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE THE FLOOR IS YOURS IS
MADE [inaudible]
WHAT'S THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR IS
YOURS.
MR CHURCH MEMBERS THERESA MAY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION FIRST OF
ALL WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE WORK ON
THE BILL AND THE AUTHOR AND HER
STAFF FOR BEING OPEN TO OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT TAXATION ON
INNOVATION AND JOB CREATION.
ARE WE JUST RECEIVED THE
AMENDMENTS YESTERDAY AFTERNOON
SO WE HAVE NOT HAD A FULL
COMPLETE ANALYSIS OF THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
HOWEVER WE DO KNOW THAT THIS IS
A A GREAT IMPROVEMENT OVER THE
ORIGINAL BILL AS INTRODUCED.
AND ALSO WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION BUT WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS SOME OBSERVATIONS
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
THE FIRST CONCERN THAT WE HAVE
IS THERE IS CURRENTLY NO
REPRESENTATION ON THE REVIEW
BOARD BY BUSINESSES OR EMPLOYERS
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BOARD IS TO BE REPRESENTED
IN COMPRISE A FIVE GOVERNMENT
REPRESENTATIVES INCLUDING THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFICE AND
THE LEO.
THAT BUT THERE IS EXPRESSLY NO
REPRESENTATION FROM CALIFORNIA'S
BUSINESSES OR EMPLOYERS.
SIMILAR REVIEW COMMITTEES
TYPICALLY INCLUDE A
REPRESENTATIVE OVER PRESENT MANY
OF REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
STUDY GROUP THAT IS BEING
DISCUSSED.
WE BELIEVE THAT IF THIS IS TRULY
GOING TO BE A COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW.
THAT THE BOARD ADD ADDITIONAL
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
IF YOU REALLY WANT TO KNOW.
HOW POLICIES ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED?
PLEASE ASK FOR THE EMPLOYERS AS
WELL AS THE BUSINESS MEN AND
WOMEN AND WE SAID WE
RESPECTFULLY SUGGEST THAT THEY
BE ADDED AND BE GIVEN AN EQUAL
VOICE ON THE BOARD.
THE SECOND CONCERN THAT WE HAVE
IS WE SUGGEST INCLUSION OF
VARIOUS REVIEW FACTORS.
CURRENTLY SECTION FORTY FOUR E.
FORTY THREE EXCUSE ME OUTLINES
THE SCOPE OF THE STUDY TO BE
ENVISIONED AND TO BE COMPLETED
AGO LONG WITH THE TIME FRAMES.
TO PROVIDE A MORE ACCURATE AND
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF THE
STUDY.
BESIDES THIS LOOKING AT THE
GENERAL FUND LOSS WE YOU PROPOSE
THAT WE SUGGEST A BROADER LOOK
AT THE GENERAL FUND IMPACTS IN
TOTAL.
AND SUGGESTS THAT THE CITY ALSO
REPORT ON MULTIPLIER EFFECTS AS
SUGGESTED BY THE PEW INSTITUTE.
THOSE MULTIPLIER FACTS ARE FACTS
THAT HAVE A RIPPLE EFFECT
THROUGH THE ECONOMY.
SPECIFICALLY THOSE FACTORS THE
WE SUGGEST THE STUDY LOOK AT
INCLUDE NUMBER ONE INCREASED
GENERAL FUND REVENUE FROM JOBS.
EMPLOYMENT WAGES AND BUSINESS
INCOME RELATED TO THESE TAX
INCENTIVES.
NUMBER TO INCREASE THE LOCAL
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE FROM
BUSINESS INVESTMENT AND
HOMEOWNERSHIP WHICH ARE A MAJOR
SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS
AND EDUCATION.
THIRD TAKE A LOOKING AT A
REDUCTION IN GENERAL FUND
SPENDING FOR PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
AS A GREAT EMPLOYMENT WOULD
REDUCE SPENDING AND PRODUCE
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS FOR THESE
PROGRAMS.
AND THESE ARE JUST TO NAME A FEW
BASED ON OUR PRELIMINARY
ANALYSIS.
THIRDLY WE ALSO SUGGESTS A
REVIEW OF OUR COMPETITION. FOR
EXAMPLE THE AMENDMENTS REQUIRE
LISTING A COMPARABLE A
COMPARABLE LIST THE FEDERAL
CREDIT.
BUT WHY NOT ALSO ADDRESS THE
COMPETITION THAT WE HAVE AMONG
OTHER STATES.
WHAT ARE COME IN SENATORS BEING
OFFERED BY OTHER STATES HOW DO
THEY STACK UP TO OUR INCENTIVES?
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST IN THAT
REGARD WHAT WILL BE THE LAST OR
STATE BOTH IN TERMS OF JOBS AND
GENERAL FUND REVENUE IF THESE
POLICIES WERE ELIMINATED.
AND THOSE JOBS AND EMPLOYMENT
WERE TO MOVE TO OTHER STATES
ONCE AGAIN THIS IS BASED ON OUR
ON OUR VERY PULMONARY VIEW WE
HAVE OTHER THOUGHTS AND
SUGGESTIONS AND WE'D CONTINUE.
TO WORK WITH YOU AND THE AUTHORS
FOR IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
AMENDMENTS.
NO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THOSE
INITIAL THOUGHTS IN WHAT SOME
COMMENTS AND AND VERY GRATEFUL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TO REVIEW.
SPAGHETTI FORESHORES YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES A MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRIS MAKAYLA ON BEHALF
OF THE COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND I'D
LIKE TO ALSO THANK.
YOU AND YOUR STAFF AND CENTER
JACKSON AND HER STAFF THE MOST
OBJECTIONABLE PROVISION -- THE
I. E. THE AUTOMATIC SUNSET DATE
IS OBVIOUSLY REMOVED -- SO THE
MOST PROBLEMATIC PROVISION IS A
IT IS GONE HOWEVER WE DO HAVE A
NUMBER OF ISSUES AS AN INITIAL
MATTER THE WAY I READ.
NEW SECTION FORTY TWO H..
ONE IS IS THAT THAT BILLION
DOLLAR FIGURE IS OVER THE LAST
TEN FISCAL YEARS RATHER THAN
ANNUAL.
AND I HEARD ANNUAL IN THE
EXPLANATION EARLIER AND I'M NOT
QUITE CLEAR WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
AN ANNUAL OR A DECADE LONG
PERIOD.
AND WHICH ITEMS WILL ACTUALLY BE
PICKED UP.
OUR LIST OF THAT I DON'T THINK
THAT GENERALLY MY CLIENT OR
GENERALLY THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
HAS HAD ANY OBJECTIONS TO THE
NOTION OF STUDYING -- TAX
EXPENDITURES OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
QUITE A BIT OF INFORMATION OUT
THERE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
RELEASES AN ANNUAL --
DOCUMENTATION EXPLAINING WHAT
THOSE ARE IN THE ESTIMATED
FISCAL IMPACT OF THE STATE'S
GENERAL FUND.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN WE WORK WITH
SENATOR LANDAU IN THE BILL
THAT'S REFERENCED IN YOUR
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT NOW
REQUIRES.
ALL NEW CREDITS TO BE SUBJECT TO
EVALUATION -- METRICS --
CERTAINLY -- THE COMMITTEES IN
THE POLICY COMMITTEES IN BOTH
HOUSES HAVE LOOKED TO NOT ONLY
METRICS FOR NEW TAX EXPENDITURES.
BUT ALSO GENERALLY SUNSET DATES
AND IN FACT THERE IS PENDING
LEGISLATION.
CURRENTLY IN THE OTHER HOUSE
THAT WOULD CODIFY THOSE
COMMITTEE PRACTICES.
I THINK ONE OF OUR FUNDAMENTAL
CONCERNS.
IS IF THERE IS THE STATED
CONCERN IS THE AUTHOR INDICATED
AND CERTAINLY THE SUPPORTERS
ABOUT THE GENERAL FUND IMPACT.
AS YOUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES
ON PAGE -- FOUR THE MOST MOST OF
THE TAX EXPENDITURE PROGRAMS IN
TERMS OF THE FISCAL IMPACT OF
THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND.
OR ON THE PERSONAL INCOME TAX
SIDE NOT ON THE CORPORATE SIDE
AND YET IT'S ONLY CORPORATE.
TAX EXPENDITURE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE BEING TARGETED FOR THIS
REVIEW -- SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO
CREATE THIS STANDALONE
INDEPENDENT ENTITY OF THE STATE
TO EVALUATE TAX EXPENDITURE
PROGRAMS AND YOUR CONCERN IS THE
GENERAL FUND IMPACT.
THEN WHY WOULDN'T WE BE LOOKING
AT ALL OF THOSE.
THE OTHER COMMENT I HAVE ALONG
THE LINES OF OF WHAT.
MISTER MAY INDICATED IS HOW DO
WE EVALUATE THESE.
QUIPUS MCKAY THERE IS ONE MAKE
SURE YOU DON'T HAVE A SECOND --
DOES WHATEVER IT DOES MANAGE
WHERE TO GO FOR MINUTES WITH YOU
SIR I'LL TRY NOT TO IT YET.
THREE YOUR BOSS TWO MINUTES IN
WHICH OBVIOUSLY WILL HAVE THE
FULL FOUR MINUTES TO BE ABLE TO
TEST AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
INTERRUPTING SIR THE FORMS OR
WHAT.
A LOT OF THE STATEMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE IN THIS CONTEXT
IS THE NOTION OF AN INCENTIVE
YOU KNOW CREDITS EXEMPTIONS
DEDUCTIONS EXCLUSIONS.
BUT A LOT OF THE CERTAINLY ON
THE CORPORATE SIDE EVEN MANY ON
THE PIT SIDE HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH AN INCENTIVE EVALUATION.
AND I WANT TO JUST TACKLE A
COUPLE OF THE ITEMS THAT ARE ON
THIS LIST FOR EVALUATION ONLY ON
THE CORPORATE SIDE.
BUT TO EXPLAIN WHAT I MEAN BY
THAT IN OTHER WORDS ARE INDEED
TAX CREDIT IS AN APPROPRIATE
EVALUATION OF IS IT HAVING AN
INCENTIVE EFFECT.
OF COURSE I WOULD NOTE THAT IN
THE EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES IT
WAS EVALUATED BECAUSE IT WAS
SUBJECT TO A SUNSET DATE AND
THIS LEGISLATE THAT PRIOR
LEGISLATURE'S OBVIOUSLY.
DECIDED TO MAKE THAT PERMANENT
IN LEGISLATION -- INITIALLY
PROPOSED BY CENTER ALPERT AND
THEN CODIFIED IN A IN AN ALL
QUESTS BILL.
SIMILARLY -- A LOT OF THESE
PROVISIONS ARE BASED UPON
FEDERAL TAX CONFORMITY THE E.
SOPS THE LIGHT KIND EXCHANGES
EVEN THE SUB CHAPTER S. IN THE
OUR INDIE CREDIT ALTHOUGH WE
MAKE SOME TWEAKS TO IT.
NOT EVERYTHING IS AN INCENTIVE I
OFTEN JOKINGLY SAY WE HAVE A
CHILD CARE TAX CREDIT.
IT'S NOT AN INCENTIVE FOR
ADDITIONAL CHILDREN OBVIOUSLY IS
TO RECOGNIZE THAT TAX PAYERS
HAVE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
AND SO WE PROVIDE A TAX BENEFIT.
BUT RECOGNIZING THOSE EXPENSES.
THE SUB CHAPTER S. CORPORATIONS
IS NOT A TAX BREAK.
IT'S A SEPARATE FORM OF ENTITY
RATHER THAN THE C. COURT.
AND IT'S A IT'S TREATED AS A
PASS THROUGH ENTITY JUST LIKE
UNDER FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF
COURSE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ALSO HAVE AN ENTITY LEVEL TAX
OF ONE AND A HALF PERCENT.
ARE WE GOING TO EVALUATE THE
FACT THAT IT'S IN FEDERAL
CONFORMITY.
WHAT ABOUT THE WATER'S EDGE
ELECTION WHAT LED TO THE WATER'S
EDGE ELECTION AND SENATE BILL
EIGHTY FIVE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX WAS?
THE THREAT OF AN INTERNATIONAL
TRADE WAR WITH THE THE
GOVERNMENTS OF JAPAN AND GREAT
BRITAIN FOR EXAMPLE AND WE ALLOW
THAT -- ELECTION OTHERWISE
YOU'RE SUBJECT TO MANDATORY
WORLDWIDE COMBINED REPORTING IS
THAT GONNA BE EVALUATED PROPERLY.
I MEAN WE CAN GO THROUGH ALL
THESE DIFFERENT ITEMS BUT NOT
EVERYTHING IS AN INCENTIVE FOR A
JOB CREATORS SUMMER PEER
CONFORMITY SOME HAVE OTHER TAX
POLICY REASONS.
AND THAT RATIONALE HAS TO BE
FULLY EVALUATED -- INSIDE IN
THIS TYPE OF AN ORGANIZATION AND
I HOPE THAT'S ACCOMPLISHED THAT
EVERYTHING IS NOT VIEWED AS DID
IT CREATE A NEW JOB FOR EXAMPLE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS SPECULATE.
I'M SO THE WAY WE LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO RUN THIS IS THAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AFTER WE HEAR THOSE WHO OPPOSE.
COME BACK UP AND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE ONE INDIVIDUAL WHO IT
REVIEWS OPPOSE STAY WITH US SO
IT COULD BE MISS TO MAY
COMMENCEMENT KAYLEE Y'ALL CAN
DECIDE WHATEVER WORKS FOR YOU.
SO WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE GOING
TO THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED IF YOU
GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND LAST AN
ORGANIZATION WE WELCOME YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR BUT WITH
CAL CHAMBER JUST WANT TO SAY WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE DIRECTION
THIS BILL'S GOING AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE IN THAT -- AUTHOR FOR
THAT -- WHEN THE AMENDMENTS
APPEAR IN PRINT WILL BE REMOVING
OUR JOB KILLER STATUS?
WE STILL HAVE SOME CONCERNS BUT
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHORS IF WE CAN'T TRUST
THEM THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THAT IS THAT A CELL BEYOND AB
OFF OF ALMOST LINES CALIFORNIA
GRAIN FEED CONFERENCE HE
DISSOCIATION JUST SAY NE OF THE
EXAMPLES ARE IS FOR PRODUCING
FOOD.
IS TO KEEP THE COSTS DOWN FOR
CONSUMERS THANK YOU.
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON GAIL DEL
HAVE WESTERN GROCERS ASSOCIATION
AND THANK YOU FOR THE AMENDMENTS
TODAY AND WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT
THEM WHEN THEY BECOME AND PRINT --
IF YOU DO GO INTO THE ARENA OF
HAVING A BOARD HI.
DEFINITELY WOULD APPRECIATE
HAVING AN AGRICULTURAL VOICE ON
THAT [inaudible]
THAT BOARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LAUREN
MILITATE CHECK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL AIRCRAFT
ASSOCIATION WESTERN AG
PROCESSORS CALIFORNIA CONGENERS
AND GROWERS ASSOCIATION NISSI
FARMERS LEAGUE AFRICAN AMERICAN
FARMERS AMERICAN STASHED YEAR
GROWERS.
WESTERN PLAN HEALTH AND FAR WEST
EQUIPMENT DEALERS -- WE THINK
THAT CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING ON THESE AMENDMENTS IN
THE AUTHOR -- FOR THE DIRECTION
THE BILL'S GOING BUT WE REMAIN
pOPPOSED AT THIS TIME AND STILL
HAVE SOME CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GETTING A MEMBERS ALL
OVER OUR GREAT CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES ASSOCIATION --
CALIFORNIA'S THE BIRTHPLACE OF
BIOTECH A LOT OF THESE RD TAX
CREDITS FOR THE REASON WHY WE
KEEP THOSE COMPANIES HERE
INSTEAD OF HAVING THEM MIGRATE
TO OTHER STATES -- SO FOR THAT
REASON WERE PUBLISHED THANK YOU.
THAT ANY.
DROUGHT COOK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE WERE OPPOSED A
BILL IN PRINT -- BUT WE
APPRECIATE THE MEMBERS OF THE
AUTHORS TAKE AND WE LOOK FORWARD --
TO WORKING WITH HER IN HER
OFFICE AS TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
CAME TO ME TREAT.
TECH NET AND NOW SHIP THE THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE MOVING
FORWARD THIS BILL BUT AT THIS
TIME WE'RE REMAIN OPPOSED.
GOOD AFTERNOON AFTERNOON MARIN
HAGENS ARE REPRESENTING BIO COM
WE ALSO WANT TO THANK THE TO THE
CHAIR AND THE AUTHOR BUT WE
ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS WITH CAL
TAX AND THEIR CONCERNS THEY
RAISED.
THANK YOU REVENUE.
TAKE A GOOD AFTERNOON FEELING
GRIEVES THE VANCE MEDICAL
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE AUTHOR
AGAIN ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS
WITH THOSE RAISED BY CAL TAX
THANK YOU.
SO MUCH.
WOULD LIKE TO BE A DO NOT A LAST
CALL LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME.
HEARING SEE NO ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
BEFORE WE GO TO COMMITTEE WE'D
LIKE TO GOING TO TURN OVER TO
SENATOR JACKSON'S -- ON ANY
RESPONSE YOU HAVE MA'AM AND THEN
WE'D LIKE TO BETTER TURNED OVER
TO THE SENATOR AS A COMMITTEE
MUCH APPRECIATED -- THE YOU KNOW
OF I AM VERY INTERESTED IN
MAKING SURE THAT THIS IS A FAIR
AND IMPARTIAL ANALYSIS.
AND SO WILL CERTAINLY MAKE SURE --
AS WE GO FORWARD THAT THE
BUSINESS CONCERNS AND INTERESTS
THAT HAVE ARTICULATED THERE THE
THOSE CONCERNS HERE TODAY --
WILL BE ABLE TO PRESENT THEIR
VIEWS THE GOAL IS TO HAVE THEM
WORKING -- REDUCING ALLERGY WITH
A GIVE A CPA WHO TALKS TO THE
VARIOUS DIFFERENT.
PARTS OF A OF AN ENTITY AND IT
KNOWS HOW TO ASK THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS AND KNOWS HOW TO DO
THE ANALYSIS AND BRINGS THAT.
ANALYSIS FORWARD -- SO THAT THE
EXPERTS CA TAKE A LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS AND PRIORITIZE WHAT THE
NEEDS ARE OF WHAT THE VALUES ARE
THAT'S WHY WE CALL FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION -- SO WE ARE --
CERTAINLY -- NOT ATTEMPTING TO
PUT THE THUMB ON ANYTHING HERE --
THE SCALES ARE SUPPOSED TO BE --
FOR AND THIS PASSIONATE -- WE'RE
LOOKING WE'RE HOPING TO LOOK AT
ALL THE FACTORS AND SO INPUT
FROM THESE VERY STAKEHOLDERS
THIS.
IS OF COURSE GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY TO ACCURATELY ASSESS
THE VALUE OF THEIR TAX
EXPENDITURES TO OUR STATE THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING -- FOR THERE
ISN'T ANY -- CRITERIA THAT I'M
AWARE OF THAT LIMITED TO THE
INCENTIVE ASPECT THERE ARE LOTS
OF ASPECTS -- FOR THESE TAX --
CREDITS AND WHAT HAVE YOU AND
AND WE WANT TO LOOK AT THE MALL --
I THINK THE ISSUE THE FEDERAL
TAX CONFORMITY IS A GOOD ONE
BECAUSE WHAT WAS UNDER TWO
FEDERAL TAX CONFORMITY TWENTY
YEARS AGO MAY NOT BE WHAT
FEDERAL TAX CONFORMITY IS TODAY.
AND SO WE MAY WANT -- TO AS WE
LOOK AT THESE THINGS --
RECOGNIZE WHAT THE TAX LAWS ARE
TODAY AND AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE CONSISTENT WITH THEM MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE MAXIMIZING THEM.
AND THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF WHY WE
NEED TO HAVE THIS KIND OF
PROCESS -- THERE WAS A STATEMENT
TO ABOUT -- THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOING AND ANALYSIS.
THEY THEY ACTUALLY DON'T DO AN
ANALYSIS PER SE THEY THEY
ACTUALLY TO STATE THE AMOUNT OF
REVENUE THAT IS LOST BY THESE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS SO WE WILL
AGAIN THAT'S WHY WE'VE INVITED
OR THAT THIS INCLUDES A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT -- EXPERTS THAT
EXIST THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO DO
THIS AND TO BE OBJECTIVE IN THAT
WORK SO -- BASICALLY I I YOU
KNOW I THINK I THINK THE
CONCERNS ARE ARE LEGITIMATE I
I'M CERTAINLY -- ANXIOUS FOR US
TO KEEP WORKING WITH THEM
BECAUSE WHAT WE WANT HERE'S AN
OBJECTIVE ANALYSIS OF WHAT'S
WORKING WHAT ISN'T WHAT WE CAN
DO TO MAKE IT BETTER -- IF WE
CAN AND CERTAINLY -- AGAIN
HAVEN'T TO BE OBJECTIVE AND
NONPARTISAN AND DISPASSIONATE
BECAUSE TAX DOLLARS ARE TAX
DOLLARS WHETHER THEY COME FROM
REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS ARE
DECLINE TO STATE.
A IT'S THE TAX ISSUE HERE IT'S
WHERE THE MONEY IS GOING IS IT
GOING FOR THE FOR A GOOD PURPOSE
AND THEN WE BRING IT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS.
AFTER ALL THE INFORMATION IS
BEING.
COMPLETED.
BECAUSE MY CENTER THE TO PUT IT
UP TO THE COMMITTEE MISTER VICE
CHAIR WILL KICK US OFF AND WE'LL
GO TO OTHER SENATORS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON'S -- A FAIR ASSESSMENT
OBJECTIVE ANALYSIS ALL GOOD --
I'M JUST CURIOUS ARE ON A FEW
LITTLE AREAS.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE SUPPORT STAFF
WILL BE THE LA -- THAT WOULD
KIND OF BE PART OF THE STRUCTURE
IN AND I'M I'M.
AND DO WE NEED TO ENCOURAGE THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO BE
[inaudible]
VERY -- HELPFUL IN ASSISTING THE
LA YOURS I JUST ASSUMED.
WELL I THINK THAT'S PART I MEAN
IT'S UP TO DISCUSSION WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE THE
THE RIGHT INFORMATION THE
ACCURATE INFORMATION.
THAT GIVES AS MUCH DATA. TO THIS
STAKEHOLDER GROUP -- OR I SHOULD
SAY TO THESE EXPERTS -- WE DO
KNOW THE LA -- HAS DONE THESE
BEFORE -- OF THE NOW THEY'RE
GOING TO BE A GOOD SUBMITTING
THIS TO A RATHER INTENSE AND I
THINK FAIRLY -- EXPERT GROUP TO
TO DO THAT ANALYSIS FOR US OR TO
DO THE SORT OF THE FACT FINDING
AND HOLD THESE HEARINGS. FOR THE
PUBLIC -- AND THEN PRESENTING A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
SO THAT'S IT'S SORT OF A THREE
TIERED PROCESS.
AND THE LA -- STARTS TO WORK
CASH TO WORK WITH THIS BOARD OF
THESE FIVE DIFFERENT GROUPS THE
BOARD THEN HAS TO GOOUT AND
HOLD PUBLIC HEARINGS.
THEY COME BACK TOGETHER THE
ISSUE A SERIES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND THEN THE LEDGER LEGISLATURE
GOES FROM THERE.
IN THE OTHER ITEM I I WILL SAY
THAT WE HAVE IN THERE -- UNDER
AT FORTY THREE D. THE NAME IS
ANY OTHER STATE AGENCY MUST
ASSIST THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
RIGHT TO COMPLETE ITS
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT OF THE
MAJOR TAX EXPENDITURE TO THE
MAXIMUM DEGREE PRACTICE
[inaudible]
SO.
LONG STORY SHORT THAT WOULD MEAN
IN THE ALLEY -- WILL BE
CONSULTING ALL RELEVANT AGENCIES --
TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST IN THIS
EVALUATION BECAUSE IN NEED TO BE
COMPREHENSIVE -- IN LOOKING.
AN EXHAUSTIVE WAY ACROSS ALL
ASPECTS STATE GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YES --
SENATOR THERE WAS A
RECOMMENDATION TO ADD MEMBERS TO
THE COMMITTEE -- ARE YOU WAS
GOING TO JUST USE THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AS A A PLACE HOLDER
FOR THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE OR
OTHER.
GROUPS.
WELL I THINK AT THIS POINT AND
WE'RE CERTAINLY OPEN TO HAVING
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS WE YOU KNOW
IF WE HAVE THE CHAMBER THEN
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE LABOR IF WE
HAVE THIS WE HAVE TO HAVE THAT --
THE GOAL HERE IS TO BRING THE
FISCAL EXPERTS TO THE TABLE HAVE
THEM DO THE INVESTIGATION
THROUGH ALL DEPARTMENTS TO GET
ALL OF THE INFORMATION.
AS FACTORED AS ACCURATELY AS
POSSIBLE TO BRING IT TOGETHER
AND TO OF FORMULATE
RECOMMENDATIONS BASED UPON THE
NUMBERS IF YOU WILL TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH IS THE POLICY
MAKING BODY.
AND THEN OF COURSE THEY'LL BE
THOSE LAYERS OF DISCUSSION ABOUT
PRIORITIES AND WHAT HAVE YOU BUT
THE DATA HAS TO BE THERE.
AND FOR AND THAT'S WHAT THE GOAL
IS OF THESE GROUPS IS TO GET THE
DATA MY ASSUMPTION IS THAT THE
LA OR DEPARTMENT FINANCER FRENCH
I SEXUAL WHOEVER IT IS.
WILL BE REACHING OUT TO THE
VARIOUS ENTITIES TO LABOR TO THE
CHAMBER TO ALL THE DIFFERENT
GROUPS FOR THAT INFORMATION FROM
THEM AND BRING IT BACK INTO THE
REPORT ITSELF.
THE IDEA OF PROVIDING COMPARED
AS WITH OTHER STATES KIND OF A
BEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES -- IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
ENCOURAGED OR DO WE NEED TO MAKE
AN AMENDMENT I I THINK I THINK
IT'S AGAIN SOMETHING WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK ON BECAUSE
AGAIN.
IF WE ARE CREATING OPPORTUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA TAKE TAKE THE
MOVIE TAX CREDIT CLEARLY WE DO
THAT IN PART BECAUSE IF WE DON'T
PROVIDE THAT BENEFIT THE THEN
THE INDUSTRY IS MOVING ELSEWHERE
GEORGE'S BECOME VERY ATTRACTIVE
I THINK FLORIDA I THINK.
OTHER PLACES SO WE HAVE TO DO
SOME KIND OF COMPARISON TO
JUSTIFY THAT TAX CREDIT WHICH BY
THE WAY WE DO NOW ANNUALLY SO
ONE OF THE THINGS I'M EXPECTING
IS THAT WILL LOOK AT WHAT THE
LITTLE BILL.
CALLED FOR WHICH IS ESTABLISHING
METRICS AND THEIR SUNSETS ON
EVERY TAX CREDIT WE'VE GIVEN
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN HAS
TO MEET UP TO CERTAIN
MEASUREMENTS IN ORDER FOR IT TO
JUSTIFY ITS EXISTENCE GOING
FORWARD.
THE PROBLEM IS WE DON'T HAVE
THAT FOR ANYTHING THAT HAPPENED
PRIOR TO TWENTY FOURTEEN AND
THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS FILL THAT GAP
BUT DO IT OBJECTIVELY.
DO IT BECAUSE IF IT'S HELPING
THE STATE IF IT'S BENEFITING THE
TAXPAYER FITS PER IF IT'S
SERVING SOME PUBLIC POLICY.
THEN WE WANT TO KEEP IT SO IT'S
JUST BASICALLY A ME TRYING TO GO
BACK -- AND GET THE SAME ANSWERS
THAT WE NOW REQUIRE AS WE DO TAX
CREDITS GOING FORWARD IT'S NOT
OUR MONEY IT'S THE TAXPAYERS
MONEY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IT'S
BEING SPENT PROPERLY.
TODAY WE WE'VE GONE OVER A BUNCH
OF NEW PROS CREDITS MAYBE
EXPANDED RENTER'S CREDIT --
ENTERPRISE ZONES TO SECTION
EIGHT CREDITS ALL KINDS OF GREAT
IDEAS -- BUT YOU'RE ONLY
LIMITING THIS TO CORPORATE
RELATED.
AT THIS POINT TIME THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE STARTING WE'RE LOOKING AT
ABOUT THE A TOTAL IS ABOUT SIXTY
SIX BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
COURSE OF TEN YEARS THAT HAVE
GONE IN THESE TAX CREDITS -- I
BELIEVE -- OR IS IT SIXTY SIX
BILLION ANNUALLY FOR ALL OF
THESE TAX CREDITS THE ONES WE'RE
LOOKING AT HERE.
ARE ABOUT SIX POINT SOMETHING
BILLION A YEAR -- TO THAT -- ARE
A DOLLAR SHOULD DON'T COME INTO
THE STATE.
MAYBE THEY SHOULDN'T I MEAN
THAT'S THE QUESTION IS SHOULD
THEY OR SHOULDN'T THING AND WE
DON'T KNOW.
AND THAT'S FRUSTRATING TO ME AND
I SUSPECT IT'S FRUSTRATING TO
DEAL WITH GOD INDIVIDUALS THAT
FILE THIRD TEN FORTY IS AN EVER
SCHEDULE SEE THEY'RE NOT
INCORPORATED.
BUT THEY QUALIFY.
FOR TAX CREDITS OF A BUSINESS
NATURE SO I'M JUST.
KIND OF WONDERING.
HOW DO WE?
WELL WE STARTED WITH THESE NINE
BECAUSE THEY WERE.
SHE'S ME BECAUSE THEY REPRESENT --
UP TO I THINK IT'S A BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY OF TAX CREDITS
AND AGAIN -- WITH THAT THIS BILL
DOESN'T SAY WE WE CAN'T DO MORE
GOING FORWARD BUT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED NINE THAT REPRESENT
THE THE LARGEST -- I BELIEVE
CORPORATE TAX CREDITS THAT WE
GIVE AND SO THAT'S WHAT I'M
FOCUSING ON HERE WITH THE BILL.
WE SEE THAT IT'S BENEFICIAL AND
THAT IT'S WORKING WELL WE MAY
WANT TO ADD ON ADDITIONAL TAX
CREDITS BUT WE FELT THAT --
LET'S START WITH THESE --
BECAUSE THEY DO REP REFLECT
BILLION DOLLARS YEAR MORE THAT
WHICH MONEY THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
GO INTO THE GENERAL FUND.
AND LET'S SEE WHETHER LET'S SEE
HOW THIS PROCESS WORKS AND GO
FROM THERE.
OLD THE DATA YOU'LL BE LOOKING
AT IS BASED ON STATIC
INFORMATION -- SO MY MOTHER
ALWAYS SAID YOU HAD TO SPEND A
DIME TO MAKE A QUARTER.
AND SO SOME OF THESE INCENTIVES
OR CREDITS ARE DESIGNED TO
ENCOURAGE MORE ACTIVITY
ABSOLUTELY I WOULD SAY MAYBE THE
REAGAN TAX CUT GENERATED MORE
REVENUES YOU MIGHT HAVE A TAX
RATE DECREASE BUT IT.
REVENUE INCREASE -- SO I'M I'M
JUST CURIOUS TO READ.
YOU KNOW IS IS THE LA -- GONNA
BE DOING MODELING OR WE JUST
LOOKING AT JUST HARD DATA AND
THEN.
GO FROM THERE.
I THINK THAT -- AGE WOULD BE
OPEN TO THE INTERPRETATION LA --
I CAN'T IMAGINE AS THROUGH IS
THE ELIO IS CURRENTLY AND YOU'RE
TRYING TO BECOME EVEN MORE
ROBUST THEY ACTUALLY WOULDN'T DO
THE MODELING -- THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT AS WELL CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT AT THE MOMENT BUT
COULDN'T IMAGINE THAT THEY WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE AS THOROUGH
A REVIEW. TO THE LEGISLATURE IS
POSSIBLE I DO WANT TO MAKE NOTE
WE HAVE A COUPLE SENATORS HERE
AT THE MOMENT.
WE ARE GOING TO LOSE -- NEVER
SENATOR HERE ABOUT.
TWELVE THIRTY SO I JUST WANTED
JUST.
TAKE NOTE OF THAT AND THIS TO ME
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE THAT HAVE
A QUICK COMMENT AS WELL SO THIS
ONE MAKE SURE BUT MISTER VICE
CHAIR THE FORCE OR SPRING
RESEARCHER I HAVE BEEN HERE ALL
DAY.
SO IT'S A FROM LIFE -- THOUGHT
CLOSE WITH THIS QUESTION.
MR MAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO REACT
TO RESPOND TO ANY OF THE
QUESTIONS I DIRECTED TO THE
SENATOR.
YES FIRST OF ALL THE FTV
TYPICALLY PROVIDES JUST THE DATA
BUT NOT AN ANALYSIS ON THAT DATE
IS TYPICALLY USE BUT BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHEN THEY
PREPARE THEIR TAX EXPENDITURE
REPORT -- ONE IMPORTANT POINT TO
CLARIFY IS THE THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE
BUT ADVISORY COMMITTEE IS
OPTIONAL IT.
PROVIDES AN AVENUE FOR PUBLIC
INPUT BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
BUSINESSES NEED A STAKE IN THAT
AND NEED AN EQUAL VOICE ON THE
BOARD SO HAVING A REPRESENTATIVE
OR REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. TO TALK
ABOUT THE SPECIFIC AND HAVING
FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERIENCE ABOUT HOW THESE TAX
INCENTIVES WORK.
IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT CRITICAL
TO THE EXCESS THE SUCCESS OF THE
QUALITY OF THE DATA TO BE USED
FOR THE EVALUATION -- SECONDLY
I'D LIKE TO RE EMPHASIZE THE
POINT THAT THE PEW RESEARCH
FOCUSES ON ONLY TAX INCENTIVES
THAT MEANS EXEMPTIONS DEDUCTIONS
AND CREDITS.
THIS BILL GOES OR THE PROPOSAL
GOES MUCH BROADER INTO THAT WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
WATER'S EDGE EXEMPTION THE
POLICY BEHIND THAT IS TO NOT TAX
INCOME.
THAT WAS NOT EARNED IN THE U. S.
WAS NOT PRODUCING U. S. AND HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE U. S. SO
HOW DO YOU EVALUATE OR HOW DO
YOU PUT.
PERFORMANCE METRICS ON THAT MADE
THE GOAL IS.
TO TAX INCOME THAT'S EARNED
WITHIN THE COUNTRY SO YOU KNOW.
TO EXCLUDE CERTAIN FACTORS THAT
ARE NOT INCENTIVES NOT
EXPENDITURES NOT CREDITS
DEDUCTIONS.
GIVES YOU A MORE QUALITATIVE
DATA KNOW A BETTER MORE
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET ACT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND MISS
TAYLOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE A
AND I'M QUICKLY.
VERY VERY BRIEFLY AGAIN JENNIFER
BAKER THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION -- THE DILEMMA THAT
WE DO HAVE IS IF WE BEGIN TO ADD
ON OTHER ORGANIZATIONS IT'S EASY
FOR C. T. AID ALSO OUT FOR
SEATED THE TABLE IS 40% OF THE
REVENUES THAT WE'D BE DISCUSSING
WOULD ACTUALLY BE REVENUES THAT
WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE GONE TO
PUBLIC EDUCATION.
SO -- KEEPING THE BOARD
OBJECTIVE IN A MANNER THAT IS
CURRENTLY -- PROPOSED TO MOVE
FOR WOULD BE THE MOST OBJECTIVE
MATTER IN DOING SO WE WOULD
USUALLY ADD THAT WITH THE NUMBER
OF TAX ITEM SOME OF THE ITEMS AS
A REFERENCE THAT ARE ANTI.
HAVEN'T BEEN EVALUATED FOR THE
NINETIES IT'S A DIFFERENT WORLD
THAN IT WAS IN THE NINETIES TO
QUE JAPAN'S ECONOMY AND
POPULATION IS CERTAINLY NOT THE
SAME TODAY AS IT WAS THIRTY
YEARS AGO.
BRITAIN ITSELF IS HAVING SOME
COLORFUL ISSUES WITH BREXIT AND
SO THIS IS A VERY OPPORTUNE TIME
WITH THE CHANGING ECONOMY IN
CHANGING WORLD TO BE ABLE TO PUT
THIS LEGISLATURE SEAL OF
APPROVAL ON FILE OF THE ITEMS.
THAT NEED TO JUST BE REVIEWED
YOU CAN SPEAKER RENAMED HER MISS
TAYLOR AND I APOLOGIZE SO -- I'D
SO SERVICE BAKER PLEASE MISS
RUSSIA REJECTED CLOSER MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON
SERIOUSNESS CENTER BELL HAVE --
I HAVE SOME QUICK CLOSING
COMMENTS IN WHICH I TURN OVER TO
THE GOOD CENTER FOR SANTA
BARBARA WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF.
THERE NIELSEN OR CENTER ABOUT
INCOMES.
ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT WITH THE MOTION OF THE
FOUR BY CENTER BELL I ENTERED
OVER TO CENTER JACKSON
MOMENTARILY.
LOOK THE BOTTOM LINE IS IF
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION
THIS LEGISLATURE FOR MANY MANY
YEARS WELL PROCEED MY TIME. TO
BE ABLE TO ADVANCE A PROCESS
THAT IS TRANSPARENT [inaudible]
DATA DRIVEN.
I IN IMPLEMENTS OVERSIGHT AND
REVIEW.
AND TO BE ABLE TO HAVE ALL SIDES
OF THE ISSUE AT THE TABLE.
I WHICH IS.
REASON WHY WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT WOULD BE
MADE UP OF BOTH -- BUSINESS AND
I DON'T OVERSIMPLIFY BY THE WAY
RIGHT BUSINESS LABOR AND
TAXPAYERS.
END I I THINK THAT THERE WERE
SOME.
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP.
AS FAR AS THE EVALUATION
TECHNIQUES. ONE I THINK WE DO
NEED TO LOOK AT IT'S NOT THIS
BILL SOMETHING TO CONSIDER LATER --
THE INCREASE OF PROPERTY TAX.
I THINK THAT ABSOLUTELY MAKES
SENSE AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE SHOULD BE REVIEWING -- AS ONE
OF THOSE TRIGGERS THAT THIS
COMMITTEE SHOULD I STUDY END.
OUT WHAT IS THAT POTENTIAL.
POSITIVE HATE TO THE GENERAL
FUND FROM THE AT TAX CREDIT AS
WELL I THINK THAT ALSO MAKES
SENSE I BROUGHT UP -- I THINK%
THAT WE GO DOWN A SLIPPERY SLOPE.
OUT WHEN WE START WANTING TO BE
ABLE TO ADD NINE STATE AGENCY
MEMBERS -- BECAUSE WHERE DOES
THAT STOP [inaudible]
BOB.
THAT SAID I THINK WE WILL BE
RIGHT AND I DON'T EVERYONE SPEAK
FROM THE GOOD CENTER FOR SANTA
BARBARA BUT OPEN HAVE A
CONVERSATION BUT I JUST WANNA.
FLAG IT AT THAT IT COULD BE A
SLIPPERY SLOPE AND WHAT CAN WE
DO TO BE A FOCUS ON THAT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE -- THAT WOULD
BE ABLE TO BEEF UP THEIR ROLE IN
THIS PROCESS AS WELL I THINK THE
OTHER IMPORTANT PART OF ALL THIS.
IS THAT THESE WOULD BE OPEN
MEETINGS THAT WHERE INDIVIDUALS
WOULD BE ABLE TO COME SPEAK IN
OBVIOUSLY BE ABLE TO HAVE.
THOSE MEETINGS AT ONE ON ONE
WITH THAT POTENTIAL MEMBERS.
AGAIN I THINK THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE SOME ADDITIONAL -- FOCUS
ON THIS IN THE MONTHS TO COME
AND I DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO SENATOR AND TO THOSE WHO WERE
IN SUPPORT.
OUR STATE THANK YOU TO THOSE WHO --
OR OPPOSE OR HAVE CONCERNS
EXACERBATING THAT THEY BROUGHT
UP SOME GOOD POINTS AND
OBVIOUSLY THIS WILL CONTINUE.
TO BE A GREATER DISCUSSION AS A
SENATOR MOVES THE BILL FOR THE
ONES WHO THINK IT ALL SITES THAN
SENATOR I'M SORRY YEP DANCE
ALONG THE FLOOR IS YOURS ARE
GOING TO WRITE I APPRECIATED I'M.
MORE THAN HAPPY TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS WE KNOW THE LA --
KNOWS HOW TO DO ITS JOB AND WILL
SEEK OUT THE VIEWS FROM THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY -- AS YOU
MENTION THEIR OPEN SO PEOPLE
WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THEIR
INPUT DURING THE PROCESS.
THAT INPUT THEN WILL BE
REFLECTED IN A REPORT IT WILL
COME TO THE LEGISLATURE WHERE
WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
HEAR ALL DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES
AND POINTS OF VIEW BUT IT WEEK
WE CAN'T DO NOTHING HERE WE HAVE --
ENORMOUS -- IT -- TAX.
OF CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
THESE CREDITS ABOUT WHICH WE
KNOW NOTHING AND THIS IS JUST TO
TRY TO GET SOME SUNSHINE SOME
OVERSIGHT SOME ACCOUNTABILITY.
I'M SURE THERE ARE MORE TO BE
DONE WE STARTED HERE AGAIN FOR
THE REASONS I MENTIONED LET'S
PUT TOGETHER THIS IS PUTTING
TOGETHER A PROCESS.
AND I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSING THAT.
RATE THE THE GOOD WORK FROM THE
THE SENATOR FROM THE GREAT NORTH
AND THE STAFF ON THIS -- AGAIN
THERE ARE THIRTY EIGHT OTHER
STATES THAT ARE AHEAD OF US IN
THIS PROCESS I THINK WE OWE IT
TO THE TAXPAYER -- AND CERTAINLY --
YOU KNOW IF THESE TAX CREDITS
ARE DOING WHAT WE EXPECTED THEM
TO DO AND ARE SERVING THEIR
PURPOSE AND THEN WE SHOULD
CONTINUE THEM.
THE AYE.
AYE MAKE GNOSTIC ON EACH AND
EVERYONE OF THEM I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE DOING
WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO AND IF
THEY'RE NOT -- EITHER WE ADJUST
OR WE REMOVE THEM -- OR IF WE
NEED TO EXPAND THEM WE DO THAT
BUT WE NEED THE DATA AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO DO
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
SENATE JACKSON IN ONE ITEM THAT
I DIDN'T MISS IT IS THAT I KNOW
THAT MISTER MCKINLEY AIDE VANCE
WAS AN ANNUAL OR CUMULATIVE OF
THE DECADE CURRENTLY AS IT READS
WITHIN THE MEN MEANT.
IT IS GREATER THAN ONE BILLION
OVER THE DECADE THAT'S AN ITEM
THAT WE CAN ALSO TAKE A LOOK AT
IS WELL BECAUSE I THINK THE IN
THE ORIGINAL FORM.
IS FOCUSING ON THE ANNUAL BUT
THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE THAT WILL
NEED TO BE ABLE TO FOLLOW UP ON
AND I APPRECIATE.
THE FLAG ON THAT WITH THAT WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR BELL
THE MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS THIS LANCASTER
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI WHY I'M MORE LOCK.
GOD GO.
NO I HERTZBERG FURTADO
[inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
ROBUST IN THE SHARE MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM CENTER MASON
GENERAL WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO I CENTER TO WHITE
COW SKI CENTER I CAO SKI HAS.
SENATE BILL FOR SEVEN SEVEN IN
FRONT OF COMMITTEE.
THIS MESSAGE YOUR MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO START OFF BY STATING
THAT I'M GOING TO BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON THE
CREDIT CAP WHICH WILL BE ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THE G..
AGI LIMITATION WHICH WILL BE A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
INDIVIDUAL TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR A MARRIED COUPLE
SENATE BILL SEVEN FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN WOULD PROVIDE A STUDENT
LOAN TAX CREDIT OF UP TO A
THOUSAND THOUSAND DOLLARS
ADVENTURES.
FOR A PERSON PAID ON THEIR
STUDENT LOAN THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
STUDENT LOAN DEBT IS NOW SECOND
THE SECOND HIGHEST CATEGORY ONLY --
TO MORTGAGES AND HOUSEHOLD DEBT
UNITED STATES WITH SOME
SOMEWHERE CLOSE.
TO FORTY FIVE MILLION BORROWERS
COLLECTIVELY OWING ONE POINT
FIVE TRILLION DOLLARS GREATER
INVOLVED THAT CREDIT CARD AND ON
A LOAN DEBT THIS DEBT IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY BORNE BY
WOMEN.
BY WOMEN BY STUDENTS FROM LOW
INCOME FAMILY BY STUDENTS OF
COLOR AND FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS THE BURDEN OF
THESE LOANS HAS RESULTED IN A
GENERATION POSTPONING THE
TRADITIONAL LIFE MILESTONES LIKE.
BUYING A HOME GETTING MARRIED
STARTING A FAMILY AND SAVING FOR
RETIREMENT THE PURSUIT OF HIGHER
EDUCATION ADVANCED DEGREES IS
HIGHLY ENCOURAGED IN CALIFORNIA --
BUT WHILE THE AVERAGE STUDENT
LOAN DEBT HAS GROWN
EXPONENTIALLY INCOME HAS NOT
KEPT PACE BY.
PROVIDING THIS CREDIT -- THE WE
THE LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZE THE
COST THE CALIFORNIA SEVEN KERR
TO PURSUING HIGHER EDUCATION
IT'S A MEASURE OF SMALL RELIEF
WITH ME I HAVE LERI DOLE AND
CHRISTOPHER LONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE.
BAR ASSOCIATIONS IN SUPPORT
NURTURE ABOUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR BYE CASKEY --
IN DO APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
AS WELL TODAY THANK YOU FOR
HANGING AROUND -- ALONG WITH
YOUR WITNESSES WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BE TO KICK US OFF.
I AM VERY BRIEFLY HILLARY DOYLE
WITH COVERS CALIFORNIA BARS SO
GENESIS.
THE EXCUSE ME -- THEIR COLLEGE
EDUCATION AS LONG BEEN PART OF
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
COME MANDELA YOU COME CRUCIAL
ELEMENT OF THAT.
IN ITS STUDENT LOAN DEBT IS
TAKING THAT -- DREAM AWAY FROM A
LOT OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING
TO PURSUE IT THROUGH THE
TRADITIONAL ROUTE.
THIS IS A SMALL AND IMPORTANT TO
STEP TOWARDS TRYING.
TO MAKE THAT DREAM A REALITY NOW.
AND I WILL SEE DAHLE FURTHER
TIME -- TO CHRISTOPHER LONG
WHO'S A DELEGATE FROM THE BAR
ASSOCIATION OF SAN FRANCISCO OF
THE CONFERENCE.
WHO IS -- BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF BOTH THE
RESOLUTION THAT.
PRODUCES A LEGISLATION AND THIS
BILL ITSELF.
IF YOU MISTER GOOD AFTERNOON
AFTER YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TWO
MINUTES SIR.
WE HAVE A CHOICE TO MAKE HERE
TODAY DO WE WANT TO GIVE HIGHLY
EDUCATED INDIVIDUALS IN THE
STATE AND INCENTIVE ROOM TO
REMAIN IN CALIFORNIA.
AND USE THEIR SKILLS HERE BY
PROVIDING MEANINGFUL RELIEF FROM
THE MOUNTAIN OF STUDENT DEBT.
THAT THEY FACE WITH THE SPELL OR
DO WE WANT TO STAND BY AND WATCH
THESE YOUNG MINDS LEAVE FOR
HIGHER QUALITY OF LIFE ELSEWHERE.
DUE TO THE CRUSHING COMBINATION
OF STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA'S HIGH
COST OF LIVING.
AND THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS SENATOR BALLOT
KNOWLEDGE EVEN EARLIER THIS
MORNING.
THIS BILL PROVIDES A SOLUTION
BREAKS FROM THE CURRENT COOKIE
CUTTER NATIONWIDE MODEL THAT
APPLIES FROM THE IRS -- EQUALLY
TO SOMEONE LIVING IN SAN
FRANCISCO AS IT DOES TO
INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN NEBRASKA
OR TAXES JUST AS EXAMPLES.
THE STUDENT LOAN CRISIS IS WELL
KNOWN AND I'M NOT GOING TO
BELABOR HERE BUT TOTAL DEBT HAS
GROWN ONE HUNDRED AND 57% IN
JUST THE LAST TWELVE YEARS.
FROM FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS TO MORE THAN ONE
POINT FIVE TRILLION DOLLARS
TODAY. 40% OF BORROWERS ARE
EXPECTED TO DEFAULT ON THEIR
STUDENT LOANS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE ON A
PERSONAL NOTE I WORKED ALL
THROUGH COLLEGE TOOK TWO YEARS
OFF IN BETWEEN UNDERGRAD AND LAW
SCHOOL. TO WORK FOR A COMPANY'S
LEGAL DEPARTMENT TO PAY DOWN MY
OWN STUDENT LOANS.
AND RECEIVED A NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLAR SCHOLARSHIP TO ATTEND
WILL A LAW SCHOOL.
LAST YEAR I PAID MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOAN
INTEREST ALLOWED.
I NOW IN MY THIRD YEAR AS A
PRACTICING LAWYER AT A REPUTABLE
FIRM IN THE BAY AREA AND I
COULDN'T QUALIFY. TO BUY A HOUSE
IN THE BAY AREA ON MY OWN I HAD
TO REACH OUT TO MY PARENTS WHO
WERE THANKFULLY IN A POSITION TO
HELP ME.
MY STORY IS HARDLY UNIQUE FROM
MY GENERATION.
JUST LAST NIGHT WHILE EATING
DINNER AT A RESTAURANT AND
PREPARING FOR MY REMARKS TODAY.
THREE MILLENNIAL SKEWS ME THREE
MILLENNIAL ENGINEERS WERE SEATED
AT THE TABLE NEXT TO US. ONE OF
WHOM GRADUATED FROM USC.
ALL THREE OF THEM WERE TALKING
ABOUT THEIR PLANS TO MOVE TO
AUSTIN TEXAS.
IN DENVER COLORADO BECAUSE IT'S
TOO EXPENSIVE TO LIVE IN THE
STATE.
AS THESE CONVERSATIONS BECOME
MORE AND MORE COMMON.
AND THE BEST AND THE BRIGHTEST
DOCTORS ENGINEERS LAWYERS.
SCIENTIFIC MINDS TEACHERS AND
OTHER HIGHLY EDUCATED
INDIVIDUALS CONTEMPLATE LEAVING
THE STATE TO PURSUE -- THE
AMERICAN DREAM IN OTHER STATES
WE HAVE A DECISION TO MAKE.
DO YOU WANT TO SIT BY WHILE MORE
AND MORE CALIFORNIANS LEAVE.
WILL ALL LOSE OUT ON THAT
POTENTIAL TAX REVENUE IT THIRTY
SECONDS OR DO WE WANT TO USE
THIS BILL AS A MEANS TO PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL RELIEF AND SENT A
VICE PEOPLE TO STAY WITHIN THE
STATE.
THIS IS ALREADY WORKING IN
SEVERAL OTHER STATES INCLUDING
IN MASSACHUSETTS.
WHERE THE STATE OF MASSACHUSETTS
CURRENTLY ALLOWS FOR A STATE
INCOME TAX -- CREDIT REGARDLESS
OF INCOME THAT HAS A CAP.
AND SO I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
US BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT.
I KNOW THE COMMITTEES ALSO GREAT
THE SHARED TO PERSONAL STORY --
YOUR COMMITMENT TO CALIFORNIA
AND I DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE SAYING IS I'M STILL
PAYING OFF A GRAD SCHOOL SO --
IT CAN BE PAINFUL SO I THANK YOU --
AND IT MEANS A LOT YOU'RE HERE
TODAY WOULD LIKE TO BE -- OPEN
IT UP TO THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF YOU COULD
PLEASE ADVANCE AT THIS TIME.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
LAST CALL WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME.
OPPOSITION LAST CALL.
THANK YOU BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY SENATOR
BAIL.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SERRA CASKEY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ORIGINAL VOTE WHEN I SAY
THANK YOU TO SONORA CASKEY FIRST
HARD WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
BEING FROM THE BEAR YOU STREET --
SO DEDICATED ON ALL ISSUES OF
HOUSING SIR THANKS FOR ALSO YOUR
WORK ON EIGHTY USE.
AND THIS IS A DO PASS IS AMENDED
TO PREPARATIONS MISSING CHESTER
ROLL CALL PLEASE WHY AM I WHY
I'M MORE A LOT.
BELL WELL HERTZBERG FURTADO
[inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
WIENER.
I THAT CURRENTLY ENJOYS A TWO
ZERO VOTE SONORA CASKEY THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIR.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR PATIENCE GELMAN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME.
HARD WORKING SENATOR SAID A
RUBIO TO COMMITTEE SB SEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE I WANNA TAKE A
MOMENT TO APOLOGIZE TO SENATOR
INTO OUR WITNESSES.
AS YOU HAVE ALL BEEN WAITING A
LONG TIME AND WE APOLOGIZE ABOUT
THAT CENTER RUBIO THANK I
PARTISAN SUPPORT ON THE BILL.
HOT DAY SO AGAIN AS FOR A
TRUNCATED VERSION THE
PRESENTATION THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ALL THANK YOU AND I
WILL TRY MAKE IT QUICK I WOULD
MAKE MY PRESENTATION AND ALAS MY
BOOK WITNESSES SAID -- YOU KNOW
KEEP IT REALLY BRIEF BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT YOU ALREADY WAITING
SELL WITH THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
SO GOOD.
MORNING Và AFTERNOON NOW CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
PRESENTING AS BE SEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE WHICH WILL ENABLE MUTUAL
WATER COMPANIES TO APPLY. FOR
CERTAIN GRANTS FROM THE STATE BY
CONFORMING TORE FEDERAL INCOME
TAX LOSS FOR TAXABLE YEARS
BEGINNING ON OR AFTER JANUARY
FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST THINK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING ON THIS
BILL AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS SOUGHT.
LOCATE ON PEACH FOR THE ANALYSIS
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
RECOGNIZE THE FEDERAL FIVE OH
ONE C.. TWELVE TAX EXEMPT STATUS
OF MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES AND
THEREFORE THE RESIDENTS IMAGE
WATER COMPANIES AND EFFECTS ARE
TAXED TWICE -- SO THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
MAINTAINS A DATABASE SYSTEM
SERVING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED HELP
COMPLY WITH SAFE DRINKING WATER
REGULATIONS THROUGH GRANTS AND
CONSOLIDATIONS. 80% OF THE
SYSTEMS LISTED ARE SMARMY TO
WATER COMPANIES THE REALITY IS
THAT MANY MUTUAL WATER COMPANY
SERVE AREAS THAT ARE
GEOGRAPHICALLY ISOLATED FROM
LARGER PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS AND
MOUNTAINS AREAS AS WELL AS THE
STATE DESERT.
OR WATER SERVICES ARE NONE THE
LESS ESSENTIAL FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
BUT SOMETIMES DIFFICULT -- TO
CONNECT TO BETWEEN SYSTEMS THERE
ARE OTHER BE TO WATER COMPANIES
OWNED BY CITIES AS WELL THAT
SHARE IN THE COST OF OPERATING
OUT ONE IN PARTICULAR IS IN MY
DISTRICT IN THAT INCLUDES COVINA.
THEN THE HUBBUB LE BRAT AND MANY
OTHERS IN CENTRAL CLOSE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA -- WITH THAT
AGAIN I'M AN ASKED OUT MY
WITNESSES TO EXPEDITED SO YOU
CAN GET TO IT WILL BE VERY FAST --
YOU'RE YOU'RE GOOD YOU'RE GOOD
CAN RUBIO THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
WELCOME YOU SIRTO COMMITTEE IN
TWO MINUTES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO FOR INTRODUCING THIS
LEGISLATION MY NAME IS THAT I
DON'T THINK I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES.
AN OFFICER OF THE CAL MUTUALS
BOARD EVEN THE CALCULUS HERE
WITH ME AS WELL -- I'M GONNA CUT
TO THE CHASE ON WHY WE NEED THIS
LEGISLATION URGENTLY -- WE
BECAME ELIGIBLE IS MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES FOR GRANTS UNDER PROP
ONE INTEGER PROP SIXTY EIGHT OF
THOSE LAWS BASICALLY REQUIRED
THAT YOU PROVE THAT YOU'RE A
NONPROFIT -- THE WAY IT'S
CURRENTLY DONE IS THAT YOU'RE
FORCED TO APPLY AS A HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION AND I'LL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF WHERE THIS IS KIND OF
GONE HAYWIRE.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE VALLEY --
FIVE THE VALLEY FIRE DESTROYED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OVER A DOZEN
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS IN LAKE
COUNTY.
THERE'S MUTUAL WATER COMPANY
THERE THAT IN TRYING -- TO PROVE
ITS TAX EXEMPTION -- AND IF IT
EXCEPT STATE FUNDING -- MUST
ALSO ADOPT INDIVIDUAL METERS AS
A CONSEQUENCE OF ACCEPTING THE
STATE FUNDING ONCE IT'S IT
ADOPTS THE METERING CONSISTENT
WITH THE STATE'S CONSERVATION
POLICIES.
IT WILL LOSE ITS TAX EXEMPTION --
SO THE WATER SYSTEM IS
CONSIDERING DISSOLUTION --
BECAUSE ANY STATE GRANT FUNDING
IT RECEIVES WILL BE TREATED AS
TAXABLE INCOME AND IT CANNOT
AFFORD TAX LIABILITY.
SO IN THE NAME OF RECONSTUCTING
THAT SYSTEM AND IN THE NAME OF
EVERYTHING LEGISLATURE IS DOING
RIGHT NOW TO ADDRESS THE HUMAN
RIGHT TO WATER -- FOR EVERYBODY
IN THE STATE -- WE URGE YOU TO
VOTE YES ON THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU MR EXECUTIVE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HANGING WITH US
WE'RE GRATEFUL.
SIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE HAD AT
A FEW WORDS.
I'M JUST HERE CASE YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS STAVING CHALCO GENERAL
MANAGER OF ALICIA HEIGHTS WATER
COMPANY IN WEST COVINA.
AND AS THE DON SAID A US OFFICER
OF COMMERCIALS THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS GENERAL INTERPRET FOR YOUR
HERE WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO GET --
OPENING UP TO THOSE WHO IN
SUPPORT.
TEAM THE MINOR ON BEHALF OF
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HANGING
WITH US WOULD LIKELY TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
THIS TIME LOOKING FOR SUPPORT.
LAST CALL HEARING SENIOR NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO OPEN UP
TO THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD LAST CALL
COMING BACK TO COMMITTEE LET ME
JUST SEE IF WE HAVE.
WE HAVE A MOTION THIS IS A
MOTION BY CENTER BELLE DU PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS VICE
CHAIR ANY COMMENTS ON THIS SIR.
HEARING -- HEARING SEE NO
COMMENTS WOULD LIKE ME TO TURN
OVER TO CENTER RUBIO TO BE ABLE
TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I ASK
FOR YOUR RIFLE.
IN RUBIO AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU GERMAN
FOR PATIENTS AS WELL TO PASS AS
AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS.
CENTER SIROCCO PLEASE WIRE HI
I'M MORE A LOT HI Là KEITEL.
VALLE HIGH HERTZBERG FOR
TOMORROW.
NIELSEN WIENER RIO I CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A THREE ZERO ADAM SENATOR
RAND KEEP THE ROLE OPEN ADD
MEMBERS ON THANK YOU SO MUCH
GREAT JOB.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA FINISH -- I
THINK BEFORE THE DINNER HOUR
TONIGHT AT WHICH IS THE CHANGE
OVER THE LAST TWO WEEKS.
MEMBERS WE HAVE EIGHT BILLS LEFT
IF YOU'RE KEEPING TRACK AT HOME
EIGHT BELLS.
I CENTER MORE LACKEY IS FIRED UP
AND READY TO GO ON THIS -- IT IS
CURRENTLY TWELVE THIRTY FOUR
WE'RE GONNA RECONVENE BETWEEN
ONE AND ONE FIFTEEN IN THIS ROOM.
RECONVENING HERE IN. ONE ONE
TWELVE ONE TWELVE BETWEEN ONE IN.
ONE FIFTEEN WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE ARE IN
RECESS
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME BACK
TO THE AFTERNOON EDITION OF THE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE WE WELCOME YOU BACK
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE
TIME.
BUT IN GENERAL GONNA START WITH
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN SB.
SIX TWENTY FOUR BUT IS IN
GENERAL OF THE COMMITTEE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE'S
ATTENTION IS DRAWN TO THE ANY
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE SUBMITTED
IT YESTERDAY EVENING.
I TO EACH COMMITTEE MEMBER WE'D
BE HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO PASS OUT
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS WELL.
ODD THAT CENTER WILK -- IS GOING
TO BE TAKING -- IF YOU NEED THEM --
BUT ALL OF THESE AMENDMENTS WERE
DISTRIBUTED TO EACH OF THE
OFFICES -- YESTERDAY EVENING
WITH THAT WE WELCOME CENTER
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR HIS PARTNERSHIP IN
ABILITY TO WORK WITH US ON THIS.
TURNER WHAT THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BEING HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN THIS AS WELL AS A
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING ON
THIS BILL.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
THAT ARE BEFORE THE MEMBERS SB
SIX TWENTY FOUR WAS INTRODUCED
TO BRING RELIEF TO MEDICAL
SUPPLY IN DURABLE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT PROVIDERS.
WHO DUE TO DELAYS IN MEDI CAL
ALTERING REIMBURSEMENT RATES
WERE UNABLE TO RECOUP
OVERPAYMENTS OF SALES TAX?
MEDI CAL SAYS THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES FOR VARIOUS TYPES OF
MEDICAL SUPPLIES AND DURABLE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT.
AND REIMBURSES FOR ANY
APPLICABLE SALES TAX ON THE
SUPPLY OR EQUIPMENT.
THE PROVIDER THEN THE PROVIDERS
IN REMIT THE APPICABLE SALES TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION.
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE
LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZED A 10%
REDUCTION REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FOR MEDICAL SUPPLIES.
THAT WAS NOT IMPLEMENTED UNTIL
THE FALL OF TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN DUE TO A COURT
INJUNCTION.
IT WAS NOT UNTIL THE FALL OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THAT MEDI CAL
RECOUP THE 10% REDUCTION FOR THE
PERIOD OF TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
THROUGH. THIRTEEN FOR MEDICAL
SUPPLIES ARE DURABLE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT SUBJECT TO SALES TAX
REDUCTION ON THE REIMBURSEMENT
AMOUNT BECAUSE REJECT.
AS A REDUCTION IN THE TAXABLE
AMOUNT AND THUS LOWERING THE
APPLICABLE SALES TAX ON THE ITEM.
DUE TO THE DELAY IMPACTED
PROVIDERS WERE UNABLE TO SEEK A
REFUND OF OVER PAID SALES TAX
YOU DO THE STATURE LIMITATIONS
ON FILING A CLAIM.
RUNNING OUT.
I HAVE AN EXAMPLE BUT I'M NOT
GOING. TO GIVE IT TO YOU SO WHAT
THIS BILL WILL DO.
IS ALLOW MEDICALS IN LESS YOU
WANT ME TO A MEDICAL SUPPLY
PROVIDERS TO WORK WITH THAT CD
TFA TO DEVELOP THE NECESSARY
DOCUMENTATION FOR CLAIMS
SUBMISSION OF OVERPAYMENT.
OF SALES TAXES AND WITH
PERMISSION THE CHAIR I HAVE TO
WITH WHEN THIS IS TO TESTIFY OF
TERRY MCHALE REPRESENTING STILL
HEALTHCARE.
BOB ACKERMAN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MEDICAL PRODUCTS AND SUPPLIES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MR MCHALE
MISTER ACKERMAN WHO WOULD LIKE
TO GET A KICK **** OFF EACH OF
TWO MINUTES IN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MISTER ACKERMAN THE FLOORS
ARE SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ABOUT
BACKGROUND HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION MEDICAL PRODUCTS
SUPPLIERS IS A PROVIDERS OF
DURABLE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT AND
MEDICAL SUPPLIES.
SENATOR WILK SAID THIS IS AN
EQUITABLE BILL IN TERMS OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT DID NOT ALLOW
THEM TO SEEK A REFUND IN A
TIMELY MANNER.
DUE TO THE LANE IMPLEMENTATION
SOURCE ESTABLISHING A WINDOW.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT
THROUGH DOCUMENTATION -- WITH
THE DEPARTMENT VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND THE
CONSOLE WORKING WITH US ON THIS
ISSUE I KNOW THIS IS A UNUSUAL
BUT ITS OCCASION WERE COLLATERAL
DAMAGE TO THE UNDERLYING LAWSUIT
THAT WAS NOT OVER.
THE APPLICABILITY OF SALES TAX
SO WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PURSUE THIS LEGISLATION AND
SUPPORTED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MR MCHALE.
TERRY MAKAYLA THERE AND READ
NECESSITY IT'S REPRESENTING
SHIELD HEALTH CARE THE LARGEST
PROVIDER OF DURABLE MEDICAL
SUPPLIES IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S ALL BEEN COVERED I TOO WANT
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MR
CANAL FOR ALL OF THE TIME YOU
PUT IN ON THIS WE DO APPRECIATE
IT.
YOU AGREE WITH THE AMENDMENTS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SHERMAN
PRECIADO THANK YOU MISS CENTER
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO OPEN UP TO
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF YOU
COULD PLEASE.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT.
WE LIKE TO LOOK INTO THOSE WHO
MAY B OPPOSED TO THE BILL
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
LAST CALL THEY BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS IN OUR MOTION FROM
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY THE VICE
CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
VICE CHAIR AND WIENER YOU GOT ON
COMMENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS BEGIN.
AT MEMBERS RECEIVE THESE.
AMENDMENTS LAST NIGHT WE DO HAVE
AND THEN MISS HERE AT THE DESK.
THANK YOU SIR ROCCO PLEASE WIRE
HI.
I'M MORE LONG.
HELLO BILL HERTZBERG AUTO
[inaudible]
WIENER. THREE ZERO VOTE.
AND WE ARE LOOKING FOR SENATOR
MORALE TO COME ON DOWN SO THANK
YOU.
NUMBER THANK YOU MISTER WELK.
I'M I'M GOING TO HAND IT -- WE
GALGIANI RIGHT.
WE ARE WELCOMING.
CENTER GALGIANI WELCOME CENTER
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI IS GONNA BE PRESENTING
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY THIS IS ITEM.
SEVEN SIXTY THREE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS YOU
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT MADAM
SENATOR SO WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR A
TRUNCATED VERSION OF YOUR
PRESENTATION THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SENATE V. SEVEN SIXTY THREE
PROVIDES THAT DISCHARGES OF
RESIDENTS INDEBTEDNESS OCCURRING
ON OR BEFORE.
ON OR AFTER JANUARY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
BEFORE JANUARY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ARE EXCLUDED
FROM AN INDIVIDUAL'S GROSS
INCOME BECAUSE THAT.
PHANTOM INCOME IS EXACTLY THAT
IT'S NEVER ACTUALLY RECEIVED BY
THE SELLER.
IS MORTGAGE THAT IS EXCLUDED
ONLY WHEN IT IS DUE TO THE LOSS
OF A RESIDENTS WITHIN A
FEDERALLY DECLARED DISASTER AREA.
SUCH AS WILDFIRES LIKE WE SAW
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN A LENDER CANCEL THE
BORROWER'S DEBT FEDERAL LAW
TREATS THE AMOUNT OF DEBT
CANCELLED AS TAXABLE INCOME FOR
THE BORROWER?
IS PUTS VICTIMS OF NATURAL
DISASTERS ON THE HOOK FOR PAYING
LARGE SUMS IN TAXES WHEN THEY'RE
MOST VULNERABLE.
THERE USED TO BE IN ACCEPT
EXCEPTION FOR MORTGAGE RELIEF
THIS EXCEPTION WAS EXTENDED BY
CONGRESS MULTIPLE TIMES BUT
SUNSET ON JANUARY FIRST. TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
STATE LAW GENERALLY CONFORMS THE
FEDERAL LAW OF MORTGAGE
FORGIVENESS BUT CALIFORNIA'S LAW
ALSO EXPIRED ON JANUARY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN IN ORDER
TO PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS WITH
RELIEF DURING THE MOST DIFFICULT
TIMES OF THEIR LIVES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WITH ME TODAY'S CHRISTOPHER
CAR ALLOW WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER CENTER
VERY GRATEFUL FOR ALL YOUR WORK.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
MISTER CARLOS CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS.
IN SUPPORT FOR THE REASONS VERY
ELOQUENTLY STATED BY THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU DR -- THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR WOULD NOW LIKE TO OPEN
IT UP TO ANY INDIVIDUAL WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR
THIS TIME.
GLASCOFF FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU BETTER LOOK FOR THOSE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSE.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSED.
THANK BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS CONVERSATIONS OR
EMOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION WATCH OUT.
BUY SHARES ON FIRE RIGHT NOW
WITH THE VICE TO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR VENTURE
MORE LIKE [inaudible]
I DAY.
GALGIANI WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER THIS HAS A MOTION.
WHICH IS DUE PASS YOU'RE
PROCREATION FOR THE VICE CHAIR.
CENTERS A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I WELL.
HELLO NIELSEN WIENER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER GOOD TO
SEE YOU.
PLACE GERMAN THIS IS OUR TIME
FOR A TRADITION THAT TRADITION
IS -- SOME MUSIC [inaudible]
SONG [inaudible]
BYE [inaudible]
BYE.
DINNER WIENER THERE ARE MORE
LOCK.
HAVE ANY AUTHORS -- I CAN DO
MINE ACTUALLY YEAH HANG ON ONE
SECOND THAT'S RIGHT.
THE CHAIR I'M GONNA GIVE.
I BELIEVE THIS HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
WE ARE NOW LISTENING OUR BBB
PRESENTED ITEM FOURTEEN SB FIVE
SIXTY BY TE WORLD FAMOUS.
SENATOR MIKE MCGUIRE THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A VICE CHAIR IF YOU
ARE LOOKING FOR EXCITING PIECES
LEGISLATION.
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS THE ONE FOR
YOU.
THE WILLIAMSON ACT PROTECTS FROM
DEVELOPMENT IT'S IT REALLY IS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
PIECE OF LEGISLATION INITIALLY
FOR THE WHIMS ACTED PROTECTS
PROXY FIFTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
ACRES OF LAND IN FIFTY TWO
COUNTIES AT FIFTY EIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA.
OVER TIME THE PROGRAM IS CHANGE
BASED ON FEEDBACK FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS BUT THE LAW HAS NOT
ALWAYS CAUGHT UP FROM THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES. ONE SUCH
AREA REGARDS TIMBERLANE WHICH
BEGAN IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
PRIOR TO CENTER MORE LIKE BEING
BORN.
IT MUST BE INCLUDED IN A TEN
MILLION PROTECTION ZONE SAID OF
THE WINGS IN ACT -- IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE PROPERTY TAX BENEFITS SB
FIVE SIXTY REPEALS AN OUTDATED
PROVISIONS STATE LAW THAT
PROVIDES THAT LANDS ZONE IS
TIMBERLANE PRODUCTION COUNTS.
IT COUNTS TOWARDS SOMEONE HATER
MONITOR ACRE MINIMUM SIZE FROM
AGRICULTURE PRESERVE.
IN OF COURSE MISTER VICE CHAIR
WE'RE GONNA BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED TECHNICAL
AMENDMENT TO MAKE IT ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR THAT THIS IS NOT AFFECT
LANDS UNDER EXISTING CONTRACTS.
MEMBERS WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
I SIGH THANK YOU SENATOR.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
ALTHOUGH GAS TO LINE UP IN.
TWO ONE WE'LL GO BACK AND FORTH
UNTIL WERE COMPLETED.
THANK YOU.
BEING A WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS FROM.
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
UNDER WIENER GIVE YOU LEAST
THIRTY MINUTES TO ASK QUESTIONS.
DO I HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
DINNER MCGUIRE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOUR TIMER
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE
LIST PRESSURE.
AND WE'RE IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING
THAT WE'RE TAKING YOUR BILL WITH
AMENDMENTS.
AND I DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
FLOOR THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
WELCOME MADAM.
SECRETARY PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
WIRE HI MY AYE MORE LONG.
RED BELL PEPPER RICARDO NIELSEN
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE. THREE ZERO AND WE
WILL HOLD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
SO MUCH A BRIEF.
INTRODUCTION REALLY APPRECIATED
[inaudible]
GEN.
THE MAN THE MYTH THE LEGEND HERE
NOW WE'RE WELCOME CENTER STERN.
TO COMMITTEE THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN THERE CERTAINLY IS A
GOOD NEWS YOU HAVE BY.
PARTISAN SUPPORT.
IN THIS BILL SO WE'RE GONNA ASK --
THAT YOU PROVIDE US WITH A
TRUNCATED STATEMENT OF THE FLOOR
IS YOURS SIR VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PRESENTING
SB SIX TWO SIX WHICH
REINTRODUCES RECENTLY.
SENSITIVE BUSINESS TAX CREDIT
FOR ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS
WHO ARE CALLED THE SERVICE TO
DEFEND OUR NATION.
IS THE LEAST WE CAN BE DOING TO
HELP THOSE WHO EITHER CEASED
OPERATIONS OR SUFFER SIGNIFICANT
LOSSES TO THEIR SMALL BUSINESS
WHILE THEY'RE DEPLOYED.
DEFENDING THIS.
WE THINK THE EXTENSION MAKES
SENSE.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER STERN WE NOW LIKE TO BE
ABL TO OPEN UP TO ANYONE ELSE
WHO'S IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT.
NOW LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED. TO
PLEASE COME.
FOR SEE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION LOOK AT AT WILL
MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR. THREE
THIS AFTERNOON THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER VICE CHAIR.
THERE SIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANKS FOR THE U. DISHES
CONSIDERATION AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER STERN
THIS HAS A DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS MOTION BY THE
VICE CHAIR.
SCIENTIST ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI.
I'M MORE LONG.
WELL -- ELTON WIENER.
THANK MEMBERS CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
THREE ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN.
MEMBERS GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS
SO WE'RE GONNA BE PASSING OUT
AMENDMENTS WE'RE GONNA BE
PASSING AND AMENDMENTS THE
SENATE BILL
.
SIX FOUR SIX I'M NOT REALLY
WE APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
PATIENCE THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
THE COMEDIAN THANK YOU I
pTHE DELAY.
BUT ISN'T CHEN ON THE COMMITTEE
WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING UP SB
SIX FOUR SIX WAS SENATOR MORALE.
THERE ARE.
AMENDMENTS IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THERE ARE TWO PIECES OF PAPER IN
FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
NOW. ONE IS A SUMMARY A SUMMARY
OF THE AMENDMENTS.
THE SECOND IS -- A LEDGE DIGEST
EXCUSE ME A YEAH LEGISLATIVE
MOCK UP.
OF THE AMENDMENTS IS WELL IN --
SO YOU HAVE BOTH IN FRONT.
THE HIGHLIGHTED PORTION OF THE
MARKUP WE TRY TO MAKE IT AS EASY
AS POSSIBLE FOR YOU.
ARE THE AREAS OF THE MOMENT IN
THE ALSO HAVE THE SUMMARY IN
FRONT OF YOU.
I'M GONNA READ OUT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE IN YOU ALSO HAVE
THESE IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY.
WE'RE ABLE TO COME TO AGREEMENT
I WAS CENTER MORALE THIS MORNING
AFTER SOME BACK AND FORTH AND
I'M GRATEFUL.
GENERAL UP FOR THAT CONVERSATION.
I RETAIN THE FAIR OR RESUME A
RELATIONSHIP REQUIRED IN THE
BILL.
WITH SOME MINOR TECHNICAL
CHANGES STRIKING OUT THE PORTION
THE BILL THAT ADDS A REQUIREMENT
FROM PROPOSITION TWO EIGHTEEN
AND THEN.
STRIKES THE INTENT LANGUAGE AT
THE IN STATING THAT THE INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATURE IS TO APPLY
BOTH PROPOSITIONS TO EIGHTEEN IN
TWENTY SIX THE MITIGATION.
BE ACT I WANT TO SAY AGAIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH IS IN A MORALE UP
FOR UP WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU.
FOR WORKING WITH WITH US ON THIS
BILL.
AND I THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ITS DILIGENT WORK AND AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR FOR THE A
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD OVER THE
LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THESE AMENDMENTS.
SB SIX FORTY SIX PRESENTS A
POLICY.
THAT IS WIDELY.
AGREED UPON IN IS IN THE SAME
SPIRIT OF LANDMARK CALIFORNIA
LAWS ENACTED BY OUR VOTERS.
IN OUR PROPOSITIONS TO EIGHTEEN
AND TWENTY SIX THE POLICY WE ALL
A GENERALLY AGREE ON AND WHEN
VOTERS MANY TIMES TO PROVE THAT
THEY'VE APPROVED. ONE OF FAIR
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT CHARGES
FEES THEY SHOULD BE FAIR AND
REASONABLE AND YOU SOLELY FOR
THE PURPOSES FOR WHICH THEY ARE
CHANGE.
SB SIX FORTY SIX MAKES THIS ONE
SIMPLE CLARIFICATION. TO THE
MITIGATION FEE ACT TO MAKE THAT
POLICY ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
SPECIFICALLY WE ADD.
WE ADDED LANGUAGE TO THE
DEFINITION OF A FEE ESTABLISHED
THAT THE FEE CHARGE MUST BE A
REASONABLE -- RELATIONSHIP TO
THE PAYERS BURDENS OR BENEFITS
RECEIVED FROM THE UTILITY
CONNECTION AND AGAIN YOU'VE GOT
THE AMENDMENTS ON THAT.
WHICH YOU READ MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AFTER THE
PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION TWO
EIGHTEEN AND TO TWENTY AND TO
TWENTY SIX WHICH SOUGHT -- THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE FEES AND
THE TAXES THERE HAVE BEEN
NUMEROUS COURT CASES SEEKING TO
CLARIFY THE EXCEPTION.
THAT PROPOSITION TWENTY SIX
ADDED TO THE LAW FOR FEES
IMPOSED AS A CONDITION OF
PROPERTY DEVELOPMENT.
REGARDLESS OF THE PROP --
CLARIFICATION AS PROVIDED BY OUR
COURTS.
IT'S OUR JOB WHAT YOU'RE DOING
HERE TODAY THE LEGISLATURE'S JOB
TO ENSURE THAT THE LAW IS
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING SO THAT CITIZENS ARE
TREATED FAIRLY.
AND LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE CLEAR
GUIDANCE ON HOW TO ABIDE BY
THESE EXISTING -- ROLES AND SO
WITH ME TODAY YES -- TWO
GENTLEMEN TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE IS NECK --
CAMMARATA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND DAVID WIFE WITH HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION IF
YOU LIKE THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME TO
COMMITTEES FOR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS I'M GONNA MISERABLE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERS AND THE CAMERA WE HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA BILLION
DISASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL I'M.
I WANT.
TO THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT AND THE
AUTHOR STAFF FOR HELPING SHAPE
THIS BILL I THINK IT'S STILL --
IS A VALUABLE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
I ONE OF THE CONCERNS WE
FREQUENTLY HEAR FROM OUR MEMBERS
IS THAT.
THERE'S A IN IN WATER
CONSUMPTION THERE'S A RAPIDLY
CHANGING REGULATORY REGIME.
BOTH -- IN TERMS OF WATER
CONSERVATION INSIDE AND OUTSIDE
THE HOME.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES TO SEE WATER BOARD.
AND JUST BASICALLY WATER FISHING
APPLIANCES.
AND WITH THAT THIS BILL I THINK
WILL HELP FOCUS THE ATTENTION OF
COMPUTING HOW MUCH WATER IS USED
BY A HOME.
BY THE WATER DISTRICTS SO THAT.
FOLKS ARE UNNECESSARILY CHARGE
HIGHER CONNECTION FEES AND
CAPACITY CHARGES.
AND TO THAT END I THINK IT'S
VERY HELPFUL I I AM JUST WANT TO
COVER ALL MY BASES THAT.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL BUT I AM WAS ASKING ME THAT
MESSAGE BUT I BELIEVE THAT
THEY'RE HERE.
AND YOU'LL HEAR FROM THEM IN A
MOMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ATTENDING WERE
NEGATIVE THE FORMER TO MR WOLF
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WILL FOR THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IN MEMBERS WERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL TO THE EXTENT THAT
THIS DOES CAR FI THE DEFINITION
OF FEES AND IN THE MITIGATION
FEE ACT -- BUT WE DO RECOGNIZE
THIS.
IS A WORK IN PROGRESS WE DO VIEW
IT AS A WORK IN PROGRESS AND WE
DO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE --
ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL TO CONTINUE TO
CLARIFY WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE SO
WITH THAT ASK FOR EVER.
I WAS JUST THINKING SO MUCH AS
WELL FOR A GREAT FOR THE HERE WE
NOW WOULD LIKE TO GET OPENING UP
TO ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LOOKING FOR YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME AS WELL AS YOUR
ORGANIZATION WE WELCOME YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
HELLO SCOTT USER REALTOR INLAND
VALLEYS CESSATION OF REALTORS
AND SUPPORT THINKING SKIS -- A
GOOD AFTERNOON AFTERNOON VICKI
CARPENTER CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH RETURNING TODAY GOOD
AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON PATRICIA HEX
MEMBER THE REALTOR ASSOCIATION
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR SIX GOOD AFTERNOON MICHAEL
STAFFEL REALTOR IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR TUNING
GOOD AFTERNOON THE SEMINARS
REALTOR IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON AFTERNOON
MARKET WORDS REALTORS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN FAVOR
BREAK GRATEFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU TO DO A LAST CALL FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO GET A LOOK
TO ANYONE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FOR THIS
TIME LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO ARE
OPPOSED.
WE'RE GOING TO A LAST CALL FOR
THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED.
YOU LIKE E TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE WE ALSO
WELCOME A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AS AMENDED BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GENERAL AGAIN THANK YOU FOR ALL
OF YOU WORK WITH THIS GRATEFUL --
FOR THE ABILITY TO WORK WITH YOU.
TOMORROW WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE A
CLOSER I WOULD.
YEAH I I I I LIKE THIS SO YOU
KNOW WE WE WANT TO DO A LITTLE
STEPS THEN -- TO MAKE THINGS
BETTER AND EASIER FOR BUILDERS
THE BILL SO EVENTUALLY PEOPLE
CAN.
GET IN THE HOMES AND SO THAT'S
WHY THERE NEEDS TO BE
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE SOME OF
OUR DEALERS HAVE BEEN BEAT UP
AND THERE'S IT'S NOT.
CLEAR ON WHAT SOME OF THE CITIES
AND THEY VERY FROM VERY AND
AGAIN THAT LONG IN GAME THAT WE
WANT TO DO IS TO GET. ONE HOMES
BECAUSE OF THE HOUSING CRISIS SO
AGAIN THIS IS A SMALL STEP --
BUT I THINK IN THE LONG RUN.
IT WILL AS WE PUT PIECES
TOGETHER OF THE PUZZLE IT'LL
LEAD TOWARD JOHN MORE HOUSING IN
BETTER UNDERSTANDING ON BILLERS
CAN DO AND HOPEFULLY BRING DOWN
SOME COSTS TO MAKE THINGS MORE
AFFORDABLE.
SO WITH THAT AGAIN THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR TIME AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER SENATOR
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THAT MOTION
AS AMENDED DO PASS TO THE FLOOR.
THIS PLANE CHESTER.
PROCOL PLEASE WIRE HI FLYER ALL
RIGHT [inaudible] FOR ONE WELL I
GOT DOWN.
HERTZBERG HI.
GUYS AUTO [inaudible]
I WIENER.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR IS ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN LAYS IN GERMAN THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER.
THANKS FOR COMING DOWN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE MOVING ON TO SEND TO
YOUR SENATOR HURT SEAT CENTER
HERTZ HE'S GONNA BE PRESENTING
SB
[inaudible]
SIXTY THREE TENER HERTZBERG.
SB SIXTY THREE HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR
TRUNCATED VERSION OF THE
PRESENTATION THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR AND BY THE WAY.
DINNER TACO I I THINK YOU HAVE A
VERY SPECIAL ANNOUNCEMENT AT
TODAY FOR SENATOR HERTZBERG
ABOUT THE RECOGNITION THESE CAN
RECEIVE TODAY.
YOU TODAY EARNED V. RICARDO LARA
WARD AT GENDER RICARDO LARA WARS --
IN IF YOU ARE A NEW COMMITTEE
IT'S THE INDIVIDUAL WHO IS THE
LATEST -- THAT KIND OF A HEARING
COMMITTEE AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN ONE MORE TIME WHO IS
IT CENTER TITLE.
THE HONORABLE SENATOR HURTS FOR
ONE MORE ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I THANK YOU FOR BLESSING US WITH
YOUR PRESENCE -- AT THE FLOOR IS
YOURS I RESPECT THAT -- OF SOME
RICHARD THIS COMMITTEE FOR TWO
YEARS -- WITH CENTER LARA ON THE
COMMITTEE I HAVE GREAT REGARD
FOR THAT AWARD AND THE I
WOULDN'T SAY I WEAR WITH A BADGE
OF HONOR BUT I WEAR IT.
SO VERY BRIEFLY I ACTUALLY I AT
MY I LOST MY WITNESS -- IS THE
DAY THAT AS THE DAY DRAGGED ON
AND DID NOT ASK HIM TO STICK
AROUND BECAUSE OF THE THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BUT BASICALLY
IN A NUTSHELL.
EDUCATION CORPORATION FOR
AMERICA DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ARE CLOSED ITS DOORS AT
BRIGHT WOULD COLLEGE IN MY
DISTRICT STUDENTS HAD NO WARNING.
BOMBS AND WE'RE STOCK RIGHT
THINK ABOUT THAT RIGHT YOU'RE IN
A SITUATION WHERE YOUR SCHOOL
DOOR CLOSES YOU'RE STUCK WITH
YOUR LOANS.
UNDER THE FEDERAL LAW STUDENTS
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL LOAN
FORGIVENESS THAT.
ON TREATMENT DOES NOT APPLY AT
THE STATE LEVEL THIS MEASURE
SIMPLY ASKS UNLIKE THE WOULD
SIMPLY LIMIT REACHED RIGHT THOSE
WORDS THIS MEASURE.
ASK THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
TREAT -- THE TAX TREATMENT SO
THERE'S NOT TAXABLE CONSEQUENCES
TO THE STUDENTS -- IF THERE IF
THERE'S FORGIVENESS FOR THEIR
LOANS A WE DID THIS IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN AT THIS
COMMITTEE.
WITH CORINTHIAN COLLEGES SO WE
HAVE A PRESIDENT.
AND ON THE SEA THE CALIFORNIA
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD ESTIMATES
GENERAL FUND DECREASE AS A
RESULT OF THIS MEASURE TO BE ONE
POINT TWO FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AS FOR NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER HURTS.
FOR WOULD LIKE TO SEE THOSE WHO
MAY BE IN SUPPORT IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
ASK OFFER SUPPORT WE NOW WOULD
LIKE TO GET A LOOK. TO THOSE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSED IF YU COULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
LAST CALL THANK YOU BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTHER WE HAVE A
MOTION FOURTH TIME -- HERE THIS
AFTERNOON THINK SO MUCH MISTER
VICE CHAIR.
HEY THERE.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR
CENTER HERTZBERG WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE AT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY THE VICE
CHAIR THIS IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MISSING CHESTER
PROCOL PLEASE.
HI WHY I'M MORE LONG.
A LOT FIVE BELL.
HI NIELSEN WIENER.
THAT ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO VOTE
THANK YOU THE ROLE OPEN.
NOW SENATOR BELL CENTRE BELL IS
OUR LAST BILL OF THE DAY.
WE AE A HUNTIN THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM SAN JOSE DOWN -- BUT WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO IS
START ADDING PEOPLE ON SO LET'S
START GOING TO THE ROLE GIVE US
ONE MINUTE AND WILL SER GET
ORGANIZED.
OF THE TODAY'S CANDIES.
CAN YOU STASHED IS.
THE FUNKY IT'S OUT WE GOT BREAST
MEN'S IN BLOW POPS SO -- A NODE
CHOCOLATE AND I DO APOLOGIZE
THINKERS BARS THE IDEA SNICKERS.
HE GET ME EARLY THERE WE GO.
YEAH EXACTLY.
ALL MY GOSH.
HEY ALL RIGHT SO LADIES IN
GENERAL WE ARE GOING TO START
WITH OUR CONSENT CALENDAR AND
WE'RE GONNA WORK TO FILE
STARTING AT ONE AND THE WORK OUR
WAY DOWN.
SO LADIES AND GENTLEMAN ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE ITEM
SEVEN IN SEVENTEEN ITEMS SEVEN
IN SEVENTEEN CURRENT VOTE IS SIX
ZERO MISSILE AND JUST A ROLL
CALL PLEASE.
HI. SEVEN ZERO WE'RE GONNA CLOSE
THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
OKAY INSANE COUNTER IS OUT.
WE'RE GONNA SKIP ITEM ONE SINCE
WE JUST VOTED ON IT AND SENATOR
HERTZBERG WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
THREE SB TWO FORTY EIGHT THIS IS
A DO PASSED YOUR PREPARATIONS
MOTION CURRENT VOTERS FOUR ZERO
MISS LANCASTER.
OR A LOT [inaudible]
I'VE HEARD [inaudible] SIX ZERO
THAT IS THE SIX ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WERE CLOSE IN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB TWO FIFTY
TWO THIS IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED
YOUR PREPARATIONS MOTION.
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO
MISSILE INTEREST [inaudible]
AUTO. SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT WERE CLOSE IN THE ROLE.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE IS TO TWO SIXTY THREE KERN
VOTE IS FIVE ZERO DO PASTOR
PERFORATIONS MOTION MISSING
CHESTER.
HI.-I DON'T -- I SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE [inaudible]
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible] SIX OLD.
ITEM WE HAVE SKEWS ME I
APOLOGIZE PULL.
AND CONCERN ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
THREE FORTY NINE CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO DO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
IS THE MOTION IS LANCASTER
[inaudible]
HELLO. SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSE IN THE ROLE --
REMEMBER IT'S GONNA ADD SOME
FOLKS ON REAL QUICK IN THE
MORNING COME STRAIGHT TO CENTER
BELL.
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB THREE FIFTY FIVE THIS IS
A DO PASSED TO AMENDED TO THE
FLOOR MOTION KERN VOTERS FIVE
ZERO MISS LANE CHESTER.
BURKE BY.
AUTO. SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE.
MOVING ON ITEM TENNIS BEFORE TO
TO DO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS MOTION KERN VOTE
IS FIVE ZERO MISS LANE CHESTER
[inaudible]
BURKE.
FINAL VOTE IS.
SIX ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT FOR
CLOSING THE ROLE.
MOVING ON NOW TO ITEM ELEVEN SB
FOUR SIX EIGHT CURRENT VOTE IS.
THREE ZERO TWO PASSES AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS MISALIGNED
CHESTER.
BURKE OTHERS AMENDED RIGHT YES
[inaudible]
AYE AUTO.
HELLO I WIENER.
THIS ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO VOTE FOR
KEEPING THE ROLE OPEN.
I AND THAT IS AMENDED IS WELL
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE SP.
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A TWO ZERO VOTE HAS A DO
PASSES A MINUTE APPROPRIATIONS
MOTION IS LANCASTER [inaudible]
AYE AUTO -- I NIELSEN WIENER.
FOUR ZERO VOTE.
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE --
PAIN AND ITEM NUMBER TWELVE ARE
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM THIRTEEN
SB FIVE TWENTY ONE CURRENTLY
ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO VOTE DO
PASSES A MINUTE APPROPRIATIONS
MOTION MISSING CHESTER.
BURKE.
THE GUY -- SIX ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT WERE CLOSE IN THE ROLE.
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM FOURTEEN
SB FIVE SIXTY CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
THREE ZERO VOTE.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR
MOTION MISSING JUST YELL.
WELL I BURKE ON AUTO
[inaudible]
NIELSEN. SIX ZERO WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN AND ALLOW
CENTER NIELSEN TO BE -- TO ADD
ON WE'RE NOT GONNA AT MOVED TO
ITEM SIX TWENTY FOUR THIS BILL
IS AMENDED DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS. THREE ZERO
MINUTES LANCHESTER AL
[inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I SIX ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR CENTER NIELSEN.
MOVING ON TO ITEM SIXTEEN SB SIX
TWENTY SIX CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
THREE ZERO VOTE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS MISS
LANCASTER.
ALL RIGHT BURKE.
ALL RIGHT AUTO.
HELLO I NIELSEN. SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT
WERE CLOSE IN THE ROLE.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM
EIGHTEEN SB SIX THIRTY FIVE DO
PASTOR PREPARATIONS IS THE
MOTION CURRENT VOTE IS THREE
ZERO MISS LANCASTER.
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THIS ROLE OPEN
FOR A BIT LONGER.
WHAT WE ARE WE'RE GONNA START
OVER ON ITEM EIGHTEEN SB SIX
THIRTY FIVE CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
THREE ZERO VOTE MISSING CHESTER?
OR R..
OR LAW I BIRTH.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THAT IS A
FOUR ZERO VOTE ON ITEM EIGHTEEN
THAT BILL IS OUT WERE CLOSE IN
THE ROLE.
THIS BILL IT HAS BEEN AMENDED
ITEM NINETEEN AMENDMENTS ARE IN
FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE.
ITEM.
SIX FOUR SIX THIS HAS A MOTION
DO PASSES AMENDED TO THE FLOOR
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO THE
SAME CHESTER L. [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI WIENER [inaudible] FIVE ZERO
WIENER.
REALLY ENJOYS A SIX ZERO VOTE
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THAT ROLE OPEN
FOR CENTER WIENER ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SB SEVEN SIXTY THREE THIS
AS A DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
MOTION.
CURRENT VOTE IS. THREE ZERO
MISSING CHESTER.
L. L. I. HERTZBERG [inaudible]
AUTO.
HELLO I NIELSEN. SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
FIND THE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE
SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE THIS IS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ZERO THIS SAME CHESTER.
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
AUTO -- IDEALS [inaudible]
HI WIENER. SIX ZERO WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR CENTER
WIENER.
SIX ZERO KEEP THE ROLE OPEN IN
THE FIND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE
ARE GRATEFUL THAT THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE'S HERE.
ON SB ONE NINETY SIX CENTER
VALUE OF BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE
CAN GET A TRUNCATED VERSION OF
THE PRESENTATION THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST WITH THEIR PROPERTY
TAX EXEMPTION FROM THE POINT.
WHERE THE PROPERTIES ACQUIRED TO
THE POINT OF SALE OF THE
AFFORDABLE HOMES IT'S A PERIOD
OF TIME WELL THE CONSTRUCTIONS
HAPPENING?
AFTER THE NONPROFIT CORPORATION
BUYS THE PROPERTY AND THE HOUSES
ARE BUILT ARJUN AYE VOTE ON THE
SYSTEM BY HOUSING.
OF FOR THE LAND TRUST -- TO LAND
SITES FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE BILL.
THE MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
SENATOR HER T. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YEAH THAT'S RIGHT THE AT THE
AWARD WINNER AND TODAY THEY WARD
WINNER.
SIR WELCOME TO COMMITTEE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU DO A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PAUL GONZALEZ HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE IRVINE
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST.
JUST IT JUST OF A QUICK -- ADD
ON WINCHESTER TYPICALLY LOCATE
HIGH COST AREAS WHERE THE LAND
VALUES ARE EXTREMELY HIGH --
HAVING THIS WELFARE EXEMPTION
WATCH WE ALLOW THEM TO BUILD
MORE AFFORDABLE UNITS PER
PROJECTS SO WITH THAT WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
IS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
TURN IT OVER TO THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT YOU CAN PLEASE COME
FORWARD SIR THANK YOU.
SO MUCH RUNNING WITH US TODAY.
I A SEVENTY AYE A WITH WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS USA REPRESENTING
SILICON VALLEY RISING AS WELL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME BACK.
LOUIS MANDE WITH CALIFORNIA BE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH LUIS.
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD.
LAST CALL.
NOW WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME ANYONE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSED.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE TO BE
TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A A THE MOTION BY
SENATOR HURTING.
THERE WERE GO.
I SEE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTER ABOUT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BE A CLOSE.
HE THAT'S AS CLOSE HE'S GOOD TO
GO LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SAYS
THEY DO PASS AS AMENDED O
PREPARATIONS MOTION BY SYNERGY.
IS IN CHESTER ROCKALL PLEASE
WIRE I FIND MORE LONG.
WELL LIKE I BELT.
WELL I HEARD.
HELLO I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I WIENER.
THAT IS A SIX ZERO VOTE SIX ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PLAYED.
A WE'RE GOING TO THE COMMITTEE
CALL VOTE ON WE CAO SKIS BILLS
THAT STILL THAT'S THAT WAS OPEN
SO [inaudible] TWELVE WE HAVE
WE'RE GONNA AT THE GO THROUGH
ROLL AGAIN FOR SENATOR NIELSEN
BECAUSE WE HAVE A FEW THAT WE
SORT OF CONFIRM WITH YOU.
IF YOU CAN JUST GIVE IS ONE
MINUTE WE'RE GONNA A COORDINATE
HERE WILL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU
[inaudible] ELEVEN OPEN
[inaudible]
I
TWELVE BUT IN GENERAL WE'RE
GONNA BE GONE CALLING TO THE
ROLE THANK YOU SO MUCH AND TO
THE PATIENTS OF BOTH.
TENER BALANCER NIELSEN WERE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER ONE
KERN VOTE IS FOUR ZERO HAS A
MOTION TO DO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
MISS LANE CHESTER.
WELL.
WELL I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I SIX ZERO THAT.
I WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT ROLE
OPEN FOR SENATOR WINNER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE MAY HAVE A
TIE FOR THE SENATE ALLOW AWARD
TODAY.
GIVE US ONE MORE MINUTE LET'S
FIGURE OUT WHICH BILLS WE NEED
TO ADD CENTER NIELSEN ON AND
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU
[inaudible] FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
THANK [inaudible]
NO.
THERE NIELSEN WE ARE GOING TO GO
OVER TO WELL ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE ITEM NUMBER.
FOURTEEN AN ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
FIFTEEN ALL RIGHT.
LET'S START WITH ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE SB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN DO
PASS AS AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS
KERN VOTERS FOUR ZERO MISSING
CHESTER [inaudible]
I FIVE ZERO BERNIE KEEP THAT
ROLE OPEN.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB FIVE
SIXTY THIS IS A DO PASSES
AMENDED TO THE FLOOR CURRENT
VOTE IS SIX ZERO MISSING CHESTER
NIELSEN. SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSE IN THE ROOM.
FINAL ITEM.
FOR SENATOR NIELSEN THIS IS --
SB SIX TWENTY FOUR ITEM FIFTEEN
DO PASSES AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT LOTUS SIX ZERO MISS LANE
CHESTER. SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSE IN THE ROLE.
THERE NIELSEN THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOU'RE CAUGHT UP.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING IN.
A TEN MINUTE RECESS.
TENET RECESS AND WE'LL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU
APPROPRIATE AWARDED CENTER
HERTZBERG GOOD THE WAR TODAY SO --
HE'S VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB.
SIXTY THREE CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
SIX YEAR VOTE DO PASSED TO
PREPARATIONS MOTION SAYING
CHESTER WIENER.
WE ARE AYE. SEVEN SEVEN ZERO
WERE CLOSING THE ROLE THAT BILL
IS OUT. FOR NOW MOVING ON SB ONE
NINETY SIX DO PASSES THE MANAGER
PREPARATIONS.
THIS CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX ZERO
VOTE MISS LANCASTER.
WE ARE ALL RIGHT. SEVEN ZERO
VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT WILL CLOSE
IN THE ROLE.
WE NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN HAS
BEEN AMENDED THIS IS ITEM.
ITEM ELEVEN SP FOUR SIX YOU DO
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FIVE ZERO
VOTE MISSING CHESTER WIENER. SIX
ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT
RECALLS A BALL ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE THIS ITEM IS AMENDED AS
BEFORE.
SEVEN SEVEN CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
ZERO MISSING GESTURE WIENER.
WE ARE ALL RIGHT. SIX ZERO VOTE
THIS BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING
THE ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN SB SIX FOUR
SIX AND WIENER YOU DO HAVE A
MOMENT IN FRONT OF YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible] FORTY YEAH.
ALL RIGHT.
I AM NINETEEN WITH AMENDMENTS
THIS IS A DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE FLOOR MOTION CURRENT VOTE IS
SIX ZERO MISS LANCASTER. SEVEN
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT OF COURSE
THE ROLE THEN FINALLY CENTER
WINNER ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE SB.
SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE THIS IS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO PREPARATIONS
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A SIX YEAR VOTE
CENTRIST WIENER.
WE ARE ALL RIGHT. SEVEN ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT FOR CLOSING THE
ROLE LADIES AND GENTLEMAN OUR
NEXT HEARING IS GOING TO BE ON
JUNE FIFTH JUNE FIFTH.
WHERE THE SMALL MATTER OF BILLS
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE COMING?
FOR THANK YOU SO MUCH HAVE A
GREAT REST AFTERNOON WE'RE JR